GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN I AM
CALLING THIS HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO
ORDER -- WILL SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM.
O'DONNELL HERE O'DONNELL HERE
KILEY.
KALRA.
KALRA HERE MCCARTY.
SMITH SMITH HERE WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER HERE.
THE COURT HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED
AND I'D LIKE TO WELCOME THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THE PUBLIC
TO TODAY'S HEARING -- WE HAVE
TWENTY EIGHT BILLS ON FILES
TODAY INCLUDING FIVE ON CONSENT.
THE MEASURES ON CONSENT ARE AS
FOLLOWS AB FIVE TWO FIVE A. B.
FIVE FOUR THREE WITH AMENDMENTS
EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY NINE EIGHT
EIGHT WITH A MOMENTS.
AB TEN EIGHTY ONE A. B. TEN
EIGHTY FIVE THE AUTHORS AGREED
TO AMENDMENTS WHICH WILL BE
PROCESSED IN THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE.
THOSE FIVE BILLS ARE ON CONSENT
ONE MEASURE EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY
SIX HAS BEEN POR SIXTY EIGHT HAS
BEEN PULLED FROM THE HEARING
AGENDA.
I WOULD LIKE TO REMIND THE
AUTHORS THAT THERE SHOULD BE
ONLY TWO MAIN WITNESSES THAT'S
TO IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
SPEAKING FOR MORE NOTE FROM FOR
NO MORE THAN TWO MINUTES SO TWO
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES -- EACH.
ALL OTHER SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
A LINE OF THE MICROPHONE TO
STATE THEIR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY THAT'S
ONLY IF -- GIVE ME OF YOU WE MAY
I HAVE.
YOU MAY BE MORE IF YOU'VE HAD
MADE.
ARRANGEMENTS WITH THE COMMITTEE
STAFF PRIOR TO TODAY'S HEARING
BUT AGAIN ONLY TO AND TO WITH
THAT WE ARE READY TO HEAR FROM
OUR FIRST AUTHOR WHICH IS.
ME SO I'M GOING TO TURN IT OVER.
TO MISS SMITH WHO'S GONNA BE OUR
VICE CHAIR.
JUST WAS SWORN IN RIGHT NOW
[inaudible]
TIME RECORD [inaudible]
THANK YOU
.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER
AUTHOR YOU MAY PRESENT WHEN
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB SEVEN FIVE ONE IS THE
REINTRODUCTION OF AB NINETEEN
FIFTY ONE FROM LAST YEAR.
WHICH RECEIVED NO NO VOTES.
IN THE LEGISLATURE.
THIS BILL WILL INCREASE THE
PATHWAY TO COLLEGE BY PROVIDING
ELEVENTH GRADE STUDENTS ACCESS
TO REQUIRED COLLEGE ENTRANCE
EXAM.
CERTAINLY.
STUDENTS IN GRADE THIRD THROUGH
EIGHTH AND THEN ELEVENTH ARE
REQUIRED TO TAKE THE SMARTER
BALANCED ASSESSMENT TESTS THAT
AGAIN IS THE STATEWIDE REQUIRED
TEST.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO ADMINISTER AN
ENTRANCE EXAM SUCH AS THE ACT.
SAT INSTEAD OF THE STATE
REQUIRED -- REQUIREMENTS TO THE
STATE REQUIRED ASSESSMENT FOR
ELEVENTH GRADE.
THE ALTERNATIVE ASSESSMENT WILL
BE OFFERED DURING THE SCHOOL DAY
AT NO COST TO STUDENTS.
IT BUILDS IT INTO THE SCHOOL
THAT BUILDS IN AS PART OF THE
SCHOOL CULTURE BUILDS IN A
CULTURE OF COLLEGE GOING.
THIS BILL REQUIRES THE
ASSESSMENT TO BE ALIGNED TO THE
STATE STANDARDS MEET FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS AND ENSURE THAT A
COMMA ACCOMMODATIONS ARE
PROVIDED.
OUR FROM OUR PROVIDED A
STUDENT'S I EP OR MAYBE.
FIVE OH FOR NEARLY FORTY FIVE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS INCLUDING
OAKLAND SAN JOSE LOS ANGELES
SACRAMENTO AND LONG BEACH AND
MANY OTHERS AGAIN.
ARE CURRENTLY OFFERING THE SAT
OR THE ACT DURING THE SCHOOL DAY
FOR FREE IN AN EFFORT TO
INCREASE.
THE COLLEGE ATTENDANCE RATE.
THIS BILL IS GOOD FOR STUDENTS
TEACHERS AND PARENTS.
AND ULTIMATELY CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL WILL REDUCE THE AMOUNT
OF TESTING I GIVE STUDENTS AND
TEACHERS MORE TIME FOR
INSTRUCTION.
STUDENTS TAKE THE SAT OR ACT
SERIOUSLY BECAUSE IT IS
MEANINGFUL TO THEM.
THE SAT IS MORE USEFUL TO
TEACHERS.
THE SMARTER BALANCED ASSESSMENT
THAT'S THE ASPECT IS A TEST.
THE SAT IS AN ASSESSMENT THOSE
ARE VERY DIFFERENT WHAT IS A
TEST WILL ATTEST IS TYPICALLY A
SUMMATIVE EVENT THAT YOU GIVE AT
THE END OF THE YEAR OR THE END
OF THE END OF A UNIT.
AND THAT WILL TELL YOU HOW THE
STUDENT DID AT THE END OF THE
UNIT BUT ASSESSMENTS TELL YOU
WHAT HAPPENS IN BETWEEN.
WITH THE S. C. TEAR THE ACTU
GIVEN THE EIGHTH NINTH TENTH AND
ULTIMATELY THE FINAL TEST ON THE
ELEVENTH AND WHAT YOU DO IN
THOSE INTRAMUROS.
IS YOU SEEK TO ADDRESS THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS THAT YOU FIND --
AS YOU TEST ALONG THE WAY.
AND THAT'S A CLASSROOM TEACHER
ME I'M A FIRM BELIEVER THAT
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO BE MOVED TO
MORE ASSESSMENT SYSTEM THAT JUST
A TESTING SYSTEM.
THE ASPECT IS A TESTING SYSTEM
NOT AN ASSESSMENT SYSTEM
ASSESSMENTS AGAIN TELL YOU HOW
STUDENTS ARE DOING ALONG THE WAY
SO YOU A MONITOR AND A DRESSER
PROGRESS.
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR OR THEIR
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE.
THERE ARE ONLY SEVEN STATES THAT
USE THE S. BACK FOR THE ELEVENTH
GRADE ASSESSMENT WELL TWENTY
FIVE STATES TO THE SAT.
OR THE ACT.
THE CURRENT SCANDAL MAKES THE
CASE FOR S. B. I'M SORRY THE
CURRENT SCANDAL MAKES THE CASE
FOR AB.
FIFTY ONE BY ENSURING THAT ALL
STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO TEST
PREPARATION.
AND THE TEST IS ADMINISTERED IN
A SAFE AND SECURE ENVIRONMENT
WITH PROTOCOLS PROFESSIONALS.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT EQUITY AND
OPPORTUNITY.
AND WITH ME HERE TODAY ARE
DOCTOR RUTH PRECIOUS
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE PARAMOUNT.
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND SHE
WILL NOW TESTIFIED.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AS THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JUST STATED MY NAME IS
DOCTOR RUTH FOR US ON THE
SUPERINTENDENT AND THE PARAMOUNT
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
WE HAVE A LITTLE OVER FIFTEEN
THOUSAND STUDENTS IN OUR
DISTRICT -- AND TODAY WAS SAT
DAY -- IN PARAMOUNT THIS IS OUR
THIRD ANNUAL YEAR WHERE BECAUSE
OF OUR CONCENTRATION FUNDS WE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO PROVIDE OUR
STUDENTS WITH FREE ACCESS AND
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE THE SAT.
WE ARE A DISTRICT WHERE 94% OF
OUR STUDENTS ARE ARE FINANCIALLY
CHALLENGED 35% OF OUR STUDENTS
ARE ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS WE
STRIVE TO PROVIDE OUR STUDENTS
EVERY OPPORTUNITY DURING THE
SCHOOL DAY. TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS
TOOLS THAT WILL HELP THEM IN OUR
ENDEAVORS TO PROVIDE COLLEGE AND
CAREER READINESS FOR OUR
STUDENTS.
SO TODAY ALL OF OUR ELEVENTH
GRADERS TOOK THE SAT WITH THE
TEACHER THAT IS IS AT THAT KNOWS
THEM IN AN ENVIRONMENT THAT IS
SUPPORTIVE WE ALSO OFFER THE PSA
T. THIRTY YEAR DOING THAT SINCE
EIGHTH GRADE.
WE OFFER KAPLAN SERVICES -- FOR
OUR STUDENTS PREPARING THEM FOR
THE EXAM AS WELL AS FREE -- AP
EXAMS AT FOUR FOR OUR STUDENTS
OUT WE DO THIS BECAUSE OF WHO WE
ARE AND WHERE WE ARE AND BECAUSE
WE WANT OUR STUDENTS TO BE ABLE
TO ACCESS THESE TOOLS --
OTHERWISE IN OUR DISTRICT NOT
ALL STUDENTS WILL BE ABLE TO
ACCESS THEM THEY CANNOT AFFORD
IT -- BUT TODAY A 100% OF ALL
OUR STUDENTS HAD AND WE'RE
SENDING A MESSAGE TO OUR
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES BY
PROVIDING THIS THAT.
YOU KNOW SEIZE UP WHETHER YOU
CAN THAT COLLEGE IS DEFINITELY
SOMETHING THAT IS ATTAINABLE FOR
ALL OF OUR STUDENTS.
AS A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS WHO ALSO
COSPONSORED THIS BILL I'D LIKE
TO SHARE WITH YOU THAT -- ALL OF
OUR ON BEHALF OF US WE ARE ALL
IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN FIFTY ONE
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS ACROSS THE
STATE.
ARE SUPPORTED BECAUSE IT
ADDRESSES THE COLLEGE DIPLOMA
GAP BY OPENING DOORS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION FOR STUDENTS THROUGH
OFFERING THESE TESTS DURING THE
DAY AND THAT NO COST TO STUDENTS.
IF MORE STUDENTS ARE ABLE TO
TAKE A COLLEGE ADMISSIONS TEST
MORE UNDER REPRESENTED STUDENTS
CAN BE CONNECTED DIRECTLY TO
SCHOLARSHIPS.
FREE PERSONALIZED TEST PRACTICE
TOOLS AND COLLEGE APPLICATION
FEE WAIVERS REMOVING THEIR
HISTORIC BARRIER STOP TO COLLEGE
EDUCATION.
THIS LEGISLATION WOULD TRULY
HELP TO REDUCE BARRIERS AND
EXPAND OPPORTUNITIES NOT JUST
FOR PARAMOUNT HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS THAT ARE ABLE TO HAVE
THE SUPPORT FOR FOR ALL HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE REALITY THAT WE'RE LIVING IN
NOW IS THE FACT THAT THE SAT IS
A USE FOR COLLEGE ADMISSIONS FOR
ENTRANCE INTO COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL ALSO ENSURES THAT
STUDENTS WITH EXCEPTIONAL NEEDS
ARE APPROPRIATELY ACCOMMODATED
EQUALLY IMPORTANT THE BILL
REQUIRES ENGLISH LEARNERS TO BE
PROVIDED.
APPROPRIATE ACCOMMODATIONS
INCLUDING ACCESS TO TESTING
INSTRUCTIONS AND THEIR PRIMARY
LANGUAGE THAT'S 35% OF OUR
POPULATION AND CONSISTENT WITH
ONE OF THE PRIMARY TENANTS OF
LOCAL CONTROL.
THE BILL OFFERS THE CHOICE FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICT TO DISCUSS THIS
AT THE GOVERNING BOARD LEVEL AND
DECIDE WHAT THEY WANT TO PROVIDE
THEIR STUDENTS -- PLEASE KEEP IN
MIND THAT THIS INSURANCE THIS
CONVERSATION THIS BILL INSURANCE
A CONVERSATION HAPPENS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL WHICH WE GREATLY
APPRECIATED.
THE VALUE OF THIS CHOICE HAS
BEEN RECOGNIZED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WHICH NOW GIVE STATES
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HELP ADDRESS
THE DIPLOMA GAP.
GIVING ALL STUDENTS EASIER
ACCESS TO COLLEGE ADMISSIONS
TEST.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SHARE MY PERSPECTIVE WITH YOU
FOR THIS REASON WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE PATHWAYS TO
COLLEGE ACT.
THANK YOU KNOW MEGAN KERR FROM
THE LONG BEACH UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT SHE IS A BOARD MEMBER.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS MEGAN KERR I'M ON THE
BOARD OF EDUCATION FOR THE LONG
BEACH UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT A
MEMBER OF CSPA WHICH IS CO
SPONSORING THIS BILL.
AND THE CURRENT MOM OF THREE
COLLEGE KIDS -- FOR US IN LONG
BEACH UNIFIED THIS IS A JUSTICE
ISSUE THIS IS ABOUT EQUITY AND
ACCESS FOR ALL STUDENTS. TWO
THIRDS OF OUR FAMILIES ARE
UNABLE TO AFFORD.
SCHOOL MEALS A FREE ESSAY T.
OPENS UP OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THOUSANDS MORE STUDENTS WHO MAY
HAVE NOT PREVIOUSLY CONSIDERED
THEMSELVES TO BE COLLEGE
MATERIAL.
TODAY IS ALSO SAT DAY IN LONG
BEACH UNIFIED SO FIFTY FOUR
HUNDRED JUNIORS ARE TAKING THE
TEST IN LONG BEACH UNIFIED TODAY.
OUT IN A SUPPORTIVE SETTING IN A
SAFE SETTING I SAW ON TWITTER
YESTERDAY THEY EVEN TEACHERS
LEAVING POSTED NOTES ON KIDS
DESK THINKER AGING THEM THAT
THEY'VE GOT THIS IN THIS
IMPORTANT AND THEY'RE THEY'RE
BEING SUPPORTED.
AND THAT'S CRITICAL AS THEY WALK
INTO A ROOM AND THEY'RE NERVOUS --
THE NERVOUS IS IS DECREASE FOR
STUDENTS BECAUSE WE OFFER THE PS
EIGHTY STARTING IN EIGHTH GRADE
EIGHTH GRADE NINTH GRADE AND
TENTH GRADE WHICH ALLOWS US TO
DO THAT ASSESSMENT WORK THAT THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WAS SPEAKING OF
SO CRITICALLY IT ISN'T I'M A
POINT IN TIME TEST.
IT'S REALLY WORKING WITH
STUDENTS TO MOVE THOSE SKILLS AS
THEY GO THROUGH THE YEARS.
DURING THE TIME LIMIT UNIFIED
HAS OFFERED THE SAT FOR FREE
WE'VE SEEN SIGNIFICANT INCREASES
IN THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
MEETING THE MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS
FOR THE CSU SYSTEM.
AT THE SAME TIME OUR GRADUATION
RATE HAS INCREASED FOR THE SIXTH
YEAR IN A ROW.
MORE OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
COMPLETING A THREE G. COURSEWORK
REQUIRED FOR ADMISSION TO BOTH
THE CSU AND YOU SEE SYSTEMS.
WE'VE ALSO SEEN A BIG INCREASE
IN THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
PASSING ADVANCED PLACEMENT EXAMS
FOR COLLEGE CREDIT.
AS A SUPPORT WE OFFER FREE SAT
PREPARATION PEER TUTORING AND
MULTIPLE SITE LEVEL
INTERVENTIONS TO SUPPORT
STUDENTS IN THEIR SAT PREP.
OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH THE KHAN
ACADEMY ALLOWS STARTING IN
EIGHTH GRADE WITH VERY
SPECIALIZED INDIVIDUALIZED --
SUPPORT. FOR AREAS OF WEAKNESS
SO WHEN MY DAUGHTER TOOK THE PSA
T..
SHE FOUND THE SPECIFIC AREAS
THAT SHE NEEDED TO WORK ON TO
IMPROVE FOR THE NEXT TIME AND
REALIZE SHE WAS REALLY STRONG IN
SOME AREAS AND DIDN'T NEED TO
SPEND AS MUCH TIME DOING PREP
WORK -- SO IT'S NOT A BLANKET
SUPPORT INDIVIDUALIZED SUPPORT.
FOR STUDENTS TO BE ABLE TO
REALLY DO THEIR BEST WORK.
I THINK WE OWE OUR STUDENTS
ESPECIALLY OUR STUDENTS OF UNDER
REPRESENTED POPULATIONS THESE
GREAT OPPORTUNITIES TO PREPARE
FOR SUCCESS IN LIFE AND IN
COLLEGE WE KNOW THAT FOR MANY OF
OUR STUDENTS THEY DON'T CONSIDER.
COLLEGE SOMETIME IS AN OPTION
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT THE FEES
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT WHETHER
IT'S APPLICATION FEES TUITION --
ARE A BURDEN ON THEIR FAMILY SO
WE HAVE STUDENTS THAT ARE
WORKING TO SUPPORT THEIR
FAMILIES SO BY GIVING THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE THIS TEST
DURING THE REGULAR SCHOOL DAY AS
PART OF THEIR SCHOOL CULTURE.
IT OPENS THEM UP TO FEED THEIR
OPPORTUNITIES TO SCHOLARSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE VERY SAT
SPECIFIC -- WE KNOW THAT GIVING
KIDS THE OPPORTUNITY THAT THEY
WILL MEET OUR EXPECTATIONS WE
HAVE HIGH EXPECTATIONS AND WE
SUPPORT THEM IN BEING ABLE TO
MEET THEM.
THIS IS AGAIN ABOUT LOCAL
CONTROL THIS BILL DOESN'T
MANDATE ANYTHING FOR ANY SCHOOL
DISTRICT IT ALLOWS THE
CONVERSATION AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
FOR GOVERNING BOARDS ALONG WITH
THEIR SUPERINTENDENTS IN THEIR
SCHOOL COMMUNITIES. TO DECIDE IF
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S RIGHT
FOR THEM WE KNOW IN LONG BEACH
FOR THE YEARS THAT WE'VE BEEN
DOING THIS THIS IS WHAT'S RIGHT
FOR OUR STUDENTS.
SO BY DECREASING THE AMOUNT OF
TESTS THAT ARE JUNIORS TAKING A
JUNIOR YEAR IS A CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT HERE BUT ALSO A VERY
BUSY YEAR.
TAKING OUT FOUR DAYS OF TESTING.
IS A GOOD THING FOR THEM THEY'RE
READY TO TAKE THE SAT THEY KNOW
THE IMPLICATIONS IT MEANS
SOMETHING TO THEM AND THEY COME
PREPARED THAT DAY. TO DO THE
ASPECT HAS AFTER THAT. FOR SOME
FOLKS AND AFTER ANY P. TEST HAS
ALREADY BEEN TAKEN -- LET'S JUST
SAY THE FOCUS IS AND ALWAYS
THERE UNLESS IT'S HIGHLY
INCENTIVIZE BY THINGS LIKE PROM
TICKETS IN YOUR BOOKS.
SO THIS IS AN OPTION FOR
DISTRICTS TO REALLY LOOK AT WHAT
MEETS THE NEEDS OF THEIR VERY
INDIVIDUALIZED SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WITH OVER A THOUSAND IN THE
STATE WE THINK THAT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT PIECE.
BUT WE KNOW FIRST HAND OUR KIDS
WILL DO AMAZING THINGS AND WE
WANT TO SUPPORT THEM IN THIS
BILL DOES THAT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I NEXT WE HAVE BILLY
DEE WHICH IS A HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT SHE IS A HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT FROM NEARBY KENNEDY HIGH
SCHOOL.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BILLY
DEE SCOTT AND I AM A LIMIT
GREATER I JOHN F. KENNEDY HIGH
SCHOOL IN SACRAMENTO.
I SUPPORT AB SEVEN FIVE ONE
BECAUSE EVERY STUDENT SHOULD BE
ABLE TO TAKE THE SAT OR ACT
DURING THE SCHOOL DAY FOR FREE.
HELPING STUDENTS CONNECT TO THE
TEST IN FINANCIAL AID IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
IF YOU WANT MORE STUDENTS TO GO
TO COLLEGE AND BECOME SUCCESSFUL.
I KENNEDY HIGH SCHOOL WE HAVE AS
A TEACHER.
SO ALL STUDENTS TAKE THE SAT
DURING THE SCHOOL HOURS.
AND THE ABILITY TO TAKE THIS AS
A T. IN SCHOOL HELPED ME VERY
MUCH.
AND COLLEGE ENTRANCE EXAMS ARE
STRESSFUL ENOUGH AS IT IS SINCE
I WAS ABLE TO TAKE THE SAT I'M
MY OWN SCHOOL DURING THE SCHOOL
DAY I WAS MUCH MORE COMFORTABLE.
I IN COLLEGE I AM PLANNING ON
STUDYING MARKETING AND BUSINESS
AND HOPES OF ONE DAY BECOMING AN
ENTREPRENEUR.
I AM ALSO A FIRST GENERATION
COLLEGE STUDENT AND WE HAVE LOTS
OF KIDS IN MY FAMILY AND I AM
THE MIDDLE CHILD OF NINE WHEN
YOU ARE APPLYING TO SOMETIMES
DOZENS OF COLLEGES.
THE HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS AN
APPLICATION FEES REALLY DO AT AT
AND SOMETIMES LIMITS WHERE YOU
APPLY.
I SUPPORT THE PATHWAYS TO
COLLEGE ACT TO MAKE IT A REALITY
FOR MORE STUDENTS LIKE MYSELF.
IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BELIEVE A VERY VERY
GOOD JOB AND I DON'T KNOW YOUR
THE MIDDLE CHILD [inaudible]
SO MY A FIVE YEAR NINE SO.
WE WILL HAVE LITTLE TRIALS IN --
BUT WE'RE SURVIVING.
OKAY -- WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION AND TO YOUR
WITNESSES AND ARE THERE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN SUPPORT AND I'D
REMIND YOU PLEASE.
SHARE YOUR NAME YOUR AFFILIATION
AND POSITION ON THE MEASURE.
ERICA HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE ONE OF THE
SPONSORS OF THE MEASURE AND
GREATLY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JEFF FROST FOR PRISON THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SUBURBAN SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
THE CENTRAL VALLEY EDUCATION
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
NANCY L. RON SUPERINTENDENT
SANTA FE UNIFIED.
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON RON ROUTE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT.
JEFF PARKER REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS AND SUPPORT.
AMY BROWN REPRESENTING THE CITY
OF LONG BEACH IN SUPPORT.
PATTY HERRERA SORRY WE DIDN'T
MAKE THE DEADLINE TO SUBMIT THE
LETTER ON TIME BUT REPRESENTING
OAKLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME'S AMMAR ISABELLA AND I'M
A JUNIOR JOHN F. KENNEDY HIGH
SCHOOL AND I SUPPORT AB SEVEN
FIVE ONE THANK YOU.
RACHEL LEWIS HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER
ROCKLIN CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
THEY LONNIE I CAN ALSO ON BEHALF
OF CREDIT OR GOES.
SEE THE CURRENT IN ORDER UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SACRAMENTO
CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KILLING JOHN ON THE OFFICE AND
JUST GO UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT.
NICK ROMAN ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
BERNADINO COUNTY DISTRICT
ADVOCATES FOR BETTER SCHOOLS AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE SMALL
SCHOOL DISTRICT ASSOCIATION BOTH
IN SUPPORT.
KYLE HIGHLANDER WE HAVE THE
ADDED CENTER IN TORRANCE UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
MARCH OUT OF THEM BE HAVE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS A SPONSOR OF THE
BILL IN SUPPORT.
SHANNON PRIMER EDUCATIONAL
PARALEGAL AND TEACHERS WIFE
WE'RE IN SUPPORT.
OKAY THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
TESTIFY.
ALRIGHT SEEING NONE DO WE HAVE
ANY UP I BEG YOUR PARDON OKAY GO
AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I'M BRIAN
REAVIS SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
EDUCATION TRUST WEST APOLOGIZE
WE DIDN'T GET OUR LETTER
INTENDED TO MAKE THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS -- WE RECOGNIZE AND
APPRECIATE THAT THIS IS AN
EFFORT TO BOOST COLLEGE GOING
PARTICULARLY FOR STUDENTS THAT
WE ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF LOW
INCOME STUDENTS AND STUDENTS OF
COLOR.
BUT FRANKLY WE WE STUDIED THIS
OVER THE COURSE OF LAST YEAR.
WE AGONIZE OVER THE TRADE OFFS
AND THIS YEAR WE CAME TO A
DIFFERENT CONCLUSION AND THAT IS
WE THINK THE TRADE OFFS IN THE
COMPROMISE THAT YOU WOULD HAVE
TO MAKE BY ADOPTING THIS BILL.
IS TOO GREAT OF A PRICE TO PAY.
AND WHAT I MEAN BY THAT IS --
ARE ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM RELIES
ON THE SCHOOL DASHBOARD. TO
IDENTIFY PROBLEMS BASED ON
COMPARING STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT
ACROSS SUB GROUPS AND ACROSS
DISTRICTS AND COMMUNITIES.
WHEN WE IDENTIFY A PROBLEM WE
HOPE TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEMS BY
DIRECTING ADDITIONAL SUPPORTS
THROUGH THE SYSTEM SUPPORTS?
WE THINK THAT THIS APPROACH
ALTHOUGH WE APPLIED FREE AS A T.
FOR ALL.
WE THINK THIS APPROACH
UNDERMINES THE SORT OF THEORY OF
ACTION OF OUR SCHOOL DASHBOARD
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
ABLE TO SEE AS CLEARLY.
AS PRECISELY.
HOW STUDENTS ARE DOING BECAUSE
OUR SYSTEM RELIES ON COMPARING
THEM TO ONE ANOTHER?
SO WE HAVE STUDENTS TAKING
SEPARATE TESTS.
THERE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO BE
PUT INTO PERFORMANCE CATEGORIES
TO SOME KIND OF ALGORITHM OR
CONVERSION.
AND EACH STEP THAT YOU TAKE TO
MAKE THAT CONVERSION IS GOING TO
INTRODUCE.
STATISTICAL ERROR VARIANCE IN
IT'S GOING TO REDUCE THE CLARITY
IN THE PRECISION OF THOSE
COMPARISONS.
SO OVERALL MY MAIN REASON FOR
THE MAIN REASON WE'RE OPPOSED IS
THAT WE THINK THE TRADE OFF HERE
IS.
SOME STUDENTS ARE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE THE SAT FOR FREE.
BUT THE STATE IS GOING TO BE
LESS ABLE TO CLEARLY SEE WHETHER
OR NOT SCHOOLS ARE SERVING THEM
AND PREPARING THOSE STUDENTS TO
GAIN ADMISSION TO UNIVERSITY.
AND GO ON TO GRADUATE WE THINK
THAT THAT PRICE IS TOO HIGH TO
PAY.
SECONDLY.
WE HAVE SOME SERIOUS CONCERNS
ABOUT ACCOMMODATIONS FOR TWO
SUBGROUPS IN PARTICULAR ENGLISH
LEARNERS AND STUDENTS WITH
SPECIAL WITH DISABILITIES.
LAST YEAR THE STATE ADVISORY
COMMISSION ON STUDENTS WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS LOOKED AT THIS
BILL.
THE THE PREVIOUS VERSION OPPOSED
IT AND CONCLUDED THAT STUDENTS
TO TAKE THE SAT OR STUDENTS WHO
TAKE.
YES THE SAT FROM THOSE GROUPS
WOULD BE DISADVANTAGED RELATIVE
TO STUDENTS WHO TAKE THE S. BACK
SO THAT MEANS FOR THOSE GROUPS
WOULD BE EVEN LESS ABLE TO SEE
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THOSE SCHOOLS
AND IN THOSE COMMUNITIES.
THAT'S A BIG PROBLEM FOR US AND
WE DON'T WANT TO RELY ON THE
PRESENT ADMINISTRATION TO MAKE
AN INTERPRETATION OF REGULATIONS
ON WHETHER OR NOT.
ACCOMMODATIONS FOR CALIFORNIA'S
ENGLISH LONGER ENGLISH LEARNERS
ARE ADEQUATE.
LASTLY I THINK WE RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
NOW IS THE TIME TO DOUBLE DOWN
ON THE SAT.
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA HAS
AN INVESTIGATION GOING ON OF THE
CURRENT SCANDAL.
THE ACADEMIC SENATE IS REVIEWING
WHETHER OR NOT TO CONTINUE USE
OF THE SAT IN UNIVERSITY
ADMISSIONS.
UC REGENT AND THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CHANCELLOR YOU LLOYD
OAKLEY IS CALLING FOR
ELIMINATION OF THE USE OF THE S.
A. T..
AND IN MISSIONS.
WE THINK RIGHT NOW'S NOT THE
TIME TO DOUBLE DOWN ON THE USE
OF THE S. A. T..
IN ADMISSIONS IN FACT WE THINK
NOW IS THE TIME TO PRESS THE
PAUSE BUTTON.
AND ASK OURSELVES WHAT'S THE
EFFECT OF THE USE OF THE S. A.
T. ON STUDENTS WHO ARE HAVING
TROUBLE ACCESSING HIGHER
EDUCATION.
AND ARE WE DOING ALL THAT WE CAN
TO REDUCE BIAS AND SAFEGUARD
AGAINST FRAUD.
EVERY DAY SO FOR THOSE REASONS
WE ARE -- UNFORTUNATELY OPPOSED
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IF I MAY OKAY WHAT TIME SIR GIVE
OWN MEN WOMEN MORE OUTSIDE OF
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION.
XENA.
JUST TO GIVE THE OPPOSITION IS
NEW SO THIS IS NEW TO ME THIS IS
NEW INFORMATION TODAY FOR ME --
THE RESULTS OF THE S. EIGHTY
WOULD BE BUILT INTO THE
DASHBOARD JUST AS THE RESULTS OF
THE ASPECTS ARE NOW -- IN THE
BILL REQUIRES THE ASSESSMENT TO
BE ALIGNED TO THE STATE
STANDARDS.
MEET FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS AND
ENSURE THAT ACCOMMODATIONS ARE
PROVIDED IN SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION HE SPOKE OF WAS LAST
YEAR.
NOT TO THIS YEAR'S BILL SO I
APPRECIATE THAT BUT BUT BUT
AGAIN IF I GROUPS THAT OPPOSED
TO LAST YEAR -- THAT THAT THEY
ARE NOT HERE TODAY THEY'RE NOT
OPPOSING TODAY THAT -- THIS BILL
THEY ARE THEY'RE NEUTRAL AS FAR
AS I KNOW.
AND WITH REGARD TO SPECIAL ED
STUDENTS IT REQUIRES US TO
ACCOMMODATE SPECIAL STUDENTS IS
EVEN BETTER.
BECAUSE WE SCHOOL SITE PERSONNEL --
THAT WOULD BE -- INSURING THAT
THE ACCOMMODATIONS ARE FULFILLED
AT THE SCHOOL SITE.
AND GIVING THE TEST AT THE
SCHOOL SITE IS A SAFER MORE
SECURE ENVIRONMENT THEN THEN
THEN THEN I'VE BEEN OF SOME
PLACE OFF CAMPUS AND AND
CONDUCTED BY A THIRD PARTY QUITE
FRANKLY.
SO GIVEN THE CURRENT SCANDAL --
I MEAN YOU CAN BLAME SAT YOU CAN
SAY A LOT OF THINGS ABOUT THE
SAT BUT TO ME BLAMING US EIGHTY
FOR PEOPLE CHEATING ON IT'S KIND
OF LIKE BLAMING THE BANK FOR
GETTING ROBBED.
RIGHT -- IN AGAIN I I THINK.
THE CURRENT SITUATION MAKES THE
CASE FOR EIGHTY SEVEN FIVE ONE
BY ENSURING THAT ALL STUDENTS
HAVE ACCESS TO TEST PREPARATION.
ONE INTO THE TEST IS GIVEN ON
SITE IN A VERY SECURE.
AND PROTOCOL ORIENTED FASHION
AND I KNOW MISS KERR HAD --
THINK DID YOU WANT TO SHARE
SOMETHING.
WITH ME HE IS INTERESTED -- WE
DO HAVE RESEARCH TALKING ABOUT
THE CORRELATION RIGHT BETWEEN
THE SAT AND THE S. BACK -- AND
THE RESULTS SHOW THAT THEY ARE
BROADLY ASSESSING THE SAME
SKILLS THERE'S A ZERO POINT
SEVEN SEVEN WHICH IS A STRONG
POSITIVE CORRELATION BETWEEN THE
ASPECT YOU NEED RW.
AN ASPECT YOU AWAY AND ZERO
POINT EIGHT TWO WHICH IS A VERY
STRONG POSITIVE CORRELATION
BETWEEN SAT MATH AND S. BACK
MATH.
BOTH TESTS INDICATE A COMPARABLE
PERCENTAGE OF ALL STUDENTS
MEETING THE STANDARDS IN THE LA
58% MET OR EXCEEDED S. BACK
WHILE FIFTY THREE MET SAT AND
MATH.
32% MET OR EXCEEDED S. BACK
WHILE 31% MATT S..
EIGHTY AND JUST ON THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION PIECE THERE'S
ESSENTIALLY A ONE TO ONE MATCH
WHERE APPLICABLE BETWEEN THE
FORTY TWO UNIVERSAL TOOLS.
DESIGNATED SUPPORTS AND
ACCOMMODATION WITH ANY ASPECT
ANY ACCOMMODATIONS WITHIN THE
SAT.
THANK YOU FOR THAT CLARIFICATION
I WILL OPEN IT UP TO COMMITTEE
MEMBER QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME
[inaudible]
DOCTOR WEBER [inaudible]
YES -- YOU'RE YOU'RE DOING THIS
IN REVERSE NOT RIVERSIDE LONG
BEACH I GATHER AT USING LONG
BEACH AND YOU ALSO STILL DO THE
TEST WE DO.
SO YOU DO THEM BOTH BECAUSE I AS
I LISTEN TO BOTH ARGUMENTS.
IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S IT'S A STRONG
ARGUMENT FOR ACTUALLY HAVING YES
CITY ON CAMPUS AND FREE.
I DIDN'T HEAR HOW IT HAD.
HOUSE STILL GIVING THE TEST
WOULD HAVE A THE OTHER TESTS AS
BACK WOULD HAVE A NEGATIVE
EFFECT.
ON STUDENTS TO TAKE MORE THAN
ONE TEST IN THE ELEVENTH GRADE I
MEAN.
MY CONCERN IS ALWAYS BEEN WITH
AN AYE WE HAVE CONTINUING THE
SAME DATA SO THAT WE CAN ASSESS
WHAT NOT STUDENTS ARE MAKING A
KIND OF PROGRESS.
AND WE'D LIKE TO THEM TO MAKE
AND SO HE'S KIND OF TAKE A PIECE
OUT YOU YOU KIND OF BREAK THE
CYCLE IN TERMS OF PROGRESS BUT
BUT I THINK YOU'RE CONVERSATIONS
ALL SAID THAT YOU DO IT NOW.
ARE YOU STILL DO THE OTHER TESTS
CORRECT.
SO IS WORKING NOW SO WHY WOULD
WE WANT TO TAKE OUT THERE
BECAUSE I COULD SEE IS WANTING
TO BASICALLY ENCOURAGE EVERY
SCHOOL -- ESPECIALLY WITH KIDS
LOW INCOME TO BASICALLY DO THE
S. A. T. ON THEIR CAMPUS TO MAKE
IT FREE FOR KIDS TO BLACK
RESOURCES.
TO HAPPEN TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN
FOR THEM I THINK THAT'S THE
ISSUE OF EQUITY THAT THAT'S
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT.
NOT SURE WHAT THE NEGATIVE IS OF
YOUR CURRENT SYSTEM THAT YOU
HAVE.
SO BECAUSE WE DO ADMINISTER BOTH
TESTS WERE INCREASE THE COST OF
THOSE TASKS SO WHILE WE'RE
BROADLY USING THE PS EIGHTY AN
SAT FOR ALL OF THOSE YEARS WE
THEN DO THE S. BACK AGAIN WHICH
IS A FORTY TEST WHICH TAKES TIME
OUT AT STUDENT LEARNING AND
REFLECTION.
BUT IT'S ALSO NOT INCENTIVIZE
FOR THE STUDENTS BECAUSE THERE'S
NOTHING IN IT FOR THEM SO FOR MY
STUDENTS WHO TOOK THE ASPECT AS
JUNIORS THEY HAD ALREADY TAKEN
THE SAT.
AND THEY WERE WORKING TOWARDS
COLLEGE ADMISSION BECAUSE TWO OF
MY KIDS ARE IN SCHOOL OUT OF
STATE -- SO THAT FOUR DAYS OF
TESTING REALLY TOOK AWAY FROM
WHAT THEY WERE DOING IT FROM A
DISTRICT RESPECTED MORE THAN
PAYING THE COST TO ADMINISTER A
SECOND TEST.
WHEN WE HAVE -- WHAT WE FEEL ARE
EQUALLY IMPORTANT METRICS AS
WELL AS LONG TERM AT MULTI YEAR
METRICS THAT WE CAN USE TO DO
INTERVENTIONS IT IF I COULD IN
EVERY ON QUICKLY AND EVERYBODY
EVERY SINGLE TAKE THE SAT?
THERE WOULD NOT BE SOME CRACKING
AND SOME NOT SO WE OFFERED TWICE
A YEAR ACTUALLY SO WE OFFER IT
TODAY IN THE SPRING FOR YOUR
STUDENTS WE ALSO OFFERED AGAIN
FOR FREEIN THE FALL. FOR OUR
SENIORS WHO ARE LOOKING TO BUMP
UP THEIR SCORES FOR THEIR CSU
INDEX FOR SOME OF THE MORE
COMPETITIVE SCHOOLS HAVE A
HIGHER REQUIREMENT.
AND WE KNOW THAT THE ONLY WAY AT
THAT POINT FOR SOMEONE TO GAIN
ADMISSION TO THE CSU IS TO
CHANGE THEIR SAT SCORE THEY
CAN'T CHANGE THEIR GPA AT THAT
POINT.
BUT WE DO THE MATH AND WE SEE
THAT IF THEY GOT FOUR MORE
QUESTIONS CORRECT ON THE SAT IN
THE FALL THAT BUMPED UP THEIR
ELIGIBILITY WHICH HELPS OUR LONG
BEACH COLLEGE PROMISE.
SO LAST YEAR WE HAD
APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED
FIFTEEN STUDENTS WHO WERE JUST
BARELY OFF THE COLLEGE PROMISE
METRIC OF THE THIRTY TWO HUNDRED
FOR CAL STATE LONG BEACH -- BUT
WE NOTIFY THEM THEY KNEW WHAT
THEIR SCORES THEY DID SOME
REALLY INVALID INDIVIDUALIZED --
TUTORING IN THOSE AREAS AND
APPROXIMATELY A HALF I BELIEVE
WE'RE ABLE TO BUMP UP THEIR SAT
A SCORE ENOUGH TO ALLOW THEM
ADMISSION INTO CAL STATE LONG
BEACH SO IT HAS VERY REAL TIME A
FAX -- SO THAT'S OUR COMMITMENT
TO THEM THAT WE'LL DO EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO SUPPORT THAT.
YOU WANT TO TELL YOU I JUST WANT
TO SHARE THEIR YOU JUST SAID IT
BASICALLY IT'S AN ASSESSMENT
SYSTEM.
NOT JUST A TRYING SYSTEM
ASSESSMENTS.
ADDRESS ACHIEVEMENT GAPS WITHIN
THAT ASSESSMENT SYSTEM ARENA.
AND IT INVESTED LISTEN KIDS A
LOT OF GREAT.
LOVE THEM THEY'RE NOT ALWAYS
REAL INVESTED IN THESE TESTS
THAT DON'T MEAN A LOT TO THEM IN
THE US BACK IS SUCH A TEST.
AND ALSO TIME TO GO.
TO THE LOGISTICS ASSOCIATED WITH
ADMINISTERING THE ASPECT ARE
SIGNIFICANT ESPECIALLY SOME OF
OUR LARGER HIGH SCHOOLS THEY
WILL DISRUPT CLASSES FOR TWO
THREE WEEKS SOMETIMES.
JUST TO GET THAT TIME WINDOW --
THAT STUDENTS NEED TO TAKE THE
ASPECT HAS TO SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF TIME AND THEN AGAIN IN THAT
ELEVENTH GRADE YOU'RE A LOT OF
KIDS HAVE A LOT OF STUFF GOING
ON THERE'S A P. TASKS -- THERE'S
COLLEGE APPLICATIONS THERE'S
THERE'S A LOT OF STUFF GOING ON
DURING THAT ELEVENTH GRADE YEAR.
THAT I THINK GIVING -- THAT THIS
APPROACH IS IS IS.
IS SMARTER TESTING NOT JUST MORE
TESTS.
YEAH I'D LIKE TO WELL I I'M NOT
SUPPORTED TO DOUSE THE I'LL TRY
TO GET THE ONLY INFORMATION THAT
HE HAD THAT HE SHARED WITH UP.
WITH THAT BECAUSE I'VE HAD SOME
CONCERNS BUT I THINK IT'S A I
THINK IT IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
MAKE SAT AVAILABLE TO ALL
STUDENTS WHO WANT IT.
I KNOW DOING ANYTHING ON CAMPUS
SOMETIMES A POSITIVE EFFECT FOR
STUDENTS AND SURELY PAYING FOR
THAT NUMBER SCHOOL TO PAY FOR IT.
AND AND AND IT'S A GOOD USE OF
THE TITLE ONE DOLLARS AND
EVERYTHING ELSE IS THERE TO GIVE
THEM THAT OPPORTUNITY.
I'D LIKE TO SEE THE I DON'T KNOW
THE DATE WITH REGARD TO HOW WELL
STUDENTS DO ON THAT KIND OF HIS
VERSES IS BAD.
I'M NOT SURE THE STUDENTS NOT
MOTIVATED ON ANY TESTS IS NOT BE
ON SAID MOTIVATED ON SAT WHEN
THEY THEMSELVES HAVE NO
INTENTIONS OF OF GOING BEYOND
WHERE THEY ARE YOU KNOW IN OTHER
WORDS JUST GRADUATING IN DOING
SOMETHING ELSE.
I'M NOT TOO THERE'S A REAL BIG
MOTIVATION FOR THAT BUT BUT IT
WOULD BE IMPORTANT TO KNOW.
WHAT IT IS AND WHETHER NOT WE
STILL NEED TOOLS TO ASSESS PUT
FOR TEACHING WITH REGARDS TO THE
S. BACK AS WITHIN OUT WHAT WE'RE
DOING IS EFFECTIVE OR
INEFFECTIVE BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN?
DOING THE SMARTER BALANCED WE'VE
BEEN DOING THE NEW CORE
CURRICULUM AND ALL THAT STUFF
AND SO NEEDING TO CONSTANTLY
ASSESS WHAT THE NOT STUDENTS ARE
GETTING IT MOVING FORWARD WITH
IT OR WHATEVER.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT HAPPENS BUT I
I UNDERSTAND THE NEED TO
BASICALLY HAVE AN ON CAMPUS FOR
EVERY STUDENT CHOOSE TO HAVE IT
AT A COST OF THREE YES NO
QUESTION.
THANK YOU.
AND THERE IS A THERE IS A STUDY
OUT OF UC DAVIS I DON'T KNOW THE
AUTHOR OF THE STUDY WHICH SHOWS
THAT THE TESTS ARE SIGNIFICANTLY
CORRELATED.
AND AND AS FAR AS HOW THEY
PREDICT COLLEGE SUCCESS AND THAT
THE SAT IS ACTUALLY A SLIGHTLY
AS I UNDERSTAND IT A SLIGHTLY
BETTER PROTECT.
YEAH BUT THE IN ADDITION TO THAT
THE THE STUDY OFTEN SHOWS TO
THAT.
STUDENTS OF COLOR DO BETTER ON
ACT AND SAT.
AND SO IT WOULD PUSH EVERYBODY
S. A. T. THERE WERE KIDS OF
COLOR DON'T DO VERY WELL.
BUT THEY DO MUCH BETTER IN A
CITY BECAUSE OF THE FORMAT OF IT
THEN WE MAY BE PUSHING THEM INTO
AN AREA WHERE.
YOU KNOW BECAUSE A LOT OF FOLKS
AND TALKING TO NOW WITH KIDS
PUTTING THEM IN A CITIES
PARTICULAR AFRICAN AMERICANS
BECAUSE IT CITIES HAS NOT BEEN.
A WHATEVER THAT HONEST I'VE DONE
AND ALL THE TESTS AND AGES BUT I
KNOW THAT IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE A
BETTER TEST IN A BETTER
ASSESSMENT.
OF AFRICAN AMERICAN KIDS SO IF
YOU WANT TO GO TO SAT YOU'VE GOT
A NUMBER OF AFRICAN AMERICAN
KIDS IN THERE.
THEY MAY STILL WANT TO TAKE THE
ACT THE PANTS ARE CONSCIOUS OF
IT SO THEY MAY FIND THEMSELVES
ONCE AGAIN BEING TESTED OVER AND
OVER AGAIN -- IN ORDER TO
ACHIEVE WHAT THEY WANT TO CHEESE
SO THAT'S SOMETHING I THINK YOU
SHOULD CONSIDER AS YOU MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS THAT.
EVEN AS A T. HAS ITS CULTURAL
BIASES OF THE GENERALLY NOT IN
FAVOR.
OF KIDS OF COLOR YOU KNOW IT'S
KIND LIKE THE I. Q. TESTS THEY
DO WE ARE NOT IN FAVOR OF KIDS
OF COLOR.
AND THE TEST A WHOLE LOT OF
STUFF IN A DIFFERENT WAY THAT
THAT GOES FAR BEYOND WHAT TO DO
IN THE CLASSROOM THE CLASSROOM
HEALTH WHICH YOU CAN'T STUDY FOR
THE SAT NOT REALLY.
YOU CAN SAY THE FORMAT OF THE
SAT BUT YOU CAN'T REALLY BONE
DOWN AND STUDY FOR THE SAT
CAUSES ACCUMULATION OF KNOWLEDGE
OVER A LONG PERIOD OF TIME.
SO -- ANYWAY.
WOULD BE INTERESTING SEEING
WHATEVER DATED INFORMATION WE
MIGHT HAVE CONCERNING BECAUSE I
THINK IT IS IMPORTANT CHOICES
DISTRICTS TO MAKE ONE THING IS
GOING IT'S A CHOICE TO DISTRICTS
CAN MAKE AND I HOPE THEY WILL.
SERIOUSLY LOOK AT IT INCOME AND
IN TERMS OF THE STUDENTS ARE
TRYING TO SERVE AND THE
COMMUNITY SAID OF THE AND HAVE
THAT HOPEFULLY CONVERSATION
INPUT FROM COMMUNITY SAID TAYLOR
IT BEST FOR THE STUDENTS THAT
ARE IN THE DISTRICT.
SO I LIKE THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND AGAIN WE'RE NOT
SAYING SAT OR ACT WERE SAYING
EITHER BUT AGAIN I I GET YOUR
POINT IS WELL TAKEN.
WITH REGARD TO THE SAT.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
ALL RIGHT HEARING NONE I WOULD
YOU LIKE OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE
MISTER O'DONNELL -- JUST ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE -- AND THIS IS THIS
THIS THIS BILL IS AOUT --
PROVIDING MORE OPPORTUNITY FOR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS AND AGAIN I
ASTRONOMICAL [inaudible]
OKAY.
WE WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
VERY GOOD I'M SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL I DON'T
KNOW I KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA.
I MCCARTY SMITH.
SMITH I WEBER.
WEBER I THE THE BILL IS THAT
WITH FIVE VOTES THANK YOU.
THE NEXT DOUBLE HAVE MISTER LOWE
PRESENTING FOR MR GLORIA PLEASE
.
WE'RE WE'RE GOING TO GO TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER. EIGHT WHICH IS A.
B. -- FOUR NINE THREE BY MR
GLORIA MR LOW WILL BE PRESENTING
TODAY -- WITH THAT YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN READY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH RESEARCHER MEMBERS OF
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT ON
BEHALF OF A SISTER GLORIA --
THIS IS WITH RESPECT TO CREATING
A MORE SAFE AND SUPPORTER
FIREMAN FOR TEACHERS WITH
RESPECT OUR LGBT YOUTH.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
I HAVE TWO WITNESSES TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT AS WELL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS TAMMY MARTIN WITH THE
QUALITY CALIFORNIA.
AND OVER THE PAST TWENTY YEARS
WE'VE SPONSORED A NUMBER OF
BILLS TO MAKE SCHOOLS SAFER FOR
LGBT Q. STUDENTS.
BUT THERE'S MORE WORK TO BE DONE.
DATA SHOWS THAT THE MAJORITY OF
LGBT Q. STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA
REGULARLY HERE ANTI LGBT Q.
REMARKS AT SCHOOL AND ARE
FREQUENT TARGETS OF HARASSMENT
AND ASSAULT.
THEY'RE MORE LIKELY TO DROP OUT
DUE TO SAFETY CONCERNS.
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS AND
CONTEMPLATE SUICIDE THAN THEIR
NON LGBT Q. PEERS.
WE KNOW THESE DISPARITIES ARE
WORSE FOR LGBTQ YOUTH WHO ARE
ALSO MEMBERS OF COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR OR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES.
AND WHILE RESOURCES EXIST MANY
LGBTQ STUDENTS REPORT NOT HAVING
ACCESS TO THEM.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S NOT
SURPRISING WE RECENTLY SENT A
SURVEY TO ALL UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE STATE.
AND OTHER DISTRICTS THAT
RESPONDED JUST A HANDFUL
REPORTED THAT THEY PROVIDE
MANDATORY LGBT Q. CULTURAL
COMPETENCY TRAINING AND OVER A
THIRD REPORTED THAT THEY DO NOT
EVEN OFFER VOLUNTARY TRAINING.
EVERY CHILD REGARDLESS OF
BACKGROUND ZIP CODE SEXUAL
ORIENTATION OR GENDER IDENTITY.
DESERVES THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SUCCEED.
TEACHERS AND SCHOOL STAFF ARE ON
THE FRONT LINES OF ENSURING THAT
ALL STUDENTS HAVE THAT SHOT AT
SUCCESS AND WE KNOW THEY WANT TO
HELP.
THAT'S WHAT THE DEDICATED THEIR
LIVES AND CAREERS TO DOING.
BUT WE NEED TO GIVE THEM THE
TOOLS TO DO SO.
THAT'S WHY WE ARE PROUD TO
SPONSOR EIGHTY FOUR NINETY THREE
WHICH ADDRESSES THIS URGENT NEED
BY PROVIDING TEACHERS AND SCHOOL
STAFF WITH THE TRAINING THEY
NEED AND WANT. TO HELP LGBT Q.
STUDENTS WERE BULLIED AT SCHOOL.
REJECTED BY THEIR FAMILIES OR
LACK ACCEPTANCE IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
THIS BILL WILL MAKE OUR SCHOOLS
SAFER AND MORE INCLUSIVE FOR ALL
STUDENTS.
BECAUSE WHEN LGBT Q. STUDENTS
FEEL SAFE AND SUPPORTED.
THEIR FRIENDS AND CLASSMATES
BENEFIT.
TO SO WE THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA AND OUR CO SPONSOR STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND. FOR
ADVANCING THIS CRITICAL
LEGISLATION.
AND WE URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
TEACHERS AND SCHOOL STAFF BY.
HI THANK YOU YOUR NEXT WITNESS.
THERE TURN MEMBERS -- MY NAME IS
DOCTOR OF ANY PUMP HEY AND I'M
HONORED TO SPEAK IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB.
FOR NINETY THREE AS A FORMER
TEACHER SCHOOL COUNSELOR AND
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL COUNSELORS.
AND AUTHOR OF THE LGBT -- YOUTH
REPORT.
I KNOW FIRST HAND THE DESPERATE
NEED FOR STAFF TRAINING ON
SUPPORTING LGBT Q. STUDENTS.
NOT ONLY ARE LGBT YOUTH
EXPERIENCING HIGH LEVELS OF PURE
BOWLING AND FAMILY REJECTION.
BUT THEY ARE ALSO NOT FINDING
ADEQUATE ADEQUATE SUPPORT FROM
THEIR EDUCATORS.
A RECENT STUDY FOUND THAT ONLY
5% OF LGBT STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA SAY THAT ALL OF THEIR
SCHOOL STAFF OR SUPPORT OF THE
LGBT PEOPLE.
WHEN STUDENTS FEEL SAFE AND
CONNECTED AT SCHOOL THEIR
ATTENDANCE ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT
AND GRADUATION RATES GO UP?
UNFORTUNATELY THIS KNOWN FACT IS
OFTEN IGNORED WHEN IT COMES TO
LGBT Q. STUDENTS PRIMARILY
BECAUSE THE SUBJECT MATTER MAKES
DISTRICT DECISION MAKERS.
UNCOMFORTABLE.
LIKE ALL STUDENTS LGBT Q.
STUDENTS DON'T HAVE A CHOICE
WHETHER OR NOT TO ATTEND SCHOOL.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
I'M SORRY SHOULD SCHOOL
DISTRICTS GET TO CHOOSE WHETHER
OR NOT THEIR CAMPUSES ARE SAFE
AND INCLUSIVE OF LGBT STUDENTS.
WITH NEARLY TWENTY YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE WORKING WITH K.
TWELVE SCHOOLS I HAVE YET TO
FIND A CAMPUS AT A SAFE AND
WELCOMING OF LGBTQ STUDENTS THAT
HASN'T YET PROVIDED TRAINING FOR
THEIR STAFF.
I'M HAPPY TO SHARE THAT THE
HARDWORKING EDUCATORS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE HUNGRY FOR THIS
TYPE OF TRAINING AND TO LEARN
HOW TO BEST SUPPORT THEIR LGBT
STUDENTS.
BUT THEY NEED THIS BILL TO PASS
SO THAT THIS NEEDED TRAINING
BECOMES A REALITY.
AB FOR NINETY THREE ISN'T JUST
THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
IT IS OUR ETHICAL OBLIGATION AS
INDIVIDUALS WHO CARE ABOUT THE
WELL BEING OF ALL STUDENTS I
URGE YOU TO VOTE IN FAVOR OF
THIS LIFESAVING BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS JOINT
WELL AS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION.
TONY THURMOND A CO SPONSOR OF
THE BILL IN SUPPORT.
RUN RAMPANT BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT.
CERRILLOS ON BEHALF OF TEACH
PLUS IN SUPPORT.
DONNA ARE TO CONVERGE CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA IN SUPPORT.
CHEN PRIMER PARALEGAL AND MOTHER
TO TO GET GIRLS AND MOTHER IN
LAW TO A TRANSGENDER PERSON.
IT'S SUPPORT.
SEC BRAMBLE HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION WE'RE BRINGING THE
BILL TO OUR MEETING THIS WEEK
AND THAT'S THE TO A STATE
COUNCIL AND I ANTICIPATE WE WILL
BE THERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN OPPOSITION WILL BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE SING A ANY
COMMENTS READY THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I DO NOT SEE ANY
COMMENTS MANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
TO EMOTION THE BILL IS REMOVED
THE MOVED AND SECONDED BY
MISSPENT -- BUT YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
RESPECT ASTRO.
BLOOM.
IS GLORIOUS BILL.
YEAH I GUESS SAID IN A THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE COMMITTEE
BENSON WOULD BE GLADLY ACCEPTING
THEM AS WELL THANK YOU MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY [inaudible]
KALRA.
KALRA I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY ICE SMITH SMITH I WEBER.
WEBER I THE BILL IS OUT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE DON'T KNOW.
I WILL GO TO MISTER HOLDEN FILE
ITEM NUMBER.
WE'LL DO NINETEEN FILE ITEM
NINETEEN FIRST.
HE WILL HAVE TWENTY THREE AFTER
THE FILING OF NINETEEN MISTER
HOLD YOU MAY PERCEIVE ONE RIGHT.
NINETY TWO FIRST [inaudible]
MR.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE -- I'D LIKE TO THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL.
NINE EIGHTY TWO I'D LIKE TO LEAD
OFF BY ACCEPTING THE A COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEES OF WORKING WITH US ON
THIS BILL.
UNDER EXISTING LAW IF A STUDENT
HAS EXCUSE ABSENCE TEACHERS ARE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE THE PEOPLE
WITH MISTER SIMONS AND TESTS.
HOWEVER FOR STUDENTS SUSPENDED
IT IS AT THE DISCRETION OF THE
TEACHER TO PROVIDE OF MISSED
WORK.
EVEN IF THE STUDENT OR PARENT
REQUESTED.
AB NINE EIGHTY TWO WOULD REQUIRE
TEACHERS TO PROVIDE MISSED
HOMEWORK OF A PARENT OR GUARDIAN
REQUESTED WHEN A STUDENT IS
SUSPENDED.
AS REFLECTED IN THE ANALYSIS
EVEN WITH THE DECLINE IN
SUSPENSIONS DISPARITIES STILL
EXIST.
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS
CONTINUE TO BE SUSPENDED AT MUCH
HIGHER RATES THAN OTHER GROUPS.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS TO
PREVENT STUDENTS FROM FALLING
BEHIND AND BECOMING MORE OF A
JUST DISCIPLINARY PROBLEMS.
IT IS NOT THE INTENT OF THE BILL
TO ADD ADDITIONAL BURDEN TO
TEACHERS.
SINCE THE TEACHERS ALREADY HAVE
A PREPARED LESSON PLAN THEY
WOULD JUST NEED TO SHARE THE
INFORMATION WITH THE PARENT OR
GUARDIAN UPON REQUEST.
AB NINE EIGHTY TWO IS CLEAR THAT.
THE GRADING OR PROVIDING CREDIT
FOR THIS MISSED WORK IS UP TO
THE DISCRETION OF THE TEACHER.
I KNOW THAT MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF EDUCATING ALL
STUDENTS.
AND IF THE PARENTS ARE CONCERNED
ENOUGH TO REQUEST THE HOMEWORK
AND TEACHERS SHOULD PROVIDE THE-SAME CLASS WORK THAT IS PROVIDED
TO THE EXCUSED.
STUDENTS.
IT IS SAFE TO SAY WE ARE ALL
HERE TODAY BECAUSE WE WANT ALL
STUDENTS TO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK SUCCEED.
AND WE CANNOT IGNORE THE LASTING
IMPACT THE SUSPENSIONS HAVE ON
STUDENTS.
THIS BILL IS JUST ONE SMALL STEP.
TOWARDS ADDRESSING THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND TODAY I HAVE JACQUE
WILSON FROM ADVOCATES FOR
JUSTICE JOINING ME.
AS A WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS CHOCK WILSON I AM A CO
FOUNDER OF ADVOCATES FOR JUSTICE.
A BOARD MEMBER OF CRLA BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY I'M A PARENT AND I'M
ADVOCATE FOR STUDENTS WITHOUT A
VOICE.
AS ADVOCATE FOR STUDENTS I KNOW
FIRST HAND THE PSYCHOLOGICAL
EFFECTS THAT A SUSPENSION HOUSE
ON A STUDENT -- SUSPENDED
STUDENTS OFTEN FALL BEHIND IN
SCHOOL DISENGAGE DROPOUT BECOME
VICTIMS OF THE SCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE.
WHICH IS WHY IN CALIFORNIA --
SUSPENSIONS ARE SUPPOSED TO BE A
DISCIPLINARY TOOL OF LAST RESORT.
EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY TWO IS NOT
ASKING FOR SPECIAL TREATMENT FOR
SUSPENDED STUDENTS.
IT ONLY SIX THAT WE WILL ATTEMPT
TO LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD FOR
SUSPENDED STUDENTS BY GIVING
THEM FAIR AND EQUAL ACCESS TO
THE CLASS ASSIGNMENTS.
THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN I ON
BEHALF OF ADVOCATES FOR JUSTICE
CONDUCTED A PUBLIC RECORDS
REQUEST.
A MODESTO CITY SCHOOLS AND WE
DISCOVERED THAT OVER A THREE
YEAR PERIOD BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN A TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
THAT THERE WAS A TOTAL OF ONE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
NINE AFRICAN AMERICANS.
THE ROLE OF THE HIGH SCHOOL
LEVEL.
THESE ONE THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY NINE AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS WERE SUSPENDED
A RECEIPT THE FUNCTIONAL
EQUIVALENT OF A SUSPENSION MORE
THAN FORTY ONE HUNDRED TIMES.
NO OTHER STUDENT GROUP
EXPERIENCES THIS TYPE OF GROSS
DISAPPEAR DESPITE DISPROPORTION
AUDI INSISTS PENSIONS OR
DISCIPLINE IN CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS.
WHAT WAS EVEN MORE DISTURBING IS
THAT THE STUDENTS WERE BEING
WAREHOUSE MANY OF THEM ALL DAY
WITHOUT ACCESS TO THEIR SCHOOL
WORK AND WERE EVEN ALLOWED TO
PLAY VIDEO GAMES AND WATCH
VIDEOS ON THEIR CELL PHONES?
ABC TEN INVESTIGATORS RAN A TEN
MINUTE SEGMENT ON THIS.
THE GROSS ABUSE OF TAXPAYER
DOLLARS.
IN CALIFORNIA WE NOW KNOW THAT
THERE IS A DIRECT CORRELATION
BETWEEN STUDENTS WHO MISS
CRITICAL CLASSROOM TIME AND THE
SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE.
ACCORDING TO DATAQUEST IN TWO
THOUSAND SO YOU SUMMARIZE.
PLEASE SUMMERS OKAY START BACK
UP THE CORDON -- AB NINE EIGHTY
TWO IS ONE WAY OF KEEPING
STUDENTS IN SCHOOL ENGAGE.
IN THE IN THE SCHOOL THIS
PROCESS OF PIPELINE I SUPPORT
EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY TWO BECAUSE
IT WILL CREATE TECHNICAL
EDUCATION.
EXPERIENCE FOR ALL STUDENTS.
THANK YOU VERY WELL DONE.
YOUR NEXT WITNESS [inaudible]
THAT'S THE ONLY ONE WITH US OKAY --
YEAH I DO NOT RIGHT -- OKAY
OTHERS IN SUPPORT PLEASE COME
FORWARD AND STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION OF THE
ERIC HAIRS WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
SEEM TO OTHERS ANY OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL.
I SEE NO OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
OF RING UP BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS MISTER
HOLDEN THERE WERE THREE OF THEM.
AND IT REALLY ONE OF MY CONCERNS
AS A CLASSROOM TEACHER -- WHICH
I SHARED WITH YOU WAS.
THANK YOU THERE'S OKAY I'M SORRY
TWO MINUTES TWO MINUTES WAS --
THAT I TEACHER NOT HAVE THAT
NUMBER ONE STUDENT BE HAVE
ACCESS TO THAT HOMEWORK THAT
WOULD HAVE TYPICALLY BEEN
ASSIGNED SHOULD THEY BE THERE.
AND YEAH I TOTALLY AGREE WITH
THAT AND THAT A TEACHER NOT
IMMEDIATELY HAVE TO RESPOND TO A
CALL FROM THE OFFICE STOP
TEACHING AND AND AND GATHER UP
HOMEWORK FOR STUDENTS WHO
SUSPENDED BUT THAT.
IT BE HANDED OFF TO A STUDENT
WHO MATTER IN A REASONABLE
AMOUNT OF TIME AND YOU AGREE TO
THAT AND THEN THERE WAS A
CHARTER MEMBER TOO SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS
READY THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MISTER MCCARTY YEAH THANK YOU I
THINK THIS IS A COMMON SENSE I
DON'T SEE WHY WE WOULDN'T HAVE
THIS ANYWAY IF SOMEONE'S.
BEING SUSPENDED HAVE THEM WORK
ON THEIR HOMEWORK AND LET'S FACE
IT YOU'RE RIGHT STUDENTS WHO GET
SUSPENDED.
I'M MORE LIKELY TO BE A DROP
OUTS IN THE COST OF LAST TIME I
CHECKED IN YOUR OWN COUNTY LA
COUNTY JUVENILE HALLS ABOUT. TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE GRAND A YEAR
FOR SOMEONE IN JUVENILE HALL
STUFF.
COSTS ARE TREMENDOUS JUST
CURIOUS I DIDN'T ANY OPPOSITION
BUT HAD HAS THE HAVE THAT SCHOOL
BOARD ASSOCIATION -- EXCEPT IN
THE PROVIDING FEEDBACK.
IF THEY OPPOSE OR SUPPORTER OF
THE CONCERNS THAT I WOULD LIKE
TO SEE THEM HERE BEHIND YOU
DOING AT ME TOO BUT YOU HAVE ANY
INSIGHT -- FOR US FROM THE
EDUCATION COMMUNITY ON THIS BUT
I HAVE NOT RECEIVED ANY DIRECTLY
NINE OR AT LEAST MY OFFICE IS
NOW.
THE COMMITTEE HAS RECEIVED NO
OPPOSITION YEAH AND I HAVE BEEN
TELLING ME TALKING TO THEM AND
WHAT'S THEIR FEEDBACK FROM THE
FROM ACCESS OR CSPA.
WELL I CAN SHARE WITH YOU THAT
THE COMMITTEE STAFF REGULARLY
INTERACTS WITH ADVOCATES REMOVES
ORGANIZATIONS AND THEY HAVE
RECEIVED.
NO FEEDBACK ON THIS BILL SO WE
ASSUME THERE RIGHT.
NEUTRAL OR POSSIBLY EVEN SUPPORT
OF MAYBE THEY'RE RELEVANT ORGAN --
BODIES HAVEN'T TAKEN A POSITION
ON THE BILL.
BUT IF YOU WANT TO DRUM UP
OPPOSITION.
THIS MIGHT BE THE WAY TO DO IT.
GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON MARC SUMMERS
ON BEHALF OF ACCESS AND WE ARE
CURRENTLY EVALUATING THE BILL I
WE HAVE NO CONTRACT THIS MOMENT
BUT WILL GET WITH AUTHORED
OFFICER IN THE NEAR FUTURE.
THANK YOU.
ERICA HOW CAN I BE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION I CAN JUST SAY DITTO
WE'VE GOT A LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE MEETING COMING UP IN A
COUPLE OF WEEKS.
AND IT IS ALREADY ON MY LIST TO
TAKE THE BILL THERE FOR POSITION.
YES I'M TRYING TO GET TO SUPPORT
SIDE FOR THAT MISTER RIGHT.
WELL I APPRECIATE THAT I I'M A
FIRM BELIEVER THAT WHEN YOU'RE
THE DICE YOU QUIT WHILE YOU'RE
AHEAD.
THIS MCCARTY HAS A DIFFERENT
VISION APPARENTLY.
NEVER NEVER ROBBING A BANK WITH
YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS REALLY COMING
DOCTOR WEBER.
OKAY DOCTORS MISS SMITH.
THANK YOU I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
THIS WHAT IN WHAT I THINK IS A
FIRST SMALL STEP TO WHERE WE
NEED TO BE IN TERMS OF RE
DIRECTING SOME OF OUR OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS AND YOU KNOW
RATHER THAN THINKING IN TERMS OF
REMOVING THEM FROM A SCHOOL
ENVIRONMENT.
INSTRUCTIONAL TIME ALL TOGETHER
WE'VE GOT TO START GETTING THERE
IN TERMS OF WHAT ARE THE MOST
INTENSIVE REMEDIES AND AN ON THE
SPOT -- ACCOMMODATIONS THAT WE
CAN BE MAKING FOR THESE KIDS TO
HELP THEM STAY ON THE PATH FOR
AS LONG AS THEY'RE IN OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOL CARE SO I I THINK YOU FOR
THIS.
DR WEB YES MR HOLDEN WELL THANK
YOU I THINK YOU BROUGHT THIS
FOURTH ONCE BEFORE WE HAD A
CONVERSATION ABOUT IT SOME WHILE
AGO.
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU --
STICKING WITH IT AND BRINGING IT
FORWARD.
I ONLY HAVE ONE PROBLEM AND THAT
IS THERE'S NO REQUIREMENT THAT
THE HOME WOULD BE GREAT IT.
AND I I AND I AND AND THAT IS
STATED THERE -- AND I HAVE A
REAL CONCERN ABOUT THAT --
BECAUSE I THINK -- I'M IF MY
UNDERSTANDS CORRECT OUR SCHOOLS
ARE STILL GETTING PAID EIGHTY
EIGHT WHEN KIDS ARE SUSPENDED.
SO THE MONEY IS STILL COMING
INTO THE SCHOOLS TO SUPPORT THE
SCHOOL WILD KIDS ARE NOT THE
YOURSELF -- HAVING GIVE HOMEWORK
AND THEN HAVE NO ONE TO GREAT IT --
MAYBE THE PARENTS DON'T HAVE THE
BACKGROUND EXPERIENCE TO BE ABLE
TO UNDERSTAND THE SUBJECT MATTER
IF THE DEAL WITH ALGEBRA
WHATEVER IT MAY BE.
IT JUST SEEMS TO ME THAT -- IT'S
NICE TO TO HAVE THEM LOOK AT THE
MATERIAL I THINK IT'S BETTER TO
TO KEEP THEM IN THE PROCESS TO
HAVE THE TEACHERS OF GRADE
MATERIAL.
I YOU KNOW I JUST I I SAW THAT I
THOUGHT WELL WHY WOULD.
YOU GIVE HOMEWORK IN SOME CASES
SEAT IS BUSY WORK UP BECAUSE
IT'S NOT BEEN GREAT.
AND SO THEY'RE NOT EVEN SURE IF
THEY'RE UNDERSTANDING THE
MATERIAL WHEN THEY COME BACK TO
THE CLASS THAT THEY HAVE THE
SAME HOPEFULLY UNDERSTANDING AS
OTHERS.
BEING SUSPENDED FROM SCHOOL IS
PUNITIVE ENOUGH YOU KNOW NOT
WHICH APPEARS AND TO LEARN THE
KID MIGHT THINK IT'S A GREAT
THING.
BUT I THINK AS A PARENT WE KNOW
THAT THAT IS A HORRIBLE THING TO
HAPPEN FOR YOUR CHILD MS TWO
DAYS.
OR WHATEVER IT MAY BE -- SO I
DON'T KNOW WHY MAYBE YOU COULD
TELL ME WHY WOULD NOT ASKING
FOLKS TO GRADE THE HOMEWORK.
THAT WOULD GIVING WORK BUT WE'RE
NOT ASKING TO BE GRADED RIGHT --
I APPRECIATE THE THE QUESTION
DOCTOR WHATEVER I IT'S A
RECOMMENDATION OF THE CHAIR OF
THE COMMITTEE THAT.
IT WAS NOT.
NOT WHAT.
THAT THAT I I I DIDN'T.
THAT ACTUALLY DID NOT COME FROM
THE COMMITTEE BUT I THINK THAT'S
A CONVERSATION YOU SHOULD HAVE
GOING FORWARD.
ABOUT WHETHER NOT TO AMENDED TO
ENSURE THAT IT IS GREAT AND I
GET.
I GET THE CONCERNED WHY WOULD
YOU HAVE THEM DO IT IF IT'S NOT
GREAT MY OWN CLASSROOM HONESTLY
I I DIDN'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
THE SIGNING WORK TO STUDENTS
SUSPENDED AND THEN GRADING IT.
WASN'T A CHALLENGE TO ME IT
SEEMS LIKE A NO BRAINER THAT YOU
WOULD DO THAT SO I THINK WE
SHOULD DO IS KIND OF LIKE GOING
FOR WHETHER OR NOT YOU SHOULD
INCLUDE THAT.
I I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO DO
TO INCLUDE IT -- AND AND I I I
UNDERSTAND IT'S IT'S I DON'T
THINK IT SHOULD BE ACTUAL WORK
OF THE TEACHERS WILL BE GREEN
HOMEWORK ANYWAY.
I WOULD HOPE THAT A TEACHER
WOULD HAVE THAT MAYBE IT'S
SUSPENDED STUDENTS THAT BETTER.
IT BECOMES.
A YOU KNOW UNBELIEVABLE BUT AT
THE SAME TIME I I THINK IT HAS
VALUE TO BE ABLE TO FOR THE
STUDENTS KNOW THAT THIS WORK
MATTERS -- AND AND THEY NEED TO
TAKE IT SERIOUSLY AND IT ALSO
GIVES SOME LEVERAGE TO PARENTS.
TO GET THE WORK DONE AND GET IT
DONE A CORRECTLY BECAUSE THEY'RE
GOING TO GET SOME RESPONSE BACK
AS TO HOW WELL THE STUDENT DID
FOR THOSE TWO DAYS THEY HAD TO
DO.
IT WOULD HOME DOING HOMEWORK SO.
I THINK AS YOU MOVE FORWARD YOU
MAY WANT TO CONSIDER I THINK IT
STRENGTHENS IT MUCH MORE THAN
JUST SIMPLY ASKING FOR CAUSES
LIKE MAYBE BUSY WORK WHATEVER.
THAT IT OUGHT TO HAVE SOME VALUE
AND IT KEEPS THE STUDENTS ON
TRACK WITH THE CLASS I CAN AGREE
WITH YOU MORE DOCTOR WEBER AND
THIS YEAR SO WITH YOUR
CONCURRENCE WE WILL CONTINUE TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH THE BILL.
ON YOUR OF TODAY AND WE WILL
LOOK.
TO SEE THAT -- ISSUE RESOLVED
THANK YOU ALONG THE WAY THANK
YOU FOR THAT.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION.
SOMEBODY WOULD BUT IF NOT I'LL
MOVE IT SO MOVE.
THE MOOD IS SECOND MINISTER
MCCARTY MAKE CLOTHES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL --
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
THE MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL AYE
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA I CARP MCCARTY.
I SMITH SMITH I WEBER.
WEBER AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT.
ACCUSER.
IT IS SIX OH TO THOSE OUT WE'RE
NOW GOING TO MOVE TO A FINAL
NUMBER TWENTY THREE AB TEN
NINETY SEVEN YOU MAY.
PROCEED WHEN READY MR HOLDEN AB.
TEN NINETY SEVEN I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR -- IF WANT TO START
OFF AGAIN WITH THIS BILL IS THE
LAST BY TAKING THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR WORK IN ASSISTING US IN.
A GIVEN DIRECTION AND ALSO --
PLEASE TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS -- THIS BILL IS MEANT
TO BEGIN A CONVERSATION AROUND
CREDIT RECOVERY CLASSES IN
CALIFORNIA.
CREDIT RECOVERY PROGRAMS LET'S
STUDENTS WHO FAIL A CLASS
RECOVERY CREDIT THE ABBREVIATED
MAKE UP.
COURSES [inaudible]
DONE WELL.
THE RECOVERY PROGRAMS PROVIDE
STUDENTS WITH A LEGITIMATE
SECOND CHANCE TO GRADUATE ON
TIME.
BUT SOMETIMES BUT SOME
PARTICULAR HIGH VOLUME PROGRAMS
OF QUALITY CONTROL PROBLEMS THAT
CREATE A SECOND TRACK TO
GRADUATION THAT A ROAD SCHOOL
CULTURES AND LOWERS EXPECTATIONS.
PARTICULARLY FOR DISADVANTAGED
STUDENTS UNFORTUNATELY TOO
LITTLE IS KNOWN ACROSS THE
NATION AND IN CALIFORNIA ABOUT
THE QUALITY OF THESE PROGRAMS.
WE SHOULD INCREASE ATTENTION TO
THESE RAPIDLY EXPANDING PROGRAMS
TO ENSURE THEY ARE HELPING NOT
HARMING STUDENTS STRUGGLING TO
GRADUATE.
CURRENTLY CDC CUT COLLECTS NO
DATA ON CREDIT RECOVERY PROGRAMS
AND THERE IS NO DEFINITION OR
REGULATION OF CREDIT RECOVERY
AND STATUTES.
AB TEN NINETY SEVEN IS A
TRANSPARENCY MEASURE THAT
DIRECTS CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO REPORT.
ON THE USE OF CREDIT RECOVERING
CALIFORNIAN ALSO DEFINES CREDIT
RECOVERY IN STATUTE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
BOTH.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
OR ANY WITNESSES.
KNOW WHAT THIS IS -- ANY
OPPOSITION.
SEEN OPPOSITIONAL BRING IT BACK
ANY COMMENT.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED SEE
NO COULD COME IN FOR MANY THE
COMMITTEE -- THE MOTION IS
SUPPORT AS AMENDED -- YOU MAY
CLOSE I RESPECT LAST FOREVER.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MOSHE
SUPPORT AS AMENDED.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL --
AYE O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA [inaudible]
I MCCARTY.
I SMITH SMITH I WEBER.
WEBER AYE.
THE BILL SIX POSTS IT IS OUT.
IT WILL NOW GO.
TO BUT WE'RE NOT GONNA TAKE UP
THE CONSENT CALENDAR
[inaudible]
CONSENT.
ARE THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS AS
FOLLOWS.
THURMOND STURNIDAE SO.
CONSENT -- CALORIES AS FOLLOWS --
FILE ITEM FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE
AB -- FIVE TWO FIVE FILE ITEM
TEN AB FIVE FORTY THREE WITH
AMENDMENTS.
FILE AND TWENTY AB NINE EIGHT
EIGHT WITH A MOMENT'S FINE
NUMBER TWENTY ONE AB. TEN EIGHTY
ONE WITH THEM I WOULD NOTE NOT
WITHIN MOMENTS -- FILE THAT I'M
TWENTY TWO A. B. TEN EIGHTY FIVE
WITH AMENDMENTS THAT IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR -- DO WE HAVE A
MOTION.
AND MOVED.
MISTER MCCARTY WILL SECOND --
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR [inaudible]
CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE FILE ITEM NINE AB FIVE
TWENTY FIVE FILE ITEM TEN AB
FIVE FORTY THREE WITH AMENDMENTS
FILE ITEM TWENTY AB NINE EIGHTY
EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS FILE ITEM
TWENTY ONE AB TEN AB TEN EIGHTY
FIVE WITH AMENDMENTS TO BE TAKEN
AND HEALTH COMMITTEE.
HI O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA HIVE MCCARTY.
THE EYES SMITH SMITH I WEBER.
WEBER AYE. SIX VOTES THE CONSENT
COME A CALENDAR HAS PASSED WE'RE
NOW GOING TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT [inaudible]
MR BERMAN.
FILE THURMAN IS -- BERMAN SO
THEY SAID THURMAN.
HE GOES FOR WHAT.
YOU KNOW YOU SIGNED IN YOUR NAME
BETTER TODAY OR NOT GERMAN.
SO I EIGHT L. TO BETTER BE.
TODAY I AM VERY PROUD OF YOU
MISTER BERMAN BERMAN.
BUT IT'S THE A. B. THIRTEEN
TWENTY TWO FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY SIX WELL KNOWN OR TWENTY
SIX MISTER BERMAN YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- I WILL
KEEP ON WORKING ON MY HAND
WRITING IT WAS NOT MY STRONGEST
GRADE IN SCHOOL CLEARLY.
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH SERVICES
PLAY A KEY ROLE IN ENSURING THAT
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS ARE SAFE AND
READY TO LEARN.
SINCE EARLY NINETEEN NINETIES K.
THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS OF AN
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE
REIMBURSEMENT FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR DIRECT HEALTH
SERVICES PROVIDED AT SCHOOL
SIDES.
THROUGH SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
PROGRAMS INCLUDING FOR EXAMPLE
THE LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCY
MEDICAL BILLING OPTION PROGRAM.
DUE TO A RECENT FEDERAL CHANGE
THESE PROGRAMS THAT USED TO BE
ONLY AVAILABLE FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION STUDENTS.
ARE NOW OPEN ALL MEDI CAL OKAY
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS.
THIS CHANGE ALLOWS FOR MANY MORE
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS TO RECEIVE
HEALTH SERVICES AT SCHOOL
INCLUDING HEALTH EVALUATIONS
PHYSICIAN SERVICES AND MENTAL
HEALTH AND COUNSELING SERVICES.
WHEN POORLY TREATED HEALTH AND
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS CAN
HAVE A DEVASTATING IMPACT ON
SCHOOL ATTENDANCE BEHAVIOR?
AND ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT.
IN CALIFORNIA THERE'S NO
INSTITUTIONALIZED PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES WHICH OVERSEES
MEDICARE NOW AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
COORDINATE VARIOUS HEALTH
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES.
DELIVERED THROUGH SCHOOLS.
AB THIRTEEN TWENTY TO ESTABLISH
AN OFFICE A SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
PROGRAMS WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ADMINISTERING HEALTH
RELATED PROGRAMS IN ADVISING ON
ISSUES RELATED TO THE DELIVERY.
OF SCHOOL BASED MEDICAL SERVICES
IN THE STATE.
WITH THE EXPANSION OF
ELIGIBILITY TO RECEIVE FEDERAL
FUNDS FOR SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
SERVICES THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR AN OFFICE OF SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH PROGRAMS TO PLAY A VITAL
ROLE.
IN ASSISTING SCHOOLS THAT WISH
TO PARTICIPATE IN THESE PROGRAMS
TO DRAW DOWN FEDERAL FUNDS
ENSURING THAT CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS MAY CONTINUE RECEIVING
HEALTH.
AND MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AT
SCHOOL SITES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE ON A. B. THIRTEEN
TWENTY TWO AND WITH ME OUR LEASE --
EISENBERG FROM THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH ALLIANCE.
AND TONI TRADUCTOR GUERO FROM
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
LISA EISENBERG ON THE POLICY
DIRECTOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH ALLIANCE WE
ARE PROUD TO SPONSOR OF AB.
THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO I'M OUR
ORGANIZATION HAS BEEN ONE OF THE
LEADING VOICES IN CALIFORNIA FOR
TWENTY YEARS BRINGING TOGETHER
HEALTH AND EDUCATION
STAKEHOLDERS.
AND WE ARE EXCITED THAT THIS
BILL IS A NATURAL NEXT STEP IN
STRENGTHENING THE COLLABORATION
BETWEEN THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
THIS COMMITTEE HAS SEEN A NUMBER
OF BILLS RELATED TO SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH YOU'VE DONE INFORMATIONAL
HEARINGS ON THE SCHOOL MENTAL
HEALTH WELLNESS.
SO YOU ALL ARE WELL WELL AWARE
OF THE GREAT NEED FOR SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH SERVICES.
AND ALSO THE BENEFIT OF
PROVIDING HEALTH SERVICES IN
SCHOOL SETTING AND I'M NOT GOING
TO COVER A BUNCH OF DATA -- YOU
MIGHT ALSO BE AWARE OF HOW
DIFFICULT IT IS TO BRING THESE
TWO VERY DIFFERENT SILOS
TOGETHER HEALTH AND EDUCATION.
SCHOOLS ARE NOT NATURALLY SET UP
TO BE HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS AND
BILL HEALTH CARE FUNDING STREAMS.
NOR DOES OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
THAT'S FAMILIAR WITH DOCTORS
CLINICS HOSPITALS.
AUTOMATICALLY UNDERSTAND HOW OUR
SCHOOLS ARE OFTEN AT THE FRONT
LINES FOR ENROLLING KIDS IN
HEALTH COVERAGE IDENTIFYING
STUDENTS WITH ASTHMA SCREENING
STUDENTS FOR DEVELOPMENTAL
DELAYS RECOGNIZING MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES TO NAME A FEW.
ALSO AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN
HAS NOTED -- WE ANTICIPATE THAT
THERE'S THIS GREAT CHANGE COMING
THAT WILL ALLOW OUR SCHOOL
MEDICAID PROGRAM TO OPEN UP
REIMBURSEMENT FOR SCHOOLS.
NOT JUST TO STUDENTS IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION BUT STUDENTS -- AND
MEDICAL STUDENTS OVERALL THIS IS
EXCITING THIS IS GONNA DRAW DOWN
THE NUMBER OF REVENUES IN
REVENUE FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
AND IT'S GOING.
TO GROW THE ROLE THAT SCHOOLS
ARE PLAIN IN PROVIDING SOME OF
THESE HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
I'M.
THIS IS GOING TO MEAN AN
INCREASED DEMAND FOR A STATE
LEVEL COORDINATION AND STATE
LEVEL SUPPORT AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO OUR SCHOOLS --
THESE ARE OURALL REASONS WHY WE
BELIEVE THAT THERE IS A GROWING
NEED FOR BETTER COORDINATION
BETWEEN THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
OTHER STATES DO THIS MEDICAID IN
EDUCATION WORK WELL TOGETHER AND
OTHER STATES TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE DO
TRAININGS -- AND PLAN FOR FEW.
STANCHION -- WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL AND URGE YOUR EYES
THANK YOU AGAIN YOUR NEXT
WITNESS MISTER CHAIR TONY TOOK
CARE ON THE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
THE SERGEANTS DISTRIBUTED TO YOU
AN ABBREVIATED COPY OF A MARCH
FOURTEENTH LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE EXAMINATION OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES THE AUDIT POINTS OUT
CALIFORNIA RANKS FORTIETH IN THE
COUNTRY.
AND IS CONSISTENTLY BELOW 50%
FOR UTILIZATION RATES PREVENTIVE
SERVICES FOR CHILDREN -- ON MEDI
CAL IN CALIFORNIA AND LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET A HUNDRED AND
FORTY FIVE HUNDRED AND FORTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
PROPOSITION.
NINETY EIGHT DOLLARS WERE
IDENTIFIED FOR REPAYMENT.
THAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN THIS
YEAR TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
FROM SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
DH CS DID NOT CONTEST TO DISPUTE
THE AUDIT OF A HANDFUL OF SCHOOL
PROGRAMS.
BUT THE HUNDRED FORTY FIVE
MILLION REPAYMENT IS SPREAD
ACROSS ALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
A PARTICIPATING IN THE LA.
MEDI CAL BILLING PROGRAM HAD DH
CS PROVIDED MORE ADEQUATE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO SCHOOLS
AND PROTESTED THE AUDIT FINDINGS.
SCHOOLS WOULD HAVE HAD AN
ADDITIONAL HUNDRED AND FORTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THIS YEAR
OF MUCH NEEDED DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT STUDENTS.
LAST YEAR THE GOVERNOR SIGNED
THE CHAIRS A. B. THIRTY ONE
NINETY TWO REQUIRING HEALTH CARE
SERVICES.
IN CONSULTATION WITH HALEY AGE
THE AD HOC WORK GROUP IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF ED TO PREPARE AND
COMPLETE A FISCAL AND COMPLIANCE
AUDIT GUIDE. TO THE LA A MEDI
CAL BILLING PROGRAM IT IS A
COMPLEX SYSTEM IN SCHOOLS
REQUIRE REQUIRE CLARITY AND
CONSISTENCY IN THE
ADMINISTRATION.
OF THE PROGRAM TO APPROPRIATELY
BILL FOR THE HEALTH SERVICES
THAT THEY PROVIDE.
THIS IS KEY TO SCHOOLS
CONTINUING TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROGRAM.
IN RECENT YEARS SCHOOL DISTRICTS
HAVE HAD TROUBLE RECEIVING CLEAR
AND CONSISTENT GUIDANCE FROM DH
CS ON HAD A BILL FOR SERVICES IN
A COMPLIANT MANNER AND IN SOME
CASES.
PRIOR AUDITING STANDARDS HAVE
BEEN RETROACTIVELY APPLIED TO
CURRENT CLAIMS SOME SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAVE CEASED
PARTICIPATING IN THIS PROGRAM
BECAUSE OF THESE PROBLEMS.
THIS HAS A DIRECT IMPACT ON THE
ABILITY OF AN ALLEY A TO PROVIDE
HEALTH SERVICES TO STUDENTS.
RUN SMOOTHLY AND MAXIMIZE
FUNDING ELIGIBILITY SCHOOLS
REQUIRE SUPPORT FROM STATE
AGENCIES RESPONSIBLE FOR BOTH
HEALTH AND EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
AB THIRTY TWO THIRTEEN TWENTY TO
ESTABLISHING OPS OF SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH WILL ASSIST SCHOOLS BY
PROVIDING TECHNICAL CAUSES.
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE NOW NOT
AVAILABLE FROM DH CS THE
EXPANSION OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES LATER THIS YEAR WAS TO
SCHOOLS IN PROMOTING HEALTHIER
OUTCOMES.
PREVENTING PROBLEMS FROM
OCCURRING IN ADDRESSING BEHAVIOR
ISSUES IMPEDING STUDENTS FROM
SUCCESS WHICH IN TURN WILL HELP
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES FEEL SAFE.
INCREASE STUDENT ENGAGEMENT AND
STUDENT SUCCESS LASTLY WE'D LIKE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THIS COMMITTEES
VICE CHAIR AND SHARES WORK THIS
YEAR ON ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
FORTY SIX AUTHORIZING COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH PLANS TO CONTRACT
WITH DAILY A IS. TO PROVIDE YOU
EAT PST T. SERVICES TO MEDICAL
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS EVAN ELLIE A
DOES NOT CONTRACT WITH THE
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH PLAN GREAT.
THANK YOU WE GOT THANK YOU WE
WON AND I BOTH -- BECAUSE IN ANY
OF THE OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
THOUSAND TEACHERS FOR HEALTHY
KIDS IN FULL SUPPORT BECAUSE
SCHOOLS NEED A VOICE AND HEALTH
THANK YOU.
DR SHERRY COVERED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES
ORGANIZATION IN FULL SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
LARA PRESTON ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
AND SUPPORT.
THE INJURY TO BE OFF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION SCHOOL
CANCERS IN SUPPORT.
IN THE GARAGE WITH THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT.
RON RAPIDLY HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT.
ERICA HAVE BEEN A BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
JEFF ROSS CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGISTS IN
SUPPORT.
DEANNA NEIGHBOR WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY INSTITUTE IN FULL
SUPPORT.
RESIDENTS ALSO WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS IN
SUPPORT.
SIR MICHAEL GAST IN WITH YOU
FORWARD IN FULL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION.
SINGLE OPPOSITION A CONSUMMATE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS DO WE HAVE A
MOTION.
THE MOVE BEEN MOVED -- AND
SECOND OF AYE MR MCCARTY -- YOU
MAY AND THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
HEALTH YOU MAY CLOSE RESPECT AS
WE ARE BOTH THE USER PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL TO PASS TO HEALTH IS
THE MOTION.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO HEALTH.
O'DONNELL AYE O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY [inaudible]
KALRA.
KALRA I MCCARTY.
I SMITH SMITH I WEBER.
WEBER I BILLS FIVE VOTED IS OUT.
THANK YOU REMOVE TO A FILE
NUMBER.
FOR A FINAL NUMBER TWO I'M SORRY
TWENTY SEVEN FIVE ON TWENTY
SEVEN IT'S AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
FOUR MISTER GIBSON.
NEXT UP WILL BE ON FILE I HAVE
MISSED CONSULTANT -- SHE'S HERE.
BUT WILL SKIPPER IF SHE'S NOT --
MISTER -- GIPSON YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN
FIFTY FOUR WHICH SEEKS TO ENSURE
CONSISTENT EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS.
FOR ALL FOR YOU WITH THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM
INVOLVEMENT THIS BILL SEEKS TO
REQUIRE THAT THE COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION IN COLLABORATION
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF PROBATION
IS DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT.
AN INDIVIDUALIZED TRANSITION
PLAN TO MEET THE ACADEMIC
BEHAVIOR SOCIAL EMOTIONAL AND
CAREER NEEDS.
OF ARE YOU TRANSITIONING FROM
JUVENILE -- COURT SCHOOL.
THIS IS NECESSARY BECAUSE THE
TRANSITION PERIOD WHEN YOU ARE
LEAVING TO THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
FACILITY.
IS AT TIMELY. TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOUNG PEOPLE DO NOT FALL THROUGH
THE CRACKS.
THEY MAY HAVE TROUBLE RE
ENROLLING.
IN SCHOOL GETTING NECESSARY
SCHOOL DOCUMENTS RECEIVING
CREDIT FOR THEIR COURT -- SCHOOL --
COURSE WORK GETTING --
INFORMATION ON COMPREHENSIVE
HIGH SCHOOL PROGRAMS THAT WILL
PREPARE THEM FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION AND ALSO CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES.
CURRENTLY IN CALIFORNIA SOME
COUNTIES HAVE TRANSITION PLANS
WITH THE DESIGNATED PEOPLE WHO
WORK WITH THE YOUTH AND
RECEIVING SCHOOL TO MAKING SURE
THAT THE TRANSITION OF THAT YOU.
GOALS ACCORDING TO PLAN.
THE KEY WORD IS PLAN.
BUT THERE IS THE ISSUE -- THAT
SOME KIDS AGAIN FALL THROUGH THE
CRACKS AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THROUGH THE THIS BILL
THIRTEEN FIFTY FOUR THE NO CHILD
FALLS BE THROUGH THE CRACKS
EXISTING LAW IN ACTIVE -- SIDE
OF AB TWENTY TWO OF SEVENTY SIX
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN REQUIRE
THE STE THE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND THE COUNTY
PROBATION DEPARTMENT TO HAVE A
JOINT TRANSITION PLAN.
POLICY THAT INCLUDES
COLLABORATION WITH RELEVANT
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
RELATING TO JUVENILE COURT
SCHOOL STUDENTS HOWEVER IT DOES
NOT GO FAR ENOUGH IN MANDATING
THAT THE TRANSITION SUPPORT
NEEDED. TO TRULY HELP YOU
CONTINUE THEIR EDUCATION WHEN
THEY RETURNED BACK HOME TO THEIR
HOME COMMUNITY.
THIS MANDATES -- IN THE BE --
ACTUALLY REFLECTS THE
RECOMMENDATION OF LEGISLATION
PASSED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FOURTEEN WHICH ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TO SEVENTY SIX THROUGH
ITS WORK GROUP.
THIS WORKGROUP RECOMMENDED THAT
THE COURTS SCHOOLS STUDENTS HAVE
A TRANSITION PLAN AND THAT THE
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTION HAVE A
DESIGNATED -- PERSONS TO ENSURE
A SMOOTH TRANSITION FOR THESE
YOUTH THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT
THE COURT SCHOOL STUDENTS GET
THE SUPPORT EDUCATIONAL SERVICES.
AND THE SCHOOLS DOCUMENTS NEEDED
TO TRANSITION EFFECTIVELY FROM
THE COURTS SCHOOLS BACK TO THE
APPROPRIATE ACADEMIC PROGRAMS IN
THE COMMUNITY.
EVERY YOUTH IN THE JUVENILE
FACILITY SHOULD HAVE A SUPPORT
SCHOOL RECORDS AND THEY SHOULD
BE ENCOURAGED -- TO ATTAIN
HIGHER EDUCATION AND ACHIEVEMENT
WITH ME TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONIES IS MISS LUCY --
CARTER AT ALSO MISTY AND CLARK --
MEMBERS OF THE RISE YOUTH --
CENTER TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONIES SUPPORTS UP.
THIRTEEN FIFTY FOUR MY NAME IS
DEANA CLARK I'M A MEMBER OF THE
RISE YOU'VE CENTER RICHMOND
CALIFORNIA I'M ALSO HIGH SCHOOL
SENIOR WHO GRADUATE WITH HONORS
IN JUNE.
UNABLE SEVEN TWENTY SEVENTEEN I
WAS FORMALLY INCARCERATED AT THE
JUVENILE HALL AND MARTINEZ
CALIFORNIA I DO NOT ENJOY MY
TIME THERE I WAS RELEASED ON A
SATURDAY AND MY RETURN HOME WAS
A VERY EASY.
BECAUSE I WAS A AND A MINOR AND
I DO NOT KNOW WHAT I COULD AND
COULDN'T DO I REMEMBER THE
FOLLOWING MONDAY I TRY GOING TO
SCHOOL AND I WAS IN THE SCHOOL
OFFICE FOR MY COUNSELOR
PRINCIPAL TOLD ME.
THAT I WAS AN OLD.
WHO NO LONGER WILL?
I HAD TO GO TO THE DISTRICT
OFFICE TO RURAL I ENDED UP AT
THE DISTRICT OFFICE WITH MY
GRANDMOTHER AND NO ONE HELPED AS
WE WAITED FOR AWHILE AND NO ONE
HELPED AS RECEPTIONIST TOLD ME
THAT SHE CAN HELP ME AND I'D
HAVE TO SCHEDULE A MEETING.
WITH SOMEONE ELSE ON A DIFFERENT
DAY.
I ENDED UP MISSING A FEW DAYS OF
SCHOOL WHILE I WAS MISSING
SCHOOL I CAN ARISE UNLESS STAFF
MEMBERS KNOW I HAD SHOVEL RING
ROLLING IN SCHOOL.
SOMEONE I RISE ON BACK TO THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT OFFICE AND ME
AND MY GRANDMOTHER AND I FINALLY
GOT A ROLE IN THE SCHOOL I WAS
GRATEFUL THAT I HAVE RISE IN
THAT I'M FINALLY GETTING WE ARE
WILLING TO SCHOOL.
IF I HAD I HAD RISE I'VE BEEN
WAITING FOR A LONGER PERIOD OF
TIME I WOULD HAVE HAD NO ONE TO
SUPPORT ME AND I WOULD HAVE
MISSING AMAZING OPPORTUNITIES
THAT I'VE HAD.
AS MY FRIENDS AND ASSOCIATES WHO
I'VE KNOWN TO BE INVOLVED IN
DOING THIS DO NOT JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THEY JUST GOT RELEASED AND NO
SUPPORT DROPPING OUT BECOMES
EASY DECISION FAILING BECAUSE
EASY DECISION CAN SING IN TO
MAKE THE WRONG DECISIONS IS
EASING OFF BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE SOMEONE TO EXPLAIN THE
TRANSITION PROCESS AND HELP THEM
THROUGH IT.
I SUPPORT AB THIRTEEN FIFTY FOUR
BECAUSE I LIKE TO SEE IS JOHNSON
IS TRANSITION PROCESS HAPPENED
THIS BILL WOULD BE PASSED
BECAUSE YOU'LL BE BETTER TO HELP
INDIVIDUALS LEAVING THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THANK YOU VERY WELL DONE THANK
YOU.
HI I'M LUCY SAUCEDO CARTER AND
WITH THE YOUTH LAWCENTER.
WE'RE SPONSORING THE BILL
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT WITHOUT THE
PROPER SUPPORTS IN PLACE TO HELP
COURT SCHOOL PUPILS.
TRANSITION.
AND CONTINUE THEIR EDUCATION
FROM COURT SCHOOL TO THE
COMMUNITY BASED SCHOOLS.
THEY ARE LIKELY TO DROP OUT.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT EDUCATION IS
KEY TO GIVING YOUTH ESPECIALLY
YOUTH WITH JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM INVOLVEMENT OPPORTUNITIES
TO PURSUE THEIR DREAMS AND HAVE
A HAPPY PRODUCTIVE LIFE.
AS MISS CLARK STORY EXEMPLIFIES
YOUTH ARE STILL STUGGLING TO RE
ENROLL IN SCHOOL THEY'RE
STRUGGLING TO GET PARTIAL CREDIT.
THEY'RE STRUGGLING TO GET THEIR
SCHOOL RECORDS.
THESE REQUIREMENTS ARE NOT BEING
MET BECAUSE CURRENT LAW DOES NOT
DESIGNATE ONE AGENCY ULTIMATELY
RESPONSIBLE FOR INSURING MAY
HAPPEN.
THIS BILL REQUIRES A TRANSITION
PLAN.
BUT JUST AS IMPORTANT IT
REQUIRES THAT THE COUNTY OFFICES
OF AT OVERSEE THE TRANSITION
PROCESS FOR ALL COURT SCHOOL
PUPILS REGARDLESS OF HOW LONG
THEY'VE BEEN IN THE FACILITY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON REFERRED
TO AB TWENTY TO SEVENTY SIX AND
THE WORK GROUP -- THE WORKING
GROUP IT'S ALWAYS SOUND POLICY
YOU KNOW TO CONSIDER LAWS AND TO
PASS LAWS BASED ON
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT HAVE COME
OUT OF WORKING GROUPS.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE APPOINTED.
BY SUPPORTING AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
FOUR YOU HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADVANCE LEGISLATION THAT BILLS
ON FORMER LEGISLATION AND ON THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE AB TWENTY
TWO SEVENTY SIX WORKING GROUP
YOU ALSO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO STRENGTHEN THE LIKELIHOOD
THAT THESE VULNERABLE CHILDREN
WILL CONTINUE THEIR EDUCATIONS
AND THRIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
RIVER NOW DIRECTOR OF EDUCATION
FOR THE CATHOLIC CHURCH IN
CALIFORNIA WHEN STRONG SUPPORT.
LARA PRESTON ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
IN SUPPORT.
MORE SECONDSALSO THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS IN
SUPPORT.
JACQUELINE RODRIGUEZ FORMERLY
INCARCERATED STUDENT AT COLLEGES
ON THE TAIL IN SUPPORT.
HI -- JASMINE FRY YOU JUST AS
PROGRAM MANAGER AT RICE CENTER
AND WE ARE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION SING
OPPOSITION ANY COMMENTS FROM ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
A MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU MISTER IS RIGHT.
I WANT TO THANK -- OUR WITNESS
FOR TESTIFYING YOU KNOW
SOMETIMES WE GET BILLS AND IT
TAKES A MINUTE TO FIGURE OUT BUT
PROBLEM THE BILL IS TRYING TO
FIX I THINK -- IN A VERY BRIEF
PERIOD OF TIME HE MADE IT VERY
CLEAR.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THAT --
IT'S A VERY HELPFUL AND I THINK
THIS EXEMPLIFIES A MAJOR ISSUE
THAT WE HAVE AND IF THE CREATES
A SOCIETAL SELF FULFILLING
PROPHECY.
IF WE'RE NOT HELPING THE YOUTH
ARE TRYING TO DO THE RIGHT THING
REGARDLESS OF OF WHAT TROUBLE
THEY MAY NOT NEED TO BE WANT.
WHAT IT WE SAY WE WANT TO YOU TO
GET BACK ON TRACK AND WE DON'T
HAVE TO PROVIDE THE TOOLS TO DO
IT?
THEN -- THEN IT'S OUR FAULT IT'S
HARD TO THE PLACE TO BE ON US
AND NOT ON THE YOUTH ARE TRYING
TO THE RIGHT THING SO I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS ECONOMIC.
AND WILL MAKE THE MOTION THANK
YOU THANK YOU SOME OF OUR GIPSON
GREAT THANK YOU LIMIT THE BILL
FROM A MOVE TO ME A SECOND.
GET DEALS AND SECOND ANY OTHER
CALLS FOR THE COMMITTEE MEMBER
SINGLE COMMENTS -- THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO ROUTE.
DID.
YOU MANAGE TO ACCEPT THE AMENDED
STRIKES UP THE MAIN MESSAGE
THANK THE STAFF WILL WORK WITH
MY STAFF TO STRAIGHTEN THIS BILL
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS YOU MAKE CALLS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ON THIS BILL IS ALL
FOCUSED ON MAKING SURE THAT THE
MOST VULNERABLE -- YOUTH AMONG
US HAVE THE SUPPORT
TRANSITIONING AND SO I
APPRECIATE DR ALL THANK YOU
THANK YOU -- PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THE MOTION AGAIN IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
SHE IS THE PASSES A MINUTE TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL AYE AYE
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY [inaudible]
KALRA.
KALRA I'D MCCARTY.
SMITH.
SMITH I WEBER.
WEBER AYE.
THE BILL HAS FOUR VOTED IS OUT.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO HEAR FROM IT
MISS SMITH.
AB NINE EIGHTEEN IT'S FILE ITEM
NUMBER [inaudible] SIXTEEN YOU
MAY PROCEED WHEN READY.
IT'S AB [inaudible] NINE
EIGHTEEN NINE YES -- HOT WELL
ONE MOMENT.
WHAT'S THE FILE ITEM
[inaudible]
IT'S A FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN THEN
RIGHT. EIGHTEEN IT'S A A. B.
NINE SIX SEVEN BY MISS SMITH
GOING TO PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MISTER
CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES I WOULD LIKE
TO OPEN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS RESOLVE
THE STRIKE LANGUAGE REGARDING
NEW AND ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS
FOR EL CAP ENGAGEMENT.
AND TO CHANGE CHARTER EL CAP
REQUIREMENTS TO BE APPROVED BY
THEIR AWESOME AUTHORIZED --
RATHER THAN THE COUNTY.
AS AMENDED AB NINE SIX SEVEN
INCLUDES CHARTER SCHOOL
COMMUNITIES IN THE EL CAP
PROCESS AND SUPPORTS THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR'S
GOAL OF ALIGNING CHARTER SCHOOL
TRANSPARENCY.
AND ACCOUNTABILITY WITH THAT OF
ALL STATE ELEAZAR. FOR FIVE
YEARS CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS HAVE
BEEN TASKED WITH DEVELOPING DATA
DRIVEN AND RIGOROUS LOCAL
ENGAGEMENT AND MEANINGFUL
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT PROCESS
SEES IN EL CAP DEVELOPMENT AND
DELIVERY.
YELL CFF REQUIRES THAT ELEAZAR
CONSULT WITH PARENTS STUDENTS
AND THE COMMUNITY AS THEY
DEVELOP THEIR AL CAPS AND
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT SCHOOLS
THAT HAVE MEANINGFUL ENGAGEMENT
WITH THEIR COMMUNITIES.
HAVE BEEN THE MOST SUCCESSFUL AT
ELIMINATING ACHIEVEMENT GAPS.
DURING MY TENURE AS A SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER WE HAD AN EXTREMELY
ROBUST EL CAP PROCESS.
IN SO DOING WE WERE ABLE TO
ENGAGE PARENTS AND STUDENTS AND
STAFF IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF A
VERY USEFUL PLANNING TOOL.
UNFORTUNATELY AT PRESENT NOT ALL
PARENTS AND STUDENTS HAVE THE
ABILITY AND MEANS TO ACCEPT
ACCESS THEIR SCHOOL BOARDS AND
PARTICIPATE IN THE EL CAP
PROCESS.
AB NINE SIX SEVEN BRINGS CHARTER
SCHOOLS INTO ALIGNMENT WITH ALL
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
PROVIDES THE EL CAP AS A UNIFORM
AND STANDARD BASIS FOR
COMPARISON TO MONITOR STUDENT
OUTCOMES ACROSS THE EIGHT STATE
PRIORITIES AND TARGETED
SUBGROUPS ACROSS ALL PUBLIC
SCHOOLS.
I AM CONFIDENT THAT THIS
CONSISTENCY WILL LEAD TO GREATER
COMMUNITY SUPPORT FOR ELLIE A
AND CHARTER ENDEAVORS.
AND A CLEAR ROADMAP FOR ELLIE A
AND CHARTER BUDGET PRIORITIES
AND AN ONGOING FOCUS ON
IMPROVING OUTCOMES FOR ALL OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS -- WITH ME
OUR RYDELL SPENCER MASSARO FROM
PUBLIC ADVOCATE SPONSORS OF THE
MEASURE AND MARYLAND WE ARE A
MOTHER OF STUDENTS WHO WOULD
BENEFIT FROM.
EIGHTY NINE SIX SEVEN YOUR FIRST
WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHARLES ON
MEMBERS MY NAME IS RACHEL
SPENCER MASSARO.
AND I'M A SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY
OF PUBLIC ADVOCATES. TWO YEARS
AGO CHARTER SCHOOL PARENTS IN
RICHMOND SEVERAL OF WHOM ARE
HERE PRESENT TODAY.
REQUESTED A CHARTER SCHOOL EL
CAP TRAINING HAVING SEEN PUBLIC
ADVOCATES DELIVER MANY SUCH
TRAININGS TO WEST CONTRA COSTA
SCHOOL DISTRICT PARENTS OVER THE
YEARS.
THIS TASK MORE DIFFICULT THAN
EXPECTED SORRY JUST RAN FROM THE
GALLERY.
WE COULD NOT FIND MANY OF THEIR
SCHOOLS ALL CAPS AND OTHERS
REFLECTED ONLY A FRACTION OF THE
SUPPLEMENTAL IN CONCENTRATION
FUNDING RECEIVED.
AT THE TRAINING PARENTS DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND WHY THEIR SCHOOLS HAD
FEWER OR NO REQUIREMENTS AROUND
ALL COPPING GAUGE MEANT
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
AS COMPARED TO THEIR DISTRICT
COUNTERPARTS.
AFTER THIS TRAINING PUBLIC
ADVOCATES CONDUCTED AN ANALYSIS
OF SEVENTY CHARTER SCHOOL --
CAPS PUBLISHED IN AUGUST OF LAST
YEAR.
WE FOUND THAT ONE THIRD OF ALL
CHARTER SCHOOLS EXAMINED HAD NO
WELL COP ONLINE EVEN AFTER EMAIL
REQUESTS TO THE SCHOOL.
OF THE CUPS WE COULD FIND MORE
THAN TWO THIRDS OF THE STATE
FUNDS GENERATED BY HIGH NEED
STUDENTS OVER THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
WERE UNACCOUNTED.
FOR ONLY 21% CLEARLY MEASURED
HOW THE ENGAGED PARENTS AND
SCHOOL DECISION MAKING.
AND ONLY 37% DESCRIBE HOW
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT IMPACTED
THEY'RE ALL CAUGHT PLANNING
PROCESS. 91% OF THE CHARTER
SCHOOL SERVING 15% OR MORE
ENGLISH LEARNERS TO NOT POST
THEIR L. COPS IN THE LANGUAGE
OTHER THAN ENGLISH.
AND NONE PROPERLY DOCUMENTED HOW
THEY WERE INCREASING OR
IMPROVING SERVICES TO HIGH NEED
STUDENTS AS A LAW REQUIRES
DURING GAUGE MY TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY. EIGHTY NINE
SIXTY SEVEN WOULD ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES AS INTRODUCED THIS
MEASURE IS ALSO REGISTERED
SUPPORT FROM PARENT LEADERSHIP
ACTION AT WORK IN OAKLAND.
FAITH IN ACTION EAST BAY AND
THEY WERE GOING TO SOUTHERN IN
POMONA SACRAMENTO AREA
CONGREGATIONS TOGETHER.
COMMON ADVOCATES IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND CONTRACT WHEN WEST
CONTRA COSTA PARENTS COUNCIL IN
RICHMOND THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
AND COMMUNITY KNOWLEDGE IS POWER
MY NAME IS SOMEBODY LIKE WAY
YEAH I'M A PARENT FROM BENEATH
THE HOTTEST ELEMENTARY AND WHICH
ONE CHARTER ACADEMY MIDDLE%
SCHOOL BOTH OF WHICH ARE PART OF
THE A. MET.
PUBLIC SCHOOLS ARMS CHARGE
MANAGEMENT ORGANIZATION THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY.
SO. TO SUPPORT AT IN CHARTER
SCHOOLS TO THE L. C. F. F. LAW.
MY SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL IS A
STRONG US MY ADVOCACY FOR
QUALITY EDUCATION. FOR ALL
STUDENTS ESPECIALLY LOW INCOME
AND ENGLISH LEARNER STUDENTS.
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE AN OPTION
NOT A SOLUTION. FOR QUALITY
EDUCATION AND LIKE TRADITIONAL
PUBLIC SCHOOLS CHARTER SCHOOLS
BENEFIT FROM FAMILY ENGAGEMENT
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
THE ANSWER REGIONAL SCHOOLS ELK
UPS ARE ONLY LIGHT ONLINE
INSURANCE RELATED BUT IT IS
UNCLEAR HOW THE SCHOOLS MY
CHILDREN SAID TEN HAD SPENT.
MILLIONS IN SUPPLEMENTAL AND
CONCENTRATION FUNDS OVER THE
YEARS LAST SCHOOL YEAR ELK UP TO
WHAT'S NEVER FINALIZED AND MANY
DATA POINTS WERE MISSING
SOMETHING HERE.
ABOUT THE ALCOTT PARENT
ENGAGEMENT.
I HAVE ALWAYS AS A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT DATA BUDGET
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT AND STUDENT
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL NEEDS MY
ADVOCATES OF HAS NOT BEEN WELL
RECEIVED AND AFTER I BEGAN
ASKING MY CHILD'S ACADEMIC
PROGRAMS REPORT.
ATTENDEE MORE MEETINGS TO ASK
ABOUT BY LAST.
ENGINES BERING SEA I WAS
PROHIBITED FROM GOING TO MY
DAUGHTER'S SCHOOL FOR SIX DAYS.
IS RETALIATION SHOWED ME TO MY
CORE BUT HE DID NOT STOP.
MY INVOLVEMENT IN ADVOCACY I
CONTINUED TO ATTEND MEETINGS
REQUESTING DOCUMENTS
INTERPRETATION IN MY LANGUAGE.
ESPECIALLY AT BOARD MEETINGS THE
LACK OF TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY AND REAL FAMILY
ENGAGEMENT IT'S CLEAR IN MY
CHARTER SCHOOL.
AND MANY CHARTER SCHOOLS.
WE LOOK AT THE PROCESS OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICT PARENTS RECEIVED
A PARENT ADVISORY COMMITTEES AND
PUBLIC HEARINGS AND I WONDER WHY
WE'RE NOT GIVING SUCH
OPPORTUNITIES AT INVOLVEMENT.
I REQUEST YOUR AYE WHAT FOR
EIGHTY NINE SIXTY THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
ELIZABETH ASK OF ALL THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS WE HAD AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
BUT WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEES -- THOROUGH ANALYSIS
OF THE BILL AND APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE HAD
WITH THE AUTHOR HER STAFF AND
THE SPONSORS YOU WITH THE
CHANGES WE WILL BE -- MOVING OUR
POSITION TO SUPPORT.
CAITLYN JENNER BE HAVE THE SAME
CISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
NICK ROMAN ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY DISTRICT
ADVOCATES FOR BETTER SCHOOLS AND
SUPPORT.
JEFF BARKER RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
SUPPORT WITH THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS.
ME NUMBER IS THAT THE MY LAI
ANYA.
ME HOLSTEIN MAKING WASTE.
CHARTERED YOUR BOY YOU.
ARE THEY LEYVA SAY SEE IT.
MY NAME IS BERTHA MATANYA MY SON
IS MAKING WAVES CHARTER SCHOOL
AND I SUPPORT AB NINETY SIX
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT SEEING NO
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
BLOOM IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT GET
UP THERE ALL RIGHT HI MY NAME IS
BRANDON RIOS PRINT SOME BARLOW
CALIFORNIA WE'RE HERE SO QUIRK
SB [inaudible]
SIX THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS YOLANDA LOPEZ MY HAVE
YOU SIGN A SAW MAKING WAY SUCH
KIND OF ME -- I SO. FOUR NINE
SIX SEVEN THANK YOU.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
BETWEEN THE LEFT AND THEN THIS I
AM A PINE.
UP FOR SCHOOL IN I HAVE TWO
CHILDREN AND I AM IN SUPPORT AB
LIKE. SEVEN SEVEN SIX SEVEN
THANK YOU.
RON RAPPER BE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT.
SEC BRAMBER HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE BRINGING THIS
BILL TO OUR MEETING OF CJ STATE
COUNCIL THIS WEEKEND AND I
ANTICIPATE WILL BE IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MARC THE ALBERTA
THE CESSATION OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS WE HAD AN
APOSTLE AS AMENDED ON THE
ORIGINAL PORTION OF THE BILL
WITH THE AUTHORS AMENDMENTS AT
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH US.
WE'RE GOING TO RECONSIDER
SUPPORT POSITION THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
ANY ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ALICE KESSLER HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER
SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION --
WE CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE
TRANSPARENCY AND PARENT
ENGAGEMENT THAT THE BILL SEEKING
TO ACHIEVE A WE DO WANT TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR
AROUND -- THE EL CAP AND OF THE
DISTRICT AS THE RECEIVING THE EL
CAP WE DO THINK THAT -- THERE
SHOULD BE SOME -- SEPARATION
THERE GIVEN THE EXISTING PROCESS
FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS -- WITH
ACCOUNTABILITY AND HOW THE EL
CAP IS ALIGNED SOLOOK FOR TO
CONTINUING TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HELLO HOW ARE AND ON BEHALF OF
THE CHARTER SCHOOLS DEVELOPMENT
CENTER AND WE ALSO APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE WORKING WITH
US BOTH IN THE DISTRICT WITH
THEIR CHARTER SCHOOLS.
AND HERE IN THE CAPITAL WITH
YOUR STAFF WE HAVE SOME CONCERNS
THAT REMAIN UNADDRESSED SO WILL
CONTINUE WITH OUR OPPOSE
POSITION BUT WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH YOUR OFFICE AND
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT OF THAT
THANK YOU.
MISSING NO OTHER OPPOSITION IT
COMES FROM THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
DR YES I WANT TO THANK YOU AND
TAKING ON THIS OBVIOUSLY
MONUMENTAL TASK TO LOOK LIKE --
IT'S SOMEONE I GOT KIND OF
CONFUSED BETWEEN BECAUSE THEY
LOOK LIKE YOU RE WRITING THE IT
COLD OR SOMETHING YOU HAD SO
MUCH STUFF IN IT.
SO MANY DIFFERENT IT IS AND IT
BECAME DIFFICULT TO FIGURE OUT
WHERE WE WERE WHAT WAS GOING ON
WHAT WAS NOT I THINK THE
AMENDMENTS HELPED ME A LITTLE
BIT IN TERMS OF OF NARROWING IT
IN ON ON THE CRITICAL ISSUE I
ASSUME THIS IS ABOUT.
BASICALLY TRANSPARENCY IN PEOPLE
GETTING ACCESS TO L. CAPS I MEAN --
SO I IT.
IT TOOK A LONG WAY TO GET THERE
BUT IN TERMS OF THE BILL BUT I
THINK THAT'S WHAT IT IS -- I'LL
BE SUPPORTING IT AS I CONTINUE
TO LOOK TO SEE WHAT IS THERE
BECAUSE I WAS SOMEWHAT I THINK
YOU TOOK UP THE FOSTER.
BOSTON THING AND IT'S A LOT OF
OTHER THINGS THAT WOULD BE A
THAT I THOUGHT.
KIND OF TOOK ME OFF TRACK AND
THEN BROUGHT ME BACK SO -- BUT I
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR DESIRE TO
MAKE SURE EL CAPS ARE -- BEING
OF A BEING MADE AVAILABLE TO ALL
COMMUNITIES AND AND I THINK IT'S
MORE THAN JUST CHARTER IS SO
TRUE BECAUSE I GET THE SAME
COMPLAINTS.
IN MY DISTRICT FROM REGULAR
SCHOOL THAT PEOPLE ARE NOT BEING
AND GAZE ROUTE YOUR CAT SO YOU
DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON AND
THEY'RE NOT GETTING THE
INFORMATION.
AND THAT HELPING TO WRITE THE
PLANS SO THERE'S A THERE'S A
GOING CONCERN -- I WOULD BE
CONCERNED ABOUT GOING TOO FAR
WITH IT BECAUSE WE WERE IN THE
MIDST OF AN AUDIT RIGHT NOW AND
YOU'LL SEE IF THEY HAVE.
AN L. CAPS WILL BE A PART OF
THAT AUDIT AS WELL AS THE KINDS
OF ISSUES APPEAR ENGAGEMENT
TRANSPARENCY AND ALL THAT STUFF
WILL BE COMING OUT OF THE AUDIT.
AFTER SIX YEARS YOU PROBABLY
NEED TO LOOK AT WHAT WE'VE DONE
AND MAKE SURE IT BASICALLY IS
BEING DONE IN THE BEST INTEREST
OF KIDS SO I THANK OU FOR
TAKING ON THIS TASK.
THANK YOU.
SEE NO FURTHER THAT'S ONE OF
THANK YOU MISS SMITH -- I I I I
TO BELIEVE ALL SCHOOL COMMUNITY
SHOULD HAVE A ACCESS -- TO TO TO
STRONG ALL CAP PROCESS AND WITH
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT SO
APPRECIATE.
OF THIS BILL AND MOTIONS TO PASS
THE MANAGER PROPRIOCEPTIVE YOU
MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I'M
WITH RESPECT TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN DIEGO I APPRECIATE YOUR
REMARKS IN FACT THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WE MAY DID REFINE THIS BILL
TO A MUCH NARROWER FOCUS RIGHT.
MAKING SURE THAT WERE FIRST
FOCUS IS ON GETTING -- WITH THE
PARENTS ENGAGE THAT WE CAN'T
MAKING SURE THAT ALL PUBLIC
SCHOOLS INCLUDING OUR CHARTER
COMMUNITIES ARE ENGAGED IN THIS
PROCESS AND THEN MOVING FORWARD
WE'RE REALLY GOING TO BE LOOKING
AT POST AUDIT.
AND THEN SOME MORE ENGAGEMENT
WITH OUR STAKEHOLDER GROUPS ON
HOW WE ENSURE THAT WE'RE BEING
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT EL CAP WORK
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL MAKING SURE
THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE THE
TOOLS AND EQUIPMENT THEY NEED TO
HAVE THIS BE A ROBUST ENGAGEMENT
PROCESS.
ALONG WITH A REFINED USE OF
STATE RESOURCES INTO THAT
REACHING THOSE EIGHT STATE
PRIORITY SO I THINK YOU FOR YOUR
REMARKS AND COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU -- PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS -- DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
OF DOT IS MOVED AND ALL STE
MISTER CROWLEY ONE SECOND ROW I
WILL.
HE MOVED A SECOND.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO KALRA [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
SMITH.
SMITH I WEBER.
WEBER AYE THE BILL HAS THREE
VOTES IT IS ON CALL [inaudible]
WITH THAT.
WILL MOVE -- TO FILE ITEM NUMBER.
THIRTEEN THIS IS A MAP.
TO THE CHAIR.
TO OKAY WE SHOULD JUST ON THE
BILL OKAY SO WHERE WE GOING NOW.
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN IS GONZALEZ
YOU MAY PROCEED ALREADY IT'S FUN
MY THIRTEEN OF EIGHTY SEVEN
SEVEN THREE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS.
I'D LIKE TO STARTUP ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN SEVEN THREE
WOULD HELP EQUIP OUR YOUNG
ADULTS WITH THE SKILLS NECESSARY
TO BECOME ELECTORALLY ENGAGE
CITIZENS.
BY REQUIRING LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO IMPLEMENT VOTER
EDUCATION PROGRAMMING FOR HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS.
IN RECENT YEARS THIS BODY HAS
PASSED SEVERAL PIECES OF
LEGISLATION AIMED AT INCREASING
VOTER REGISTRATION IN MAKING IT
EASIER FOR PEOPLE TO CAST THEIR
BALLOTS.
HOWEVER IN THE PROCESS OF
EXPANDING ACCESS TO DIFFERENT
VENUES.
THROUGH WHICH TO CAST BALLOTS
SOME INDIVIDUALS MAY FEEL
OVERWHELMED AND SIMPLY CONFUSED
THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE FOR OUR
NEWEST VOTERS.
MOST YOUNG PEOPLE LEARN HOW TO
VOTE AT LEARN HOW VOTING WORKS
BY WATCHING THEIR PARENTS OR
OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS PARTICIPATE
IN THE PROCESS.
HOWEVER DUE TO DEMOGRAPHIC
CHANGES MANY YOUNG CITIZENS NOW
COME FROM FAMILIES IN WHICH NO
ONE HAS EVER VOTED OR MAY NOT BE
EVEN ELIGIBLE TO VOTE. FOR THOSE
STUDENTS THAT DO NOT LEARN HOW
TO VOTE FROM THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS THE OTHER PRIMARY AVENUE
IS THROUGH THEIR CIVICS
EDUCATION CURRICULUM.
WELL I CURRICULUM FRAMEWORK
INCLUDES A CIVICS EDUCATION
COMPONENT THERE IS NO MANDATED
OR SPECIFIED INSTRUCTION MODEL
THE TEACHERS MUST IMPLEMENT IN
THE CLASSROOM.
THIS RESULTED INSTRUCTION
MODULES THAT VARY FROM CLASSROOM
TO CLASSROOM IN SOME INSTANCES
CAN BE GLOSSED OVER IN A LESSON
PLAN.
THIS ULTIMATELY RESULT IN A
YOUNG ADULT POPULATION THAT IS
UNCERTAIN WITH HOW TO
PARTICIPATE ELECTORAL PROCESS
IT'S NO LONGER ENOUGH TO SIMPLY
REGISTER YOUNG VOTERS WE NEED TO
LITERALLY TEACH YOUNG PEOPLE HOW
TO VOTE IN DEMYSTIFIED ENTIRE
ELECTORAL PROCESS.
AB SEVEN SEVEN THREE WILL HELP
DO THAT BY REQUIRING THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND THE SECRETARY OF
STATE TO DEVELOP EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMMING FOR IMPLEMENTATION
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
LOCAL COUNTY ELECTION OFFICIALS
WILL ALSO BE REQUIRED TO ENSURE
THAT THE PROGRAMMING IS
SPECIFICALLY TAILORED TO LECTURE
IN SYSTEM IN THEIR COUNTY.
I HAVE A FEW WITNESSES WITH ME
HERE TODAY AND I ULTIMATELY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE DOCTOR WEBER.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR SHARON
WHITEHURST PAIN AND I AM THE
BOARD PRESIDENT OF THE SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
SAN DIEGO UNIFIED IS PLEASE TO
WORK WITH THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
LORENA GONZALEZ.
AS A CO SPONSOR OF ASSEMBLY BILL.
SEVEN SEVEN THREE THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TO WORK WITH COUNTY ELECTION
OFFICIALS TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT VOTER EDUCATION
PROGRAM IN FOR HIGH SCHOOL
SENIORS.
WE SUPPORT THAT BECAUSE IT WOULD.
HELP OUR STUDENTS TO ACQUIRE
THAT TANGIBLE KNOWLEDGE THAT
THEY NEED.
IN ORDER -- TO BECOME REGISTERED
VOTERS AND TO VOTE.
I AM TOTALLY I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT SAN DIEGO HAS ALREADY BEEN
ON THAT PATH IN THIS PAST
SEPTEMBER.
WE HAD THE A CONGRESSMAN FROM
JOHN LEWIS FROM WASHINGTON DC TO
SPEAK TO MORRIS HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS AND THEY ARE STILL
TALKING ABOUT THAT AND I'LL.
TO REGISTERING STUDENTS IN
GETTING INVOLVED THEMSELVES WE
ALSO HAVE OUR SECRETARY OF STATE
AT LINCOLN HIGH SCHOOL.
AND OUR STUDENTS GOT THE MESSAGE
THEY ARE THEY KNOW THE PROCESS
LOGISTICALLY BECAUSE FOLKS DON'T
REALIZE THAT A LOT OF TIMES IT
JUST STICKS.
IS A PROBLEM FOR THEM SO THEY
HAVE THAT TRAINING AND NOW
THEY'RE IMPLEMENTING IT WE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THIS AND
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD.
I REQUEST AN IPHONE FOR ME THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS STAFF.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING US TO
SPEAK TODAY WE APPLAUD THE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD.
THE DEPARTMENT APPRECIATES OF
BOTH -- THE THE AMENDMENTS --
THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT FOR THAT
WOULD ALLOW SOME STANDARDIZATION
OF THE EDUCATIONAL.
PROGRAM BY ALLOWING THE
DEPARTMENT TO WORK WITH THE
SECRETARY OF STATE BUT WE
FURTHER A PRIEST OF APPRECIATE
THE FLEXIBILITY THAT THE BILL
ALLOWS.
AND FOR COUNTY OFFICE ELECTION
OFFICES TO WORK ON THE PROGRAM
AS WELL AS THE FLEXIBILITY THIS
ALLOWS FOR LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES TO PROVIDE THIS IN AN
ENERGETIC -- PROACTIVE AND
ENERGIZE MANNER WHAT WE KNOW IS
WHEN STUDENTS ARE -- ENGAGE AND
ENERGIZE THEY PARTICIPATE WHEN
THEY PARTICIPATE -- THEY'RE OUT
THERE IN THE VOTE AND WE KNOW
THAT IF WE WANT TO HELP ELEAZAR
BE -- PROVIDE TOOLS AND
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS TO THEIR
STUDENTS TO BECOME MORE ACTIVE
CITIZENS IN THEIR COMMUNITIES --
IN THEIR COLLEGES AND ON THE
WORLD STAGE.
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
IS SOMEONE THE LONG ON BEHALF OF
SECRETARY OF STATE ALEX BUT THE
YEAH I LIKE TO THINK THAT A
COMMITTEE IN THE AUTHOR ON
RECENT AMENDMENTS AND MORE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MELISSA ROMERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAVE CONSERVATION
VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME'S ERIC CARES WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
MICHAEL SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL AN URGENT
AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
TONY TO KERO CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
INTERESTING BROWN CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS IN
SUPPORT.
SHANNON PRIMER EDUCATIONAL PRESS
A PARALEGAL AND GOVERNMENT
TEACHERS OF WIFE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION
ANY OPPOSITION SAYING OPPOSITION
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO EMOTION.
GEN MOVED SECOND AND IN SECOND
AND DO WE HAVE ANY.
YES ONE THANK YOU FOR THE ONE
FOR MY PRESIDENT OF A SCHOOL
BOARD COMING TODAY TO MAKE
DILLON SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BILL.
THERE'S ANOTHER BILL THE
TRAVELING ALMOST IN THE SAME
PATH I'M NOT SURE IF YOU HEARD
IT THIS MORNING -- THAT DEALS
WITH -- VOTER EDUCATION IN HIGH
SCHOOLS SO HOPEFULLY YOU GUYS
WILL COORDINATED BECAUSE I THINK
THERE'S SOME SIMILARITIES
BETWEEN THE TWO BUT I SUPPORT
THIS THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER COMMENTS FROM A
COMMITTEE MEMBER SAYING ON YOU
DO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS.
YES OKAY THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE THE TWO ELECTIONS
AND REDISTRICTING -- YOU MAY
CLOSE.
I I JUST WANNA POINT OUT FOR DR
WEBBER THAT I THINK IT'S
ASSEMBLY WOMAN AT GARY CURRY'S
BILL AND I'M A CO AUTHOR ON THAT
TO ANOTHER ON THAT BILL AS WELL.
THERE IS THERE SOME DIFFERENCES --
WHAT WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO DO
HERE IT'S HARD TO KIND OF GET
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS A
REALIZATION THAT A LOT OF OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE NEVER EVEN
SEEN A BALLOT?
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT THE FINALLY
REGISTER THEM IN AND THEN WHAT
WHAT DO YOU DO AND I KNOW -- FOR
FOR GROWN ADULTS THE FIRST TIME
THEY VOTE IT CAN BE SCARY BUT
WHEN YOU'RE EIGHTEEN AND YOU'RE
EXPECTED TO JUST GO FIND.
POLLING LOCATION AND YOUR NAME
IN CASE SOME BALLOTS ARE
CONFUSING AND WHAT YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO DO JUST THAT FEAR OF
NEVER BEING EXPOSED -- IT IS IS
A BARRIER AND SO WE WANT TO TRY
TO REDUCE THAT WITH THE LEAST
AMOUNT TIME POSSIBLE FROM
CURRICULUM AS POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU I RESPECT LASSEN ABOUT
THANK YOU THANK YOU KNOW JUST A
COMMENT AS A CLASSROOM TEACHER
OFTEN HAD KIDS REGISTER IN CLASS.
AND HATE TALK ABOUT THE PROCESS
VOTING IMPORTANCE OF IT AND THEN
THE LOGISTICS ASSOCIATE WITH I
THINK WOULD BE NICE IF THEY WERE
BETTER RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO
TEACHERS ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
SO YOU CAN ACTUALLY BRING A
VOTING BOOTH IN THE CLASS MEAN
ACTUALLY SHOW THE MACHINE AND
SHOW THEM THAT PROCESS BECAUSE
I'VE SEEN ADULTS.
WHO ARE CONFUSED BY THAT PROCESS%
SO TO THE EXTENT THAT YOUR BILL
CAN ADDRESS THAT AS WELL I HOPE
IT DOES -- WITH THAT -- THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE ELECTIONS AND REDISTRICTING
REDISTRICTING COMMITTEE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO ELECTIONS AND REDISTRICTING.
O'DONNELL O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO KALRA.
MCCARTY.
SMITH SMITH I WEBER.
WEBER I THE BILL IS ON CALL AS
THREE VOTES. THREE ROOMS.
VOTER FILE ITEM I MISS REYES
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
ONE EIGHTY SIX FILE ITEM.
ONE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. TO THEIR PRESENT AB SIX
A BILL WHICH CREATES THE BRANCH
OF EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION.
INCREASING THE CAPACITY IN
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION FOR ALL
OF EARLY CHILDHOOD PROGRAMMING.
THIS GOVERNMENT STRUCTURE CAME
AS A RECOMMENDATION FOR THE
SPEAKERS A BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION ON EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION.
THIS COMMISSION WORKED
DILIGENTLY FOR TWO YEARS AT
ASSESSING ALL ASPECTS OF THE
VERY COMPLEX EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION STRUCTURE WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND THEREAFTER PREPARED A
COMPREHENSIVE REPORT.
WITH A LONG ARRAY OF PLANS. TO
EXPAND EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
FROM CHILD CARE TO PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS WITH PROPOSALS BY
EVERYONE FROM THE BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION THE GOVERNOR AND A
MULTITUDE OF LEGISLATORS.
IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE ELEVATE.
EXISTING GOVERNANCE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO BE ABLE TO
HANDLE THE COMING INFLUX.
OF PROGRAM EXPANSION.
THIS NEW BRANCH WILL HELP
SUPPORT THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION SUCCEEDING WHILE THE
LEGISLATURE THE GOVERNOR
CONTINUE TO FOCUS EFFORTS ON
EXPANDING THIS CRUCIAL ACCESS TO
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION.
THE VERY NATURE OF EARLY
CHILDHOOD.
EDUCATION REQUIRES A VARIETY OF
STATE AGENCIES MIXED MATHIS
DRILL DELIVERY SYSTEMS OF CHILD
CARE AND PRESCHOOL AND HAS A
DIVERSE ARRAY OF STAKEHOLDERS
WITH PARTICULAR NEEDS.
THE COORDINATION OF EFFORTS
WITHIN THE NEWLY CREATED BRANCH
OF EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
WILL ENSURE THAT ALL PROGRAMMING
REMAINS COORDINATED HIGH QUALITY
AND SUPPORTIVE OF THE FAMILIES
THE PROGRAM SERVES. FOR THE MORE
PRO ACTIVE EXAMINATION CREATION
OF GOVERNANCE STRUCTURES FOR
RAPIDLY EXPANDING AREAS OF
EDUCATION RATHER THAN REACTIVE
CAN ENSURE THAT THE PLAN SET
FORTH BY THE GOVERNOR THE BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION.
AND OUR COLLEAGUES ARE
SUCCESSFULLY ADMINISTERED FROM
THE START.
THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT HIGH
QUALITY EARLY EDUCATION.
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION IS THE
GREATEST EQUALIZER THE
CALIFORNIA SHOULD PROVIDE FOR
FAMILIES AND CHILDREN.
AND THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE
BRANCH OF EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION WILL ENSURE THAT WE
PROVIDE THESE SOCIO ECONOMICALLY
AND DEVELOPMENTALLY
TRANSFORMATIVE PROGRAMS IN A
COORDINATED AND EFFICIENT MANNER.
HERE WITH ME TODAY TO SPEAK MORE
ON THE ISSUE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PARENT TEACHERS ASSOCIATION IS
DONNA ARE TO COVERAGE
[inaudible]
AFTERNOON.
REMEMBER OF DIAL UP IT'S NOT ON
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OF DONALD AND MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS DONNA ARE TO COVERAGE.
I AM A FORMER TEACHER AND A
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER I ALSO HOLD
A MASTER'S DEGREE IN EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION SO THIS.
THIS ISSUE IS VERY DEAR TO MY
HEART BY THE WAY I'M A MIDDLE
CHILD ALSO.
I'M HERE THIS AFTERNOON WELL.
I AM HERE THIS AFTERNOON
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SIX THE RESEARCH AND THE EXPERTS
AGREE THE EARLY YEARS OF A CHILD
ARE THE MOST CRUCIAL IN TERMS OF
BRAIN DEVELOPMENT.
PROVIDING QUALITY EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION DURING THESE YEARS
ENHANCES A CHILD'S OPPORTUNITY
TO SUCCEED IN THE K. TWELVE
SYSTEM.
ALL OF YOU HERE ON THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE OUR FOCUS ON HOW TO
MAKE OUR K. TWELVE EDUCATION
SYSTEM BETTER.
WHAT CAN WE DO TO HELP THE
CHILDREN OF CALIFORNIA SUCCEED
IN SCHOOL AND BEYOND? ONE WAY
ONE CENTRAL CONCRETE RELATIVELY
SIMPLE WAY TO IMPROVE OUR K.
TWELVE SYSTEM IS TO FOCUS ON THE
EARLY YEARS. FIVE FIVE WHEN A
CHILD ENTERS OUR SYSTEM.
WELL IT'S ALMOST TOO LATE.
IF CHILDREN DO NOT HAVE ADEQUATE
CARE AND EDUCATION IN THEIR
EARLY YEARS THEY QUICKLY FALL
BEHIND IN SCHOOL AND HAVE A
REALLY HARD TIME CATCHING UP.
OUR PRESENT SYSTEM OF CARING FOR
IN EDUCATING INFANTS TODDLERS
AND YOUNG CHILDREN IS IN
DISARRAY.
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION AND
CARE IS HANDLED BY MULTIPLE
AGENCIES HOUSED IN MULTIPLE
LOCATIONS AND REQUESTS MULTIPLE
AND DUPLICATE THE FACT
APPLICATIONS.
PARENTS DO NOT KNOW WHERE TO GO
TO SEE CHILD CARE PRESCHOOL
SERVICES THEY'RE CONFUSED AND
CONFOUNDED AND OFTEN GIVE UP.
OR PERHAPS TO NOT EVEN KNOW THAT
ASSISTANCE IS AVAILABLE.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE OF
PARENTS WHO WORK MULTIPLE JOBS
AND OUR LOW INCOME EARNERS.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE OF
PARENTS WHO SPEAK ANOTHER
LANGUAGE AND ESPECIALLY TO OF
PARENTS LOOKING TO ENTER THE
WORKFORCE WONDERING HOW TO
JUGGLE.
CHILDCARE AND A JOB BY CREATING
THE EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
GRANTS BRANCH UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION THERE
WOULD BE ONE CENTRAL LOCATION
FOR PARENTS ONE CENTRAL OFFICE.
TO COORDINATE SERVICES AND GIVE
PARENTS THE ASSISTANCE THEY NEED
TO FIND QUALITY HEARING SPOT FOR
THEIR YOUNG CHILDREN.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PTA
STRONGLY SUPPORTS THIS IDEA WE
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
EARLY YEARS AND WE AYE VOTE ON
AB SIX THANK YOU -- OTHERS IN
SUPPORT TONY TOOK CARE ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
RON RAPPER BE AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION TEACHERS
AND SUPPORT.
THE ONE REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA
DIVISION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY
YOU DO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS YES
SIR.
GREAT THANK YOU -- ANY COMMENTS
MANY THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- I
KNOW I'M SORRY ANY OPPOSITION.
SING OPPOSITION THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED IT IS SECOND MY
DOCTOR WEBER -- AGAIN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO HUMAN
SERVICES YOU MAKE CLOTHES.
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MISSION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO HUMAN SERVICES
O'DONNELL.
AYE O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO KALRA [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
SMITH SMITH I WEBER.
WEBER AYE.
THE BILL HAS RESULTED IS ON CALL
THANK YOU -- MISS GARCIA IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER [inaudible] FOR AB.
TWO TWO ONE FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR THANK YOU CHAIR ADVENTUROUS
JUST TO CLARIFY WE HAVE THREE
WITNESSES AND SUPPORTED THROUGH
AND THIS IS IN OPPOSITION TODAY.
BY PREVIOUS ARRANGEMENT YOU MAY
PROCEED.
THANK YOU I WANT TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS ON PAGE
ELEVEN OF THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
WHEN I THINK THE CHAIR AND THE
STAFF FOR THEIR EFFORTS.
ON THIS BILL.
BEFORE I BECAME A STATE
LEGISLATOR I TAUGHT MATH FOR
THIRTEEN YEARS AND PUBLIC
SCHOOLS -- LOW INCOME MOST OF
THEM ARE -- FREE AND REDUCED
LUNCH ENOUGH COLOR.
AND I GOT TO SEE FIRSTHAND HOW
EXPERIENCE MATTERS TO THE
STUDENTS EXPERIENCE INTO THEIR
SUCCESS.
I GOT TO SEE MY GROWTH OVER THE
THIRTEEN YEARS FROM BEING A
NOVICE TEACHER TO BE IN A
PROFICIENCY SIR.
AND I WOULD HOPE BY THE END I
WAS A GOOD TEACHER I DON'T KNOW
IF I WAS AN EXCELLENT TEACHER.
I ACTUALLY GOT TO SEE SOME OF
THE SAME STUDENTS THAT I HAD MY
FIRST YEAR OR WHEN I WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE TEACHING THEM PRE
ALGEBRA.
AND THEN I WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
TEACHING IN GEOMETRY THIRTY
YEARS LATER AND I GOT TO SEE THE
BEARS I HAD IN TEACHING GEOMETRY
BECAUSE THEY HAD ANOTHER PAGE
WITH A LIST WAS HAVE TAUGHT THEM.
THE FIRST TIME AND THAT'S
CANNELLA WHEN I SAY IT'S KINDA
HAVE THIS.
IDEA IN MY BELLY OF OF THIS
PIECE IN IT WELL I'VE BEEN HERE --
FOR THIS IS MY SEVENTH YEAR IT
I'VE TAKEN A WHILE TO SAY TO
JUMP INTO THE INTO THIS INTO THE
SPACE -- AND TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THAT EXPERIENCE AT THE END
OF THE DAY I WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE HAVE.
QUALIFIED EXPERIENCED TEACHERS
WITH OUR MOST VULNERABLE
STUDENTS OUT THERE -- AND SO
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT TO DAY
SEVEN TWO DAYS AB TWO TWENTY ONE
TO PROHIBIT OR LIMIT UNDER
TRAINED AND UNTRAINED.
TEACHERS FROM IN TERM PROGRAMS
OF NOW OUTLINED.
IN.
THE AMENDMENTS WHICH INCLUDES
TEACH FOR AMERICA.
WE KNOW THAT IT TAKES ABOUT
THREE YEARS TO BECOME PROFICIENT
IN THE CLASSROOM WE KNOW THAT A
LARGE NUMBER OF STUDENTS IN DATA
HAS BEEN HARD TO ABSTAIN TO
OBTAIN AND DEPENDING ON HOW YOU
TALK TO OR TALKING ABOUT. 70% OF
THOSE TEACHERS ARE 85% OF THOSE
TEACHERS EVEN WITHIN THREE YEARS
THE CLASSROOMS ARE RIGHT WHEN
THEY'RE GETTING TO PROFICIENCY
WERE LOSING THEM -- WE KNOW THAT
THE STUDENTS -- ARE ARE.
THE STUDENTS HAVE A LOT OF
BARRIERS IN FRONT OF THEM -- AND
AS HER LEARNING ON THE JOB WITH
THEM WE'RE CREATING HOLES FOR
THEM ALONG THE WAY IN AFFECTING
THEIR EARNING POTENTIAL DOWN THE
ROAD.
AS I EXAMINED THE DATA FURTHER
ON TV AND LEARN MORE ABOUT THE
CENTER PROGRAMS I'VE ALSO
LEARNED THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ARE PAYING ABOUT FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR FOR THE PLACEMENT
OF THESE YOUNG PROFESSIONALS
INTO.
THEIR CLASSROOMS MONIES THAT I
FEEL SHOULD BE SEEN IN THE
CLASSROOMS WHETHER IT'S FOR
TEACHER INCREASE US SALARIES
WHETHER IT'S FOR ADDITIONAL
TRAINING OR JUST FOR OUR
STUDENTS OUT THERE -- WHICH IS
IN LINE WITH THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WE HAVE I'D ACCEPTED -- I'VE
BEEN REPLACED BY THIS ISSUE AND
I HAD KNOWLEDGE WE HAVE A
TEACHER SHORTAGE BUT I'M LET
MYSELF ASKING THE QUESTION IS
THIS REALLY THE SOLUTION.
OR IS THIS PART OF THE EXCUSE
FOR US TO CONTINUE TO HAVE A
TEACHER SWORDS THAT WAS AROUND
WHEN I WAS THE TEACHER TWENTY
YEARS AGO WHEN I STARTED AND
IT'S BEEN A LONG LONGER.
THAN THAT'S HIS NAME FEELS LIKE
MATH AND SCIENCE THAT ARE SO
HIGHLY IMPACTED ON AND SO I
APPRECIATE THAT DISCUSSION THAT
WE'RE HAVING TO DAY WITH ME I
HAVE TO THE PEOPLE TESTIFYING WE
HAVE WILLIAM BASKETS HIGH LAKE
PROFESSOR OF EDUCATIONAL
LEADERSHIP AND POLICY STUDIES.
AND THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DOCTORATE IN EDUCATIONAL
LEADERSHIP I CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SACRAMENTO.
HAVE CERAMIDE SILLY MEMBER THE
TEACH FOR AMERICA PHILADELPHIA
CORPSE I HAVE AMBER CAM MEMBER.
OF THE TEACH FOR AMERICA ATLANTA
CLUBS IN TWO THOUSAND AND ONE
THESE INDIVIDUALS OF STUDY TFA
PROGRAM FOR DECADES PUBLISHED
PEER REVIEW REPORTS.
AND I DEDICATED TO SUPPORTING
THE TEACHING PROFESSION AND OUR
FUTURE EDUCATORS.
THEY ARE ALSO FORMER TFA CORPSE
MEMBERS -- AND SO I WILL HAND IT
OVER TO THEM.
I'M JOINED US BECAUSE LIKE
PROFESSOR OF A LEADERSHIP AND
POLICY STUDIES AT CAL STATE
SACRAMENTO I ALSO SERVICE THE
EDUCATION CHAIR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA AND DOUBLE ACP AND I
SERVE ON THE BOARD.
OF THE NETWORK FOR PUBLIC
EDUCATION AS A SCHOLAR I'VE
STUDY TEACH FOR AMERICA SINCE
TWO THOUSAND FIVE OUR FIRST PEER
REVIEWED STUDY OF TFA CO
AUTHORED WITH LINDA DARLING
HAMMOND.
WHO IS STATE BOARD EDUCATION
CHAIR WAS ENTITLED DOES TEACHER
PREPARATION MATTER EVIDENCE
ABOUT TEACHER CERTIFICATION
TEACH FOR AMERICA AND TEACHER
EFFECTIVENESS THIS STUDY IS
PROBABLY THE MOST PROMINENT
STUDY?
MOST PROMINENT PEER REVIEWED
STUDY OF OF TFA IN THE RESEARCH
LITERATURE IT'S BEEN CITED MORE
THAN TWELVE HUNDRED TIMES WE
EXAMINE THE ACHIEVEMENT OF
STUDENTS TOPIC TFA TEACHERS
COMPARED TO OTHERS.
IN A LARGE URBAN DISTRICTS
SETTINGS -- WE FOUND THE TFA
TEACHERS DID NOT PERFORM BETTER
THAN CERTIFIED IN TRAIN TEACHERS
IN MY WORK AS A FACULTY FELLOW
FOR THE NATIONAL EDUCATION
POLICY CENTER.
I'VE PROBABLY READ IT EVERY
SINGLE STUDY AND TEACH FOR
AMERICA AND STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT
FOR THE LAST FIFTEEN YEARS WHILE
MOST STUDIES DON'T SHOW A
POSITIVE EFFECT OF TEACHER
AMERICA.
THE STUDIES THEY DO FIND A
POSITIVE EFFECT TYPICALLY DON'T
FIND IN EFFECT UNTIL THE FOURTH
AND FIFTH YEARS AND PRIMARILY
ONLY IN MATH.
BUT BECAUSE 85% OF TO GIVE ME A
TEACHERS ARE GONE BY THE FOURTH
AND FIFTH YEARS I THINK YOU HAVE%
TO PUT A BIG ASTERIX BY THOSE
FINDINGS.
WE SHOULD CAN LOOK AND AND RE
ASSESS THE VALIDITY OF THOSE
FINDINGS.
I ALSO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT SAY
THE TFA IS NOT THE NEW CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT AS THEY HAVE
CLAIMED IN THE PAST MY MOTHER
ALWAYS TOLD ME SHOW ME WHO YOUR
FRIENDS ARE.
AND I'LL SHOW YOU WHO YOU ARE.
I THINK IT'S NOTABLE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA AND DOUBLE ACP LOU
ACT OUR NATION'S LARGEST AFRICAN
AMERICAN LATINO CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS ARE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL. FOR THE MORE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS REPRESENTED
BY SEE IF T. ARE ALSO SUPPORTING
THIS BILL IN CONCLUSION.
THE CALIFORNIA POLICE BE IN THE
NETWORK FOR PUBLIC EDUCATION
SUPPORT PARENTS IN OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS WHO DESIRE A HIGHLY
QUALIFIED TEACHER FOR EVERY
SINGLE STUDENT.
IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD SCHOOLS
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS THERE MIGHT CITY I
WAS A TEACH FOR AMERICA CORPS
MEMBER IN TWENTY ELEVEN AND THE
AUTHOR OF THE BOOK PUBLISHED BY
PETER LANG. FOR THE STUDY I
SURVEYED AN INTERVIEW TWENTY SIX
OF MY FELLOW CORPS MEMBERS IN
THE GREATER PHILADELPHIA REGION.
THREE SURVEYS INTERVIEWS
CONDUCTED OVER TWO YEARS THESE
TWENTY SIX TEACH FOR AMERICA
CORPS MEMBERS SHARE THEIR
EXPERIENCES WHICH COLLECTIVELY
PROBLEM TIES TEACH FOR AMERICA'S
APPROACH.
TEACH FOR AMERICA TO YOUR
ALTERNATE A TEACHER
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM THAT
FOCUSES ON RECRUITING.
GRADUATES FROM ELITE YOU NEVER
CITIES TO TEACH PRIMARILY POOR
STUDENTS OF COLOR.
TEACH FOR AMERICA'S FOUNDERS
STATED THAT THERE IS QUOTE
NOTHING ELUSIVE ABOUT SUCCESSFUL
TEACHING PEOPLE SIMPLY NEED TO
WORK HARD AND BE DISCIPLINED AND
QUOTE.
IN CONTRAST MANY TEACH FOR
AMERICA CORPS MEMBERS WORKING
VERY HARDAND WERE SEEKING TO
CARE FOR OTHERS.
BUT THEIR EXPERIENCES IN THE
CORE OR COMMONLY SELF DESCRIBED
WITH THE WORDS SHAME FAILURE AND
ISOLATING.
WITH LIMITED TEACHER TRAINING
AND AS THEY WERE BEING PLACED IN
UNDER RESOURCE SCHOOLS CORPS
MEMBERS REPORTED EXPERIENCING
NEW LEVELS OF ALCOHOL DEPENDENCY.
FATIGUE DEPRESSION TRAUMA PTSD
AS DIAGNOSED BY THEIR LICENSED
THERAPISTS.
DURING THEIR TWO YEAR TEACH FOR
AMERICA SERVICE COMMITMENT.
COR MEMBERS ARE TRYING THEIR
BEST TO SERVE STUDENTS BUT NOT
ONLY DID MANY CORPS MEMBERS IN
MY STUDY STRUGGLE AND LEAVE THE
CLASSROOM AFTER THEIR TWO YEAR
COMMITMENT.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT EVEN WHEN AN
INDIVIDUAL IS SUCCESSFUL BY
TEACH FOR AMERICA STANDARDS IT'S
NOT AN ACTING SYSTEMIC CHANGE.
IN OUR WORK TOWARD EDUCATIONAL
EQUITY IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE
HOLD OURSELVES TO PROVIDING
STUDENTS FROM LOW INCOME
FAMILIES THE SAME EDUCATIONAL
RESOURCES OPPORTUNITIES AND
FULLY PREPARED TEACHERS THERE
DEMANDED FOR STUDENTS FROM
HIGHER INCOME FAMILIES.
AB TWO TO ONE IS AN IMPORTANT
STEP FORWARD IN THIS DIRECTION
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS AMBER CAM I'M A
FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE STUDENT
AND I HAVE A PHD IN EDUCATION
FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF DENVER MY
JOB IS PREPARING TEACHERS TO
TEACH IN URBAN.
AND HIGH POVERTY SCHOOLS.
I AM ALSO A TF A CORE MEMBER
FROM ATLANTA.
TWO THOUSAND ONE I JOIN TO BE A
BECAUSE I THOUGHT I WAS
ORGANIZATION THAT RECRUITED
QUALITY -- SKILLED TEACHERS TO
TEACH IN HIGH NEED SCHOOLS --
WHEN I MATRICULATED TO TFA I HAD
A BACHELOR'S AND MASTER'S DEGREE
IN TEACHING AND THREE YEARS OF
TEACHING EXPERIENCE?
I WAS NOT THE TYPICAL T. AFFAIR
I WAS PREPARED I WAS EXPERIENCED
SADLY MY FELLOW CORE MEMBERS
WERE NOT.
MOST HAVE NEVER TAUGHT OR EVEN
TAKEN ONE TEACHING CLASS. FIVE
WEEKS OF TRAINING IN A BIT OF
SUMMER SCHOOL WAS NOT ENOUGH AND
SUDDENLY THEY WERE PLACED IN
SCHOOLS.
SERVING THE MOST VULNERABLE
MARGINALIZED STUDENTS IN OUR
COUNTRY.
IT WAS LIKE WATCHING UNTRAINED
PILOTS WITH ONLY FIVE WEEKS OF
FLYING EXPERIENCE -- TO TRY TO
TAKE OFF AND KEEP THE PLANE IN
THE AIR.
THEY BECAME FRUSTRATED DEPRESSED
ANXIOUS ANGRY IN A FEW DID WELL
THAT'S TRUE.
SOME LEFT AND 40% LEFT BY -- BY
THE END OF THEIR TWO YEAR
COMMITMENT 85% WERE STILL
TEACHING ONLY 85% LEFT AFTER
THEIR FIVE FIFTY YEAR -- IN THIS
CONTINUES TO HAPPEN I KNOW
BECAUSE I TEACH.
CORE MEMBERS RIGHT NOW AS A
PROFESSOR -- SOME SOME OF THEM
ARE REALLY AMAZING BUT MOST
LEAVE DISILLUSIONED AND IN THEIR
PLACE ARE HOLES FEELING OF
ABANDONMENT AND DESTABILIZATION
OF COMMUNITIES.
WHAT'S MORE IS TO BASED ON A
REALLY GOOD JOB OF COMMUTING OF
RECRUITING DIVERSITY LIKE ME FOR
EXAMPLE I COME FROM A WORKING
CLASS AND POOR COMMUNITY -- AND
I'M THE FIRST MY FAMILY GO TO
COLLEGE AND THEY RECRUIT PEOPLE
LIKE ME PEOPLE OF COLOR.
BUT BY PLACING UNPREPARED
MARGINALIZED TEACHERS IN THE
SCHOOLS THEY'RE BURNING OUT OUR
MOST PRECIOUS RESOURCE TEACHERS
OF COLOR AND FOR MOST OF THE
PRODUCTS THAT IT SAYS THESE ARE
THE ONES THAT LOOK LIKE AND
SOUND LIKE OUR KIDS.
I UNDERSTAND WE NEED TEACHERS
BUT WE NEED PEOPLE IN CLASSROOMS
WE BELIEVE IN KIDS POTENTIAL WE
ALSO NEED TO FIND WAYS TO
PREPARE LEADERS WHO UNDERSTAND
THE SEVERITY OF EDUCATION
JUSTICE.
BUT TFA IN PROGRAMS LIKE IT ARE
A BANDAID THEY DON'T PROVIDE
LONG TERM STABILITY.
IN FACT IF WE GOT DO SOME
DIGGING WE SEE TO HAVE A HOUSE
COSTS THAT OUTWEIGH THE BENEFITS.
BUT AS LONG AS WE CONTINUE TO
INVEST IN BANDAIDS THE WHOLE THE
WOMAN'S TOGETHER WE WILL NEVER
GO TO THE DOCTOR HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO ADDRESS THE DEEPER
INFECTION.
I ASKED TODAY THAT YOU ALLOW THE
CHIU DISALLOW UNDERPREPARED
TEACHERS TO EDUCATE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT RON
WRAPPING THE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS AND
SUPPORT.
SEPTEMBER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
DISCUSSED.
WE'RE EAGER TO SEE THOSE IN
PRINT -- BUT CERTAINLY SOUND
LIKE SOMETHING WE COULD SUPPORT.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT SEE NO
THERE'S A SUPPORT -- THE
OPPOSITION
.
YOU MAY PROCEED.
CHAIRMAN O'DONNELL VICE CHAIRMAN
KILEY AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS ASHLEY CAN PLAN I'M A
SIX YEAR TEACHER TEACHING AT
ALLEN AT SIGN BACK ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL IN SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA --
TO BE HONEST I'D RATHER BE WITH
MY CLASSROOM TODAY BUT I AM HERE
ON THE PATH MY STUDENTS -- I AM
HERE TO ASK YOU TO OPPOSE AN ILL
ADVISED BILL. EIGHTY TWO TO ONE
IS BAD FOR STUDENTS BAD FOR
SANTA FE AND BAD FOR CALIFORNIA.
IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN I WAS A
SECOND YEAR CORPS MEMBERS LISTED
HERE SOUNDS AIMED.
AT MANSON MIDDLE SCHOOL.
I KNEW I WANTED TO BE A
CLASSROOM TEACHER.
NTFA OFFERED ME THE CLEAREST
PATH TO BECOMING A TEACHER
IMMEDIATELY WITHOUT HAVING TO
PAY FOR YEAR OF GRAD SCHOOL OR
MOVE CROSS COUNTRY.
BUT BECAUSE OF CAFE I WAS ABLE
TO JUMP RIGHT INTO TEACHING AND
STAY ASK WHAT I LOVE.
TO WITHOUT TFA I WOULD BE A
PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER TODAY.
THROUGH GRANTS TO HAVE A GAVE ME
THE FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO PAY
FOR A DEPOSIT ON AN APARTMENT.
IN FOR MY CREDENTIALS WITHOUT IT
I WENT HAVE AFFORDED TO TEACH IN
SAN JOSE.
THIS IS THE POWER OF TFA IT
OPENS DOORS FOR DIVERSE
PASSIONATE SMART PEOPLE WHO
MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO AFFORD TO
BECOME TEACHERS REGARDLESS OF
THEIR SOCIOECONOMIC BACKGROUNDS.
THIS MAKES OUR SCHOOLS BETTER.
I AM HONORED AND HUMBLED TO SAY
THAT I WAS NAY MY SCHOOL'S
TEACHER OF THE YEAR THIS YEAR.
AND THIS WAS MADE POSSIBLE
BECAUSE OF TO GET A SUPPORT.
SOME OF THE BEST TEACHERS I'VE
EVER MET I TF A LAMB INCLUDING
MY MENTOR VICE PRESIDENT OF
SALES A TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WHEN I SANCHEZ.
THIS IS WHY I'M ASKING YOU TO
VOTE DOWN AB.
TWO TO ONE TINA FEY STRENGTHENS
OUR SCHOOLS MY COMMUNITY OF SAN
JOSE AND DISTRICTS ACROSS THE
STATE.
BECAUSE PRINCIPLES AND
COMMUNITIES THE ABILITY TO MAKE
THE BEST DECISIONS FOR THE
SCHOOLS AND STUDENTS.
WHY WOULD YOU TAKE AWAY THIS
LOCAL CONTROL?
AND MORE TO THE POINT WHY WOULD
YOU TAKE TEACHERS LIKE ME OUT OF
AYE DISTRICTS CLASSROOMS AND
AWAY FROM OUR STUDENTS.
PLEASE VOTE NO ON AB TWO TO ONE
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TARA DONALDSON
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS DOCTOR THEM ON THE LIST AND
I'M ACTUALLY A PROFESSOR AT
LOYOLA MARYMOUNT UNIVERSITY
SCHOOL OF EDUCATION.
I'M AN IMMIGRANT FROM THE
PHILIPPINES AND I ACTUALLY HAVE
A TEACHING CREDENTIAL.
IN A CALIFORNIA BILINGUAL
TEACHING CREDENTIAL AND AFTER
TALKING DALY CITY AND SAN
FRANCISCO BEFORE MOVING TO ALL
OF YOU.
ALLEN YOU HAS BEEN A PARTNER
WITH VARIOUS DISTRICTS INCLUDE
AND PARTLY TINGLING TEACHER
AMERICA.
AND THEREFORE I STRONGLY OPPOSE
OPPOSE AB TWO TWO ONE WHICH
WOULD BAN TFA CORE MEMBERS FROM
TEACHING IN THE SCHOOLS THAT
NEED THEM THE MOST.
ESPECIALLY DURING THIS TIME OF A
TEACHER SHORTAGE.
ALLEN WEST COLLABORATED WITH TFA
FOR ABOUT TWENTY YEARS AND WE
PARTNER WITH BARS DISTRICTS
INCLUDING SENT LOS ANGELES
SACRAMENTO STOCKTON OAKLAND AND
SAN JOSE.
OUR PARTNERSHIP IS ONE OF THE
MOST RIGOROUS OF THE EIGHTY
INTERN PROGRAMS IN THE STATE.
WE ARE ACCREDITED BY THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING IN FACT WE JUST
FINISH THIS A VERY SUCCESSFUL
SITE VISIT YESTERDAY.
THE FAA PROVIDES FURTHER SUPPORT
TO ADDITIONAL CLASSROOM
OBSERVATIONS AND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT.
WE KNOW THAT THIS COLLABORATIVE
RELATIONSHIP WORKS.
BECAUSE OUR TFA SCANNED
CANDIDATES LAST YEAR SCORED
ABOVE THE STATE THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE ON THE NTP A WHICH IS AN
INDEPENDENTLY ADMINISTERED
PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENT.
THE FAA ALSO ALLOWS THE TEACHING
FORCE TO BE MORE DIVERSIFIED.
61% OF THE FAA TEACHERS
IDENTIFIES PEOPLE OF COLOR
COMPARED 238%.
NTFA TEACHERS ALL TO TEACH IN
HIGH NEED AREAS LIKE STEM
SPECIAL EDUCATION IN BILINGUAL
EDUCATION.
ACTUALLY BECAUSE IF THE FAA OUR
STUDENTS ACTUALLY GET TO SEE
THEMSELVES IN THEIR TEACHERS.
I WITNESSED THEIR GREAT TO NASA
THE INDICATION.
THE BAND THE MORE THAN SEVEN
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE THE FAA
CORPS MEMBERS WITH EACH ANNUALLY
IN CALIFORNIA WOULD BE A MAJOR
FINANCIAL BURDEN TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
AND A LOSS FOR THEIR STUDENTS IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES.
FURTHERMORE THE BILL FAILED STOP
KNOWLEDGE THE POSITIVE IMPACT OF
THEIR WORK.
INSTEAD WE SHOULD SUPPORT AND
WELCOME THE SCORE MEMBERS INTO
THE TEACHING PROFESSION IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE NEXT WITNESS.
IN OPPOSITION THAT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR O'DONNELL
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HI
MY NAME'S CHRISTOPHER LEAK AND I
AM THE VICE PRESIDENT OF DATA
REPORTING AND INSIGHTS THAT
TEACH FOR AMERICA.
I WORK TO BEAT THE ANALYSIS AND
RESEARCH -- FOR THE IMPACT AND
SATISFACTION OF BOTH OUR CORE
MEMBERS AND OUR ALUMNI -- AN
IMPACT ON THE COMMUNITIES THAT
WE SERVE AND THE NUMBERS THAT WE
HAVE REPORTED ABOUT THE
RETENTION RATES AND THE ONGOING
ENGAGEMENT OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
STAYED IN EDUCATION EVEN IF
THEY'RE NOT STILL.
TEACHERS -- IN THE TEACH FOR
AMERICA COMMUNITY AND I'M HERE
AS A TECHNICAL EXPERT.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE COME UP THE STATE YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON
THE BILL ONLY AND MR DONALD
MICHAEL BOCA DORO LONG TIME
LOBBYIST TURNED SACRAMENTO I'M
NOT HERE TODAY ON BEHALF.
OF THE YOU SEE YOUR NAME A
FILTER STOOD.
UP EXCUSE ME YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL ONLY THE TITLE LOGUDORO
WEST COAST ADVISERS ON BEHALF OF
MY DAUGHTER WHO'S A TF A CORE
MEMBER IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THANK YOU SIR.
OUR NEXT.
ANY ANY FURTHER ANY OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
CIGNA.
IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE OPPOSE THE
BILLION INCOME BORDERS THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE DOING NOW SORRY
THAT'S IN SCHOOL TRUSTEE IN
GRANTS MANAGER FOR THE ARREST OF
BROTHERS TRUST IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
DR RANDY WARD RETIRED SAN DIEGO
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
A POST.
ADAM KEVIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TERMS SCHOOL SOCIAL
ASIAN IN OPPOSITION.
PAUL HE'S EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND
THE BAY AREA FOR TEACH FOR
AMERICA OPPOSED.
MY FAVORITE NOW I TAUGHT SPECIAL
EDUCATION FOR THREE YEARS AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
RIGHT TOM PARIS ON THE PRESIDENT
THE WEST CONTRA COSTA UNIFIED
SCHOOL BOARD ALTHOUGH I'M
SPEAKING ON MY OWN BEHALF I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSED.
NO THEY'RE NOT TRAVIS IS A UNION
HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT TRUSTEE
STRONGLY OPPOSED.
NANCY ELRON SUPERINTENDENT OF
SAN JOSE UNIFIED STRONGLY
OPPOSED.
JEFF FROST REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LATINO
SUPERINTENDENTS AND
ADMINISTRATORS AND DR DAVID FOR
DIEGO THEIR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
IN OPPOSITION.
LARA PRESENT ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
AND OPPOSITION.
JACK CARTY WITH TEACH FOR
AMERICA OPPOSED.
MAKE OUR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
HUMAN CAPITAL STOCK AND UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF AND DOCTOR JOHN DAISY
SUPERINTENDENT STOCKTON UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT THE POST.
BRIAN REAVIS ON BEHALF OF THE
EDUCATION TRUST WEST IN
OPPOSITION.
JENNIFER WATER ON BEHALF OF AT
VOICE IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
LIVE JENNINGS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
TEACH FOR AMERICA LOS ANGELES IN
STRONG OPPOSITION.
WHICH ALL THESE HE TEACH FOR
AMERICA CORPS MEMBER ALUMNI AND
STOCKTON STRONGLY OPPOSE.
SERRA LAWS ON BEHALF OF TEACH
PLUS IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU I JUST TO CLARIFY --
WITH THE OTHER GOOD CLARIFY I
THIS BILL ISN'T NECESSARILY
TARGETED TEACHER AMERICA AS MUCH
AS IT'S TARGETED TO ENSURE THAT
TEACHERS HAVE A HAVE A HAVE A
FIVE YEAR COMMITMENT. TO TO THE
CLASSROOM RIGHT.
HE WANTED YOU WANTING TO THE ANA
AMENDMENT REALIZE JUST REGRET I
THINK PEOPLE SAYING YOU WANT TO
LEARN ANY TEACH FOR AMERICA --
THAT'S NOT WHAT THE BILL SAYS
WITH THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE HAVE
TAKEN IT SAYS THAT YOU.
ARE GOING TO ENTER INTO A FIVE
YEAR.
MA'AM -- AND WERE YOU AND SO MY
GOAL IS TO KEEP TEACHERS IN THE
CLASSROOM TEACHING.
AND IN CERTAINLY ENCOURAGE THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO BE.
THERE FOR A LONG FOR OVER A
LONGER TIME HER TAKING ALL THE
NECESSARY SKILLS.
AND MAYBE PAY BACK THAT
INVESTMENT THAT THE DISTRICT
WOULD BE MAKING ON THEM OKAY
THANK YOU -- MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
ANY COMMENTS MISS SMITH.
AM I THINK THE OTHER FOR THE
TIME AND CONSIDERATION THAT SHE
HAS PUT INTO THIS MEASURE AND
WE'VE HAD SOME REALLY -- DEEP
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT IT AND THE
INTENT BEHIND IT IS REALLY WHAT
I APPRECIATE THE MOST BECAUSE
IT'S TWO FOLD IT'S ABOUT
SUPPORTING THE STUDENTS AND IN
OUR MOST ACADEMIC ACADEMICALLY
CHALLENGING SCHOOLS WHILE AT THE
SAME TIME BEING CONSIDERATE
ABOUT WHAT BEST SUPPORTS
TEACHERS IN THAT EARLY INDUCTION
PHASE OF THEIR CAREER.
AND SO WHILE I ATE I
RESPECTFULLY HERE THE OPPOSITION
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
CHALLENGES WE NEED TO CONTINUE
TO WORK THROUGH -- I APPRECIATE
THAT YOU'VE ACCEPTED AMENDMENTS
WHICH I THINK GETS IT BETTER ON
A TRACK TO THE THE GOALS THAT
WE'VE BOTH TALKED ABOUT.
AND I WILL SUPPORT IT TODAY IN
IN SO FAR AS I WOULD LIKE US TO
CONTINUE THAT DIALOGUE BECAUSE
YOU KNOW THAT I'D LIKE TO BE
WORKING ON THE INDUCTION SIDE
AND HOW WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
THAT -- BUT ULTIMATELY THIS IS
ABOUT WHAT'S DOING BEST FOR KIDS
WHO NEED IT.
AND SUPPORTING EARLY CAREER
TEACHERS AND PUTTING THEM ON A
PATH WHERE THEY CAN HAVE.
CLASSROOM SUCCESS AND A
SUSTAINABLE CAREER WE WE WANT TO
KEEP YOUNG AMBITIOUS TEACHERS IN
OUR CLASSROOMS SO AND I
APPRECIATE THE AMOUNT OF TIME
YOU YOU'VE PUT INTO THIS AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH YOU.
ANY OTHERS -- MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU SUMMER GARCIA AND AND TO
EVERYONE THAT'S COME OUT ON ON
ON BOTH SIDES ON THIS ISSUE AND
I APPRECIATE IT.
THE AUTHOR PROBABLY PAT OF THE
CONVERSATION SOUNDS A SIMILAR TO
THE SERIOUSNESS I APPRECIATE THE
FACT YOU'RE REALLY.
TRYING TO TALK. TO ALL OF US TO
REALLY GET A SENSE OF OF WHAT
YOUR GOALS AND INTENTIONS ARE I
ALSO APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE
STAFF I I KNOW THAT -- MY STAFF
AND A LOT OF CONVERSATIONS WE'VE
ALSO BEEN TALKING A LOT WITH
SOME LOCAL FOLKS LOCAL DISTRICTS.
TO REALLY KIND OF WRAP OF TO
WRAP MY HEAD AROUND.
ON THIS TO THERE'S A COUPLE
THINGS THAT COME TO MIND ONE IS --
THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT WE ONE LOW
INCOME SCHOOLS WE DON'T BUNDLE
COMES WITH THE SAME DEGREE FUND
SCHOOLS ABOUT THEIR COMMUNITIES.
AND THAT IS A LARGER ISSUE THAT
IMPACTS EVERY ASPECT OF OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM.
AND THAT BEING SAID I I I DO
APPRECIATE THE ASPECT OF THE
BILL THAT.
REGARDLESS OF WHAT INDUSTRY YOU
AND IF YOU HAVE INTERNSHIP
PROGRAMS WHAT HAVE YOU THE GOAL
SHOULD BE THAT.
I MEAN I WAS IN TURN PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE I BIG BECAUSE
I WANT TO COME IN I DID BECOME A
PUBLIC DEFENDER RIGHT I MEAN I
THINK THAT.
ULTIMATELY THAT INTERNSHIP TYPE
PROGRAMS THE PURPOSE SHOULD BE
AS WE HEARD FROM BOTH SIDES
WE'VE HEARD YOU KNOW.
THAT YOUR PENSION COME TEACHERS
RIGHT I MEAN THAT THAT'S THE
IDEA IS TO FIND DIFFERENT.
WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE A IN ISSUE
WITH ATTRACTING BECAUSE GOING TO
TEACHING ESPECIALLY IN AREAS
LIKE SO LIKE.
TALK ABOUT I CAN SOUNDS A WAS
VERY EXPENSIVE.
AND SO WE WANT TO FIND WAYS TO
GET PEOPLE.
TO GET INTO THE PROFESSION AND
UP OF ENTRY POINTS WHERE THEY'VE
HOPEFULLY STAY IN THE PROFESSION
AND SO I APPRECIATE -- THE THE
INTENTION THERE PARTICULARLY
WITH THE IDEA OF HAVING A LONG A
COMMITMENT I THINK THAT THAT.
MATTER WHAT PROGRAM IT IS
WHETHER COMING FROM THE CSU
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM MORE A THIRD
PARTY PROGRAM THAT THAT LONGER
COMMITMENT I THINK WILL REALLY.
YOU KNOW WE GET OUT FOLKS THAT
ARE THAT THAT REALLY WANT TO
MAKE THAT COMMITMENT TO BECOMING
A TEACHER -- AND THE THE ONE
THING I DO WANT TO MENTION
BECAUSE THIS IS A CAN A AND IT
IS SOMETHING WE TALKED ABOUT
TALK TO THE AUTHOR ABOUT -- IS.
THE AT LEAST IN THE SHORT
CERTAINLY IS THE SHORT TERM
IMPACTS.
OF PROHIBITING -- TEACHING AT
TITLE ONE SCHOOLS.
I HAVE SOME DISTRICTS I THINK
PROBABLY A MANY OF US DO THAT
ARE ALMOST EXCLUSIVELY TITLE ONE
SCHOOLS.
SO.
YOU KNOW WHAT.
ALTHOUGH THERE MAY BE A GOAL
THAT I THINK WE ALL MAKE.
CAN AGREE AND AGREE ON THAT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WERE
PREPARING.
IN TERMS OF ANY FORM TO BECOME
GOOD QUALITY TEACHERS THAT STAY
IN THOSE DISTRICTS.
THE SHORT TERM PRAGMATIC REALITY
IS THAT I HAVE SOME DISTRICT
ALUM ROCK IS ONE UP THAT HAS
ABOUT 10%.
THAT -- ARE THESE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS USE THIRD PARTY TYPE
PROGRAMS AND TING.
A CHALLENGE TO TRY.
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO NEGOTIATE
THAT IN IN A ONE OR TWO YEAR
PERIOD -- AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I KNOW WE'VE TALKED ABOUT --
IS.
YOU KNOW IF THIS BILL WERE TO
GET THROUGH THE COMMITTEE TODAY.
UP OUR AND IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU
AGAIN YOU HAD CONVERSATIONS THE
NUMBER OF US ARE.
THAT IS THE WILLINGNESS TO HAVE
SOMETHING CONVERSATIONS ON JUST.
IMPLEMENTATION TIMELINE OF
FLEXIBILITY BECAUSE IN SOME OF
THE DISTRICTS AND AND MY
COMMUNITY I I DON'T.
THERE'S A LOT OF REASONS WHY
SCHOOLS PERFORM POORLY.
AND I THINK THAT WE HAVE THE
ADDRESS A LOT OF THEM AND I
THINK THAT.
CREATING THAT LONG TERM PIPELINE
IS ABSOLUTELY A CORRECTLY
IDENTIFIED ISSUE THAT WE HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT.
AGAIN WITH OTHER COMING THROUGH
A CSU INTERNSHIP WITH THEIR
COMING THROUGH A THIRD PARTY IN
SHIP YOU WANNA MAKE SURE THEY
STAY THERE AND THE LADY LOVE
TEACHING AND THAT THEY'RE
THEY'RE NOT JUST FIVE YEARS BUT
HOPEFULLY. TWENTY FIVE YEARS BUT
IT TAKES A LOT OF TIME AND
EFFORT ENERGY TO HOW WE GET
THERE AND SO I WOULD LOVE.
THE OPPORTUNITY HOPEFULLY GET A
COMMITMENT THAT WE CAN KEEP
TALKING ON HOW WE ENSURE.
THAT.
THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
NOT CREATING A LEASE SHORT TERM
TRAUMA FOR SOME OF THE DISTRICTS
BUT INTENTIONALLY.
THAT IF WE DO GET A LONGER TERM
COMMITMENT FROM ORGANIZATIONS --
THAT MAYBE THERE MIGHT BE A PATH
TO ALLOWING SOME THIRD PARTY
ORGANIZATIONS WOULD YOU BE OPEN
TO THAT CONVERSATION IF THERE'S
AGAIN PARAMETERS IN PLACE THAT
ENSURE.
THAT IT'S REALLY BEING DONE TO
CREATE A PIPELINE. FOR FUTURE
TEACHING I I HOPE THAT MAKES
SENSE.
I WILL SAY THAT WE OPPOSITION --
FOLKS WHO ARE HERE ARE OUR
TEACHER OF THE YEAR WE WANT THAT
PIPELINE SO I THINK WE HAVE SOME
COMMON GROUND.
AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
TEACHERS STAY IN THE CLASSROOM
PASSED THAT PROFICIENCY IN TH OF
IT TAKES TWO TO THREE YEARS TO
BECOME PROFICIENT ON AVERAGE.
THE VIEW IN RECENT YEARS BEYOND
THAT FOR THE INVESTMENT THAT
THAT WE HAVE PUT INTO THIS -- I
IF WE HAVE TEACHERS LIKE
YOURSELF WE HAVE TO JUST LIKE
MYSELF THAT.
WE FIGURED IT OUT AND WE STAY
THERE RIGHT I STAY THERE FOR
THIRTEEN YEARS AND IT'S ALWAYS
BEEN MY INTENTION TO RETURN TO
THE CLASSROOM AFTER THIS CASE UP --
AND AND SO WE CAN DEFINITELY
HAVE THAT EXAMPLES BUT HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE THAT THE VAST MAJORITY.
ARE US AND WE'RE NOT THE
EXCEPTION WHICH IS AT THE DATA
SHOWING US RIGHT NOW IT'S I
THINK WE HAVE THAT.
IN COMMON I THINK I'M ONLY TO
HAVE DISCUSSIONS WITH WITH
EVERYONE I THINK MY PLAINTIFF OF
THIS BILL EVEN PARADIS IS
STARTED DISCUSSION ABOUT OUR
MOST VULNERABLE STUDENTS.
WHEN WE IDENTIFY SCHOOLS HAD A
ONE WAY SEEN THESE KIDS FROM THE
BEGINNING HAVE ALL THE SYSTEMIC
BARRIERS AGAINST THEM?
DOES THIS ADD TO THE SYSTEMIC
BARRIERS AND IF SO HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE WE RATIFY FOR SOME OF
THAT AND AND EVEN MORE SO WITH
THEIR SPECIAL AT US SPECIAL ED
STUDENTS AND NEEDS.
AN ALLEY YOU IS THE ALL OF OUR
TEACH FOR AMERICA TEACHERS ONLY
TEACHING SPECIAL EVENTS ARE MOST
ONE OF THE STUDENTS OF COLOR
SPECIAL THAT -- YOU KNOW AND SO
AND SO I WANT TO MAKE SURE
HAVING THAT DISCUSSION THIS
TRAUMA WHEN YOU HAVE THIS
CONSTANT CYCLE EVERY TWO TO
THREE YEARS PEOPLE LEAVING
THERE'S A TRAUMA THAT HAPPENS TO
THE STUDENTS ARE THE TRAUMA
HAPPENS IS GOING TO THE
COMMUNITY.
THAT'S ALREADY HAPPENING I'M
PRAGMATIC I'M MORE THAN WILLING
TO ENGAGE ON A TIME LINE THAT
MAKES SENE THAT MIGHT BE FAIR.
TO TO ORGANIZATIONS WHO HAVE
BEEN RELYING ON THESE PROGRAMS
TO COME UP WITH A BETTER WAY AS
WE MOVE FORWARD BUT I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT AS I'M BEING
PRAGMATIC AND I'M OPEN THAT THE
OTHER SET IS OPEN.
TO SOME OF THESE A MOMENT THAT
WE'VE ALREADY TAKEN FROM THE
COMMITEE CHAIR TO DAY -- AND SO.
I I WILL CONTINUE AS I THINK I
HAVE RIVER THE MULTIPLE YEARS
HERE TO FIND THAT SWEET SPOT
WHERE MAYBE AT THEN IT AT THE
END WE ALL GET SOMETHING WHEN I
WE HAVE A GOOD BILL.
I I AND I APPRECIATE THAT OF A
SUMMER GARCIA SO I THINK THAT
YOU KNOW THE THE THE THE REASON
WHY THERE'S BEEN THAT THIS IN
DEPTH CONVERSATION WITH A NUMBER
OF US BECAUSE WE'RE TRYING TO
GET THERE WITH THE ON YOUR
INTENTION.
WITHOUT CAUSING TO MUCH ISSUE
WITH THE PRAGMATIC APPLICATION
OF IT AND MAKING SURE THAT THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN.
RUNNING THESE INTERNSHIP
PROGRAMS AT THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SAY OKAY WELL IT THIS IS
DIRECTION THAT THE ASSEMBLY SOME
TO GO WITH EVEN WITH THESE
AMENDMENTS AND WHAT HAVE YOU.
THAT THERE'S A WAY TO KIND OF
TRY TO COME TOGETHER SAY THAT
THERE ARE SCHOOLS THAT STILL
NEED.
THAT BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT GETTING
ENOUGH TEACHERS THE DAY ONE TO
COME INTO THOSE CLASSROOMS IS
THERE A WAY THAT WE CAN ALL WORK
TOGETHER TO CREATE A MORE ROBUST
PROGRAM.
THAT PUTS THE NEEDS OF THE
STUDENTS WHICH IS REALLY WHAT
IT'S ALL ABOUT CAN WE CREATE A
MORE ROBUST PROGRAM THAT HAS A
LONGER TERM COMMITMENT.
AND DO IT IN A WAY THAT WERE NOT
AT LEAST IN THE VERY SHORT TERM
DISADVANTAGING THESE SCHOOLS
THAT. FOR WHATEVER REASON AND
THERE ARE PROBABLY A LOT OF
REASONS FOR IT ARE RELYING ON ON
THIS SHORT TERM INTERNSHIP -- TO
BUILD THEIR CLASSROOMS AND SO.
THAT'S AND I AND I I I I WILL
SAY.
THERE DISADVANTAGED WITH OR
WITHOUT THIS PART ACTUALLY --
AND AS WE THINK ABOUT THE SHORT
TERM I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DON'T GET TO ANOTHER THIRTY
YEARS DOWN THE ROAD AND WE'RE
SAYING STILL STAYING.
AWAY WE HAVEN'T REALLY FIX THE
TEACHER SHORTAGE PROBLEM ARE WE
HAVING GIVEN OUR TEACHERS ENOUGH
SUPPORT THERE'S A LOT THAT NEEDS
TO BE HAPPENING IN THIS
DISCUSSION THE COMMITTEE.
YOU HAVE LEADERS HERE HAVE BEEN
PART OF THOSE SOLUTIONS FOR FOR
MANY YEARS SINCE IS ONCE.
ADDITIONAL LAYER TO THE
DISCUSSION THAT HAS BEEN HAD --
ENTERTAIN HERE AND SO I AGREE
WITH YOU THAT DISCUSSES THE DO
CONTINUE ON BOTH SIDES -- IT'S
Y. TOOK SUBSTANTIVE AMENDMENTS
IN THIS COMMITTEE -- IT'S WHY I
GUESS HAVE MULTIPLE COMMITTEES
TO GO THROUGH AND AND PART OF
THAT PROCESS AND SEND THE SAME
WAY THAT I'VE TAKEN FROM
SUBSTANTIVE A AMENDMENTS I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT BEFORE I
WANTED TO COMMIT TO ANY
ADDITIONAL STUFF THAT I HAVE
COMMITMENT FROM.
THE OTHER SIDE THAT SOME OF
THESE AMENDMENTS AND SOME OF THE
ACTION IS THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
AND I'VE MONSTER I THINK THE
LONGER TERM COMMITMENT IS
SOMETHING THAT I THINK IT'S
REALLY A PIPELINE I THINK THAT
EVERYONE SHOULD AGREE.
THE QUESTION IS HOW DO WE GET
THERE AND I THINK THAT THAT'S
WERE SOME OF THE THIRD PARTY
FOLKSY.
TO COME TO THE TABLE BUT WITH
YOU AND WITH OTHERS UP EDUCATION
COMMITTEE AND SAY OKAY WHILE.
THIS IS THE THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN BUY INTO BUT IT WILL
WORK WITH US IF AB AND SEE.
IF THOSE KIND OF CONVERSATIONS
HAPPEN HAPPEN THEY NEED TO
HAPPEN AND I THINK THAT.
THIS BILL GOING FORWARD I THINK
I IMAGINE WILL URGE ON THOSE.
CONVERSATIONS BUT YOU KNOW.
FOR YOU KNOW I A AND SO I AGREE
WITH THE INTENTION I AGREE WITH
THE CREATING A LONG TERM
PIPELINE A REAL PIPELINE FOR
LONG TERM SUCCESS OF CREATING
MORE TEACHERS.
AND FOR MY CONTINUED.
SO I SUPPORT TODAY BECAUSE OF
THE COOKING COMMITMENTS YOU'VE
MADE IN CONVERSATION AS WELL AS
THIS AND I UNDERSTAND YOUR
EXPECTATIONS OF OTHERS TO BE
ABLE TO COME BOARD AS WELL AND
HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
AND IF THINGS PROGRESS IN A WAY
THAT CERTAINLY I FEEL
COMFORTABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT MY
DISTRICTS.
A BOOK OR OR YOU WILL CONTROL
THE SHORTER DRAMA.
YET WE'RE DEALING WITH A LONG
TERM TRAUMA AT THE SAME TIME
THEN I ABLE.
YOU'LL LIKELY CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THE BILL BUT RIGHT NOW I
WANT TO VOTE FOR IT -- BUT WHEN
IT GETS THE FLOOR I THINK A LOT
OF THOUGHT OF THINGS A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS FROM ALL SIDES
NEED TO HAPPEN AND I'LL BE
LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT LOUD AND
CLEAR.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I AT A
FEW.
QUESTIONS BUT OBVIOUSLY THIS IS
A COMPLICATED TOUGH ISSUES ARE
TAKING THE MOST AMOUNT OF TIME
ON THIS BILL OF ALL THE BILLS
TODAY THERE'S A BIG LINE OUT
THERE.
I THINK THERE ARE TWO ISSUES
THAT THAT THAT -- WERE THAT
TERROR ADDRESSES THAT ONE WE
HAVE THIS REAL TEACHER SHORTAGE
I KNOW EVERY YEAR.
IN THE BUDGET COMMITTEE RE
OVERSEAS SCHOOL FUNDING.
WHEN THAT COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING COMES AND GIVES
THE RIVER THERE UPDATE ON THE
NUMBER OF?
EMERGENCY CREDENTIAL TEACHERS I
THINK IT'S RELATIVELY STABLE I
THINK IT'S THOUSANDS RIGHT SIX
THOUSAND SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
AND SO THAT'S REAL ON THOSE ARE
KIDS THAT ARE IN CLASSROOMS WITH
TEACHERS THAT ARE NOT PROPERLY
PREPARED THEY SOME OF THEM HAVE
SUBSTITUTES FOR DAY ON DAY IN
DAY IN DAY [inaudible]
ON ON MONTHS AND SO.
AND THEN THE SO WE KNOW ABOUT
THE TEACHERS WERE IS OBVIOUS YOU
ARE NOT COMPENSATING TEACHERS
ENOUGH.
IT'S HARD TO BE A TEACHER.
AND STRESSFUL POSITION MR
O'DONNELL REMINDS US ALL THE
TIME -- YEAH.
AND THE THE THE FLIP SIDE IS
THAT -- IN SOME OF THESE HIGH
POVERTY SCHOOLS AND DISTRICTS.
IT'S JUST TOUGH FOR THE KIDS AT
THE THE DECK IS STACKED AGAINST
THEM.
IN THEIR IN THEIR HOME.
IN THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD.
HEALTHCARE JUST THEIR LIGHTS AND
THEN THEY'RE IN SCHOOLS WITHOUT
ADEQUATELY -- TRAIN TEACHERS AND
AND THOSE ARE THE SCHOOLS THAT
HAVE.
THE THIS ISSUE AND SO I I
UNDERSTAND -- WHERE YOU'RE
GETTING AT AND SO WE HAVE TO
BALANCE THOSE THOSE ISSUES SO I
I I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THIS
TODAY I THINK THERE ARE SOME
FLAWS AMID TALK ABOUT A SECOND I
DO HAVE A FEW?
A FEW QUESTIONS IS -- I JUST I
JUST.
I WAS REMINDED TODAY THAT MY
NIECE WAS IT TEACH FOR AMERICA
TEACHER AFTER GRADUATING FROM
SAINT MARY'S COLLEGE ABOUT FIVE
YEARS AGO.
AND SHE DID IT FOR A YEAR AND
THEN SHE DIDN'T DIDN'T PAN OUT.
SO SHE'S DOING GREAT ANOTHER
PROFESSION AND SO.
BUT THAT'S A LOT JUST TO SAY
THAT JUST BECAUSE IT'S A TEACH
FOR AMERICA TEACHERS DID IT
THEIR OTHER TEACHERS THAT TEACH
FOR A YEAR AND LEAVE AS WELL.
SO I WANT TO ASK YOU AND AND YOU
THE PROPONENTS AND TEACH FOR
AMERICA.
IT DO WE THINK THAT.
TEACHERS IN TEACH FOR AMERICA
ARE ARE ARE MORE WE'VE HEARD
SOME OF THIS ONE EIGHT YOU CAN
REVIEW THIS WE WANT.
TO IF THEY ARE MORE LIKELY TO
LEAVE WITHIN THE FIRST FEW YEARS
THAN TEACHERS IN THE TRADITIONAL --
TEACHER TRAINING PROCESS SO ALL
OF YOU CAN ANSWER THAT
[inaudible]
WE WILL.
WELL -- OUR DATA T DOESN'T SHOW
THAT TO BE TRUE.
IN CALIFORNIA PARTICULAR WE SHOW
THAT.
WELL EMPTY SEVEN ABOUT 35% OR
TEACHERS.
REMAIN IN THE CLASSROOM BUT
ANOTHER 3235% MOVE ON IN
CALIFORNIA AND OTHER.
CAREERS IN EDUCATION SO A LOT OF
THEM ARE MOVING INTO ROLES AS
YOU KNOW SYSTEM PRINCIPLE DEAN'S
MOVING TO CHARTER SCHOOL
ORGANIZATIONS AND SO.
WE START TO SEE THEM TAKING ON
LEADERSHIP ROLES AND SO.
YOU'RE ON THE SUPPORT SIDE THE
BILL OR YOUR TEACHER AMERICA YES
THAT'S RIGHT YOU'RE SITTING OVER
THERE WITH US.
I'M SORRY THIS IS WITH THE WITH
THE SEATING AVAILABLE THAT'S
ALRIGHT I JUST GOT LOOKING.
COMMON GROUND I JUST GOT A
LITTLE CONFUSED AS WANT TO
CLARIFY THANK YOU.
YEAH THEY'RE GONNA ANSWER.
I HAVE DATA THAT SHOWS THAT --
AFTER THEIR FIFTH YEAR ONLY
TWENTY SEVEN POINT 8% OF TEACH
FOR AMERICA CORPS MEMBERS WERE
STILL TEACHING.
TEACHING NOT JUST IN EDUCATION
BUT ACTUALLY TEACHING COMPARED
TO THE FIFTIES 50% ESTIMATED FOR
NEW TEACHERS ACROSS ALL TYPE OF
SCHOOLS.
SO.
ACROSS ALL SCHOOLS IT'S 50%
AFTER FIVE YEARS AND TO ONLY
TWENTY SEVEN POINT 8% STILL
TEACHING.
IF YOU'RE A CORE MEMBER
CORRECTED AND THAT'S YOU KNOW
WHAT I THOUGHT YOU SAID EARLIER
IN A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT FROM
YOUR EXPLANATION SO.
HE THAT'S THE POINT OF THE
AMENDMENT THE YOU'RE PROPOSING
IN THERE SOME TYPE OF COMMITMENT
AND SO CAN YOU EXPLAIN HOW WE
WOULD ENFORCE THAT THAT. FIVE
YEAR COMMITMENT.
AND WE'RE NOT THE LANGUAGE AND
IN FRONT OF US HERE SO HOW WOULD
THAT STRUCTURALLY WORK.
WELL.
CURRENTLY IF YOU HAVE A TEACH
FOR AMERICA TEACHER AT YOUR
SCHOOL SITE YOU HAVE A MEMO OF
UNDERSTANDING -- THAT THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS DO FOR THE TWO YEAR.
COMMITMENT AND SO THEY WOULD
HAVE TO WORK ON THE FIVE YEAR
AND WILL YOU AND THE SAME WAY
THEY FIGURED OUT A TWO YEAR AND
WHAT YOU BUT HOW DO WE ENFORCE
THAT.
WE GO TO THE DOCTOR.
CLAW BACK.
MONEY SOME OUT HOW HOW WOULD
THAT WORK I KNOW LIKE IN THE
MILITARY OUT TO SERVE CERTAIN MY
YEARS YOU SOME HAPPENED SO IT
HOW WOULD THIS WORK FOR THE FOR
THIS.
BUT I CAN SURE AS AS
CONTEMPLATED FROM THE COMMITTEE
STANDPOINT -- THAT WOULD BE
BUILT INTO AN AMMO YOU AND IF
YOU VIOLATED ANNA YOU THERE
WOULD BE.
CERTAIN CONDITIONS -- CERTAIN
MEASURES OF ACCOUNTABILITY BUT
ALSO I THINK WHEN WHEN.
WHEN TFA OR WHATEVER
ORGANIZATIONS ARE OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS A PLACE PLACE
TEACHERS IN IN IN IN IN SCHOOLS
ACROSS UNITED STATES?
THAT THEY WOULDN'T THE TICKET
WHAT THEY DO OF MINORS AS GIVE A
BONUS FOR EACH YEAR EACH OF THE
TWO YEARS.
RIGHT SO I I WOULD I WOULD HOPE
I WOULD THINK THAT THEY WOULD
CONTEMPLATE THAT IS THIS A
BUILDING THERE BONUS STRUCTURE
THAT YOU HAVE TO STAY FOR THIS
FOR BEFORE YOU ALTERNATELY
RECEIVE.
SOME TYPE OF BONUS I DON'T WANT
TO DESIGN IT HERE BUT I I THINK
THERE VARIETY OF FRONTS WHERE
YOU TO DRESS THE ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES.
YEAH THAT'S I WOULD THINK WE
HAVE THE APPLE PROGRAM THE LOAN
FORGIVENESS FOR YOU GET AN AWARD
BASED ACCOUNT.
BASED UPON EVERY YEAR.
THAT YOU TEACH BUT IS IS THE
EMMA USE IT IT IS IT
[inaudible]
BASED UPON.
MULTIPLE TEACHERS FOR DISTRICT
OR IS IT.
IS A PER INDIVIDUAL I I WOULD
THINK WOULD BE I THINK YOU MIGHT
DISTRICT PROBABLY SET UP AND I
WILL YOU WITH AN ORGANIZATION.
AND PROBABLY THERE'LL BE A
CERTAIN NUMBER OF CANDIDATES
PROBABLY KAPPA PROBABLY WITH.
A DEFINED NUMBER I ASSUME YEAH.
AND THEN TOO I I WANTED TO ASK
IF YOU TO TEACH FOR AMERICA
REPRESENTS -- ONE TO TO RESPONSE
TO THE THEN THE NOTION THAT UP
IN LA FOR EXAMPLE WHICH I FIND
SHOCKING MAYBE COULD POLITENESS.
IS AT ALL OR THE MAJORITY OF
YOUR TFA TEACHERS TEACH SPECIAL
ED.
AND HERE IN SACRAMENTO I'VE
HEARD THAT.
THEY'RE ALL IN IN INDEPENDENT
CHARTER SCHOOLS WAS WONDERING IF
THAT'S A STRUCTURE THAT YOU FIND
EASIER TO GO INTO AND AND AND
WHY IS THAT SO.
NOW THE TWO SEPARATE TWO
SEPARATE ISSUES SUFFERS THE
LAUSD WAS STATED BY THE BY THE
AUTHORED OTHERS THAT.
OF THE IN LA U. S. T. ALL OF
THEIR NOT ALL SPECIALTY DESSERT
TFA OF COURSE BUT ALL OF THE TFA
TEACHERS.
END UP TEACHING SPECIAL ED.
THE ANSWER QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
MISTER CHAIR [inaudible]
YEAH -- I CAN ANSWER THE
QUESTION ABOUT SPECIAL EDUCATION
LA STM LYDA FROM EXACTED RECTOR
FROM TEACH FOR AMERICA LOS
ANGELES THEY'RE NOT ONLY SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS AND ALL YOU
SEE RIGHT NOW.
THERE ARE STEM TEACHERS AS WELL.
AND THEN -- BUILDING WAS BUILT
JUST SO YOU KNOW THE L. L. A. U.
S. T. DID INFORM THE COMMITTEE
THAT ALL THEIR TFA TEACHERS ARE
SPECIALISTS.
AS DIRECT INFORMATION TO THE
YEAH THAT'S WHAT I SAID SOME NOT
ALL SPECIALIST BECAUSE OF COURSE
TFA BUT THEY WE COULD PROVIDE
OLD IDEATION THAT WE HAVE ABOUT --
EIGHT FIRST YEAR STEM TEACHERS
WITH ELLIE S. T. RIGHT NOW
[inaudible]
AND THEN.
OKAY THANK YOU.
I WOULD SAY THAT PART OF IT IS
AS WE'RE TRYING TO COLLECT DATA
OUT THERE'S NOT ALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE TRACKING ALL THIS
INFORMATION SO IT'S ALSO BEEN.
A CHALLENGE AT TIMES AND WE HAVE
COMPETING SEVEN INFORMATION BUT
ALLEY ESTATE THEMSELVES TOLD US.
THAT THEIR TFA PLACEMENTS WERE
DOING SPECIAL AT THE REPS RIGHT
BEHIND THE THINKING WAS TO SAY
SOMETHING [inaudible]
OF STATE.
IN THE GARAGE WITH THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
ON WE DO HAVE -- IN THIS CURRENT
SCHOOL YEAR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
THIRTY FIVE SPECIAL ED TEACHERS.
FOR TFA AND FOR THE NEXT SCHOOL
YEAR WE ARE LOOKING AT OTHER
SUBJECT AREAS OF C. T. HE WOULD
BE ONE OF THEM AS WELL.
AND OBVIOUSLY WE'RE STILL
WORKING FOR THE NEXT SCHOOL YEAR
YEAH [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
HI.
AND THEN WHAT ABOUT THE ISSUE
WITH -- WITH WITH CHARTER
SCHOOLS IS IS THAT MORE OF A
RELATIONSHIP THAT TFA FINDS.
WORKABLE LEAVE DID YOU FIND MORE
INDEPENDENT CHARTERS ARE
WELCOMING.
TFA THAN SCHOOL DISTRICTS I KNOW
LIKE HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
THE TFA MY UNDERSTANDING THEY'RE
NOT THROUGH.
THE NINE CHARTERS THEY'RE THE
THEY'RE THEY'RE ONLY THROUGH.
THE INDEPENDENT CHARTERS IN
THEIR SACRAMENTO SCHOOL DISTRICT.
WELL I THINK WE HAVE A VARIETY
OF PLACEMENT STRATEGY SENSE OUR
GOAL IS TO SERVE THE NEEDIEST
COMMUNITIES AND THE STUDENTS
THAT WE SERVE RATHER THERE IN
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
ARE CHARTER SCHOOLS -- WE FEEL
THAT WE CAN BENEFIT THEM SO WE
GO -- WHEREVER THERE ARE
PLACEMENT OPPORTUNITIES BUT I
DON'T THINK WE HAVE A PARTICULAR
PREFERENCE IN TERMS OF CHARTER
VERSUS THAT TRADITIONAL PUBLIC
JUST.
BASED ON WHAT THE LOCAL NEED AND
AND EASE OF ENTRY OUR OKAY.
THAT IS SOMEBODY WHO
DISPLACEMENT YES OKAY SO I ALSO
WORK WITH ALL OF OUR DISTRICTS
IN CHARTERS AND SOME COOL SAY --
IN WE DO PLACE IN BOTH IN THE
HIGHEST NEEDS MOST OF THE
DISTRICTS THAT WE PLACE IN HAVE
MORE SCHOOLS THAN THE CHARTER
SCHOOL SO IT'S PRETTY EVEN THAT
IS THE GOAL. TO SERVE ALL OF THE
COMMUNITY IT'S NOT SPECIFICALLY
THAT CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE EASY TO
WORK WITH WE HAVE TONS OF
DISTRICTS.
ON THAT ARE EASY TO WORK WITH
AND THAT ACTUALLY WANT MORE
TEACHERS I WE CHEST IN SAMPLE
SAT ALONE PASSED FOR AMMO USE
FOR TEACH FOR AMERICA THIS YEAR
IN THE PAST TWO OR THREE MONTHS.
FIVE ZERO BECAUSE THEY SEE THE
BENEFIT OF THE PROGRAM AND WE
WANT LOCAL CONTROL RIGHT -- SO
THANK YOU DEFINITELY EASY TO
WORK WITH DISTRICTS THANK YOU.
WAS RECORDED YEAH THANK YOU AND
THEN MY LAST IS FOR THE FOR THE
AUTHOR AGAIN I I SUPPORT THIS
TODAY I THINK THERE ARE SOME
ISSUES THAT WE NEED TO KEEP
SORTING OUT THE NINE I'M GLAD
YOU TOOK THE FIRST STEP IN
OVERALL.
THANK THANK THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR CLARIFYING THIS IS
A TYPE OF INDUCTION OF TEACHERS
NOT NECESSARILY A BRAND I THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT AS WELL -- BUT
ALSO -- AS MISTER KALRA
MENTIONED YOU KNOW SOME OF OUR
SOME OF OUR SOME DISTRICTS ARE
ALMOST ALL TITLE ONE AND THERE
IS A VALUE IN IN THESE TYPE OF
OF EFFORTS AND SO.
YOU KNOW WHAT TYPE OF
FLEXIBILITY OF GOING FORWARD TO
TO NOT NECESSARILY HAVE NONE IN
TITLE ONE EVEN WITH A FIVE YEAR
COMMITMENT BUT SOME TYPE OF LIKE
A RATIO IS AT ALL UNDER
CONSIDERATION.
I DON'T KNOW THE TWO THINGS THAT
HAVE TO BE WOULD NEED TO HAPPEN
THE FEASIBILITY OF A RATIO OR
HOW WE TRACK THAT I MEAN YOU'RE
ALREADY ASKING QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE AND WE USE AND HOW WE KEEP
THAT ACCOUNTABLE.
AND SAYS THAT AT A LATER THAT
KIND OF MAKES AN UNWORKABLE SO
I'M NOT SAYING NO BUT IT IT IN
THOSE QUESTIONS NEED TO BE
ANSWERED AND FOR ME ALONG THE
WAY.
AND TO IF I'M GOING TO GO DOWN
THAT PATHWAY I NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT IN THE COULD THE FIVE YEAR
COMMITMENT -- IS.
IS IMPORTANT KEEPING THOSE
DOLLARS IN THE SCHOOLS IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT ARE PART OF THE
SUBSTANTIVE AMENDMENTS THAT
WE'VE TAKEN.
TODAY FROM THE OPPOSITION AND SO
I THINK AT THIS POINT IN THE
DISCUSSION I CAN'T SAY NO TO
ANYTHING -- BUT IF YOU KNOW WHEN
IT'S RIGHT WHAT ARE THE
CONSEQUENCES AND AND IN DOING SO.
ARE WE GETTING TO THE GOAL OF A
WITH THE BILL. ONE AMPS DO.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU A DOCTOR YES I I I I
APPRECIATE THIS CONVERSATION --
OBVIOUSLY IT BUT BRINGS TO OF
FOR A NUMBER OF CRITICAL ISSUES
WITH REGARDS TO EDUCATION AND
PLACEMENT OF TEACHERS IN
CLASSROOMS AND THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS AND WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
THAT.
YOU AND I OVER THE YEARS -- YEAH
I THINK.
IT UNFORTUNATELY I THINK THE
TEACH FOR AMERICA'S BRAND IS OUT
THERE AT THIS POINT AND SO I
THINK THAT WAS NOT THE INTENT.
NECESSARILY TO DEAL WITH THAT
BUT TO DEAL WITH THE QUESTION OF
PLACEMENT OF INDIVIDUALS IN
SCHOOLS AND I THINK OF THOSE OF
YOU FROM IN DOUBLY C. P. AND
OTHERS WHO HAVE THE RESEARCH
KNOW.
THAT ONE OF THE GREATEST
CHALLENGES AT MOST SCHOOLS HAVE
SOMEONE HAVE GENERALLY THAT ARE --
LOW INCOME OF SCHOOLS TITLE ONE
SCHOOLS IS SHE MENTALLY
CHALLENGED SCHOOLS HAVE MOST OF
THE NEW TEACHERS THE
INEXPERIENCED TEACHERS WHETHER
THERE.
IS A BE FORTY FOUR AMERICA THIS
IS DURING TEACH FOR AMERICA NO
BE ACTED TEACH FOR AMERICA --
AND THAT'S THE ONGOING
CHALLENGES THE PLACEMENT AND AS
HAVING BEEN A SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER WITH THE AND NUMBER TITLE
ONE SCHOOLS I SOMETIMES MUST
DISTRICTS HAD MY SCHOOL
INDIVIDUAL SCHOOLS HAD AS HIGH
AS 70%.
BRAND NEW TEACHERS IN THE SCHOOL.
OF LOW INCOME KIDS WERE REALLY
CHALLENGED AND YOU CAN IMAGINE
THERE'S NOT ONLY THEIR THOSE
TEACHERS ARE TRYING TO LEARN
WITH THE BEST THAT THEY CAN PUT
TOGETHER A AS AS AS NEW TEACHERS.
BUT THERE'S NO THEY'RE VERY FROM
ROLE MODELS AT THAT SCHOOL IN
TERMS OF EXPERIENCED TEACHERS
WHO CAN HELP WHERE ACROSS
INTERSTATE EIGHT YOU KNOW THERE
ARE HOLES THE SCHOOL COMMUNITIES
WITH THE AVERAGE NUMBER OF YEARS
IS TEN FIFTEEN YEARS IN SCHOOL.
AND WHEN YOU BRING IN A NEW
TEACHER THEY HAVE WON FIVE
MENTORS TO HELP THEM FIGURE OUT
THE CURRICULUM DO CLASSROOM
MANAGEMENT AND ALL THOSE THINGS
THAT NEW TEACHERS STRUGGLE WITH.
SO IT'S NOT SO MUCH IS IS REALLY
THE ISSUE OF PLACEMENT.
AND THE FACT THAT WE HAVE --
THAT WE OFTEN PUT OUR NEW AS OUR
NEW TEACHERS NO MATTER HOW
ENERGETIC THEY ARE THEY GOING TO
CHILD THE CHALLENGE WITH
MANAGING CURRICULUM AND CLASS
MANAGEMENT ORGANIZATION AND
THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
AND ISN'T TAKEN TWO THREE FOUR
YEARS TO BECOME GOOD ENOUGH TO
DEAL WITH IT IN THE IN THE
MEANWHILE YOU'VE GOT KIDS
SIGNALS CLASSROOMS WITH FOR
YEARS.
THE ONE CLASSROOM TO THE NEXT IF
YOU HAVE A LOT OF BRAND NEW
TEACHERS AT THE SCHOOL WILL
GOING TO BE THE VICTIMS OF
WHATEVER HAPPENS NOT
INTENTIONALLY.
BUT SIMPLY BECAUSE THAT'S THE
NATURE OF WHAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH AND IF YOU DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH.
EXPERIENCE TEACHERS IN THOSE
SCHOOLS TO INTERVENE TO SUPPORT
AS WELL AS FOR YOUNG PEOPLE TO
BE IN THOSE CLASSES AT SOME
POINT YOU'RE GOING TO ALWAYS IN
A WITH THE SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE.
SO I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT AS WE
LOOK AT IT I'M I'M.
I I I'M CONCERNED A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE LANGUAGE AND WILL WORK
ON THAT BECAUSE I'M I'M NOT SURE
IF THIS IS THE ISSUE OF
CONTRACTING OUT CONTRACTING IT.
IN MY MIND IT'S A MATTER OF
PLACEMENT.
AND A MATTER OF COMMITMENT --
AND I KNOW OVER THE YEARS I'VE
I'VE BASICALLY SAID WE SHOULD
NEVER HAVE A A LARGER PERCENTAGE
OF NEW TEACHERS IN THE SCHOOL
LARGER THAN WHAT THE DISTRICT
PASS.
SO THE DISTRICT HAS 10% NEW
TEACHERS THERE SHOULD BE NO MORE
THAN 10% NEW TEACHERS AT A POOR
SCHOOL.
BECAUSE IT SHOULD BE DISTRIBUTED
AROUND AT THAT OF COURSE BRINGS
HEARTBREAK TO PEOPLE BECAUSE
THAT MEANS SOME PEOPLE MAY BE
MOVED FROM SCHOOL IF YOU'RE
COMFORTABLE WITH BUT YET THEY'RE
VERY EXPERIENCE AND THEY NEED TO
GO SOME PLACE TO HELP.
OUT WITH WHAT'S GOING ON SO I
THINK THIS IS THE GIVES TO ISSUE
BUT WE WHAT KIND OF STARTING
AROUND IT IN TERMS OF TALKING
ABOUT.
TEACH FOR AMERICA AND ALL THAT
WE REALLY TALKING ABOUT IN
EXPERIENCED TEACHERS NOT HAVING
THE KIND OF SUPPORT THAT THEY
NEED TO BE AFFECTED AND BEING SO
MANY OF THEM IN ONE SCHOOL.
THAT IT BECOMES DIFFICULT WITH
IT BECAUSE IF YOU GOT TEACH FOR
AMERICA IN THE AND THEN YOU IF
YOU'RE A POOR SCHOOL YOU
PROBABLY HAVE A WHOLE BUNCH OF
THOSE THAT ARE NOT TEACH FOR
AMERICA.
YOU CAN'T HAVE TO TEACH FOR
AMERICA FOLKS BECAUSE THEY'RE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT'S
GOING ON AND SO WE HAVE THE
SCHOOLS IN MY DISTRICT WOULD
LARGE NUMBERS OF BRANDY TEACHERS.
NOW WOULD NEVER BANNED BRENDA
TEACHERS BECAUSE THEY BRING
ENERGY AND ENTHUSIASM INTO A
SCHOOL BUT SOMETIMES THE OTHERS
DON'T BRING.
BUT THEY ALSO NEED MORE THAN
JUST INCLUDES THE AS MAY NEED
TRAINING I MEAN IT'S SUPPORT ON
HOW TO BECOME AN EFFECTIVE
TEACHER AND SO -- I'M OF SUPPORT
IS NOT BECAUSE I KNOW YOU WHEN
YOU'VE COMMITTED TO CARRYING ON
THE THE CONVERSATION BUT IT IS
AN ISSUE THAT IS CRITICAL THAT
WE NEED TO LOOK AT THE RESEARCH
BEARS OUT.
THAT WE SHOULD BASICALLY BE
DISTRIBUTING ARCS TEACHERS
ACROSS THE BOARD WITH WITH XP
BASED ON EXPERIENCE AND
EXPERIENCE SO THAT PEOPLE CAN
ACTUALLY TEACH THE STUDENTS HAVE
SOME MENTORS SOME SUPPORT AS
WELL AS THE OTHER KIND OF
STRUCTURES THAT HELP PEOPLE
BECOME.
EFFECTIVE TEACHERS EVEN IN OUR
OWN REGULAR TEACHER POOR WHEN WE
HAD THE MEETING HERE TALKING
ABOUT WHY ARE PEOPLE LEAVING THE
PROFESSION.
NUMBER ONE ONE OF THE NUMBER ONE
REASONS ONE OF COURSE IT WAS IT
ALL.
MONEY AND SO FOR THIS ONE BUT
ALSO THERE WAS AFFECTED PEOPLE
DIDN'T FEEL SUCCESSFUL.
AND THEY PROBABLY DID FEEL
SUCCESSFUL BECAUSE THEY WERE
BEING PUT IN SITUATIONS THAT
THEY FELT THEY WOULD NOT DOING
THE BEST THEY COULD DO AND
THAT'S UNFORTUNATE.
BECAUSE PROBABLY WITH A LITTLE
BIT MORE SUPPORT THEY COULD HAVE
BEEN SUCCESSFUL BUT THEY DIDN'T
FEEL LIKE THEY WERE DOING A GOOD
JOB AND SO THEY LEFT THE
PROFESSION SOMEWHAT FRUSTRATED
BUT ALSO BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
WANT TO BASICALLY MESSEL ANYMORE
KIDS.
AND I CAN UNDERSTAND AND
APPRECIATE THAT SO I I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU THE ISSUE
BUT I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
SEE THE REAL ISSUE WE HAVE HERE
AND IT'S AN ISSUE A PLACEMENT.
NEW TEACHERS IN TOO MANY NEW
TEACHERS IN ONE SCHOOL AND THE
INABILITY OFTEN TIME WITH THOSE
SCHOOLS TO SUPPORT AND TO
PROVIDE THE MECHANISMS AND THE
AND THE SUPPORT SYSTEMS. TO HELP
THOSE TEACHERS BECOME EFFECTIVE
AND THAT IS FOR I TEACH FOR
AMERICA THAT IS FOR ANY OTHER
PROGRAM WE HAVE ONE ON AND
SOMETHING ELSE THAT WE NEED TO
BASICALLY FOCUS ON HELPING OUR
TEACHERS BECOME EFFECTIVE.
AND NOT PUTTING TOO MANY IN A
SITUATION WHERE THEY CAN HELP
EACH OTHER.
THANK YOU -- MISTER HASN'T.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA DO YOU.
THINK THIS BILL VIOLATES THE
EQUAL PROTECTION CLAUSE OF THE
US CONSTITUTION.
YOU WILL PROTECTION BECAUSE OF
THE US CONSTITUTION.
EQUAL PROTECTION CLAUSE. TO THE
QUESTION.
HAVE YOU LOOKED AT THAT.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME I GET
THIS QUESTION TO MYSELF DIRECTLY
SO.
HAVE A LOOK THAT EXAMINE
MANASSEH QUESTION UNTIL THIS
MOMENT OKAY HAVE YOU HAD ANYONE
RAISE CONCERNS OF THE BILLS AND
CONSTITUTIONAL [inaudible]
OKAY.
DO YOU THINK ABOUT VIOLATE THE
CONTRACTS BECAUSE THE US
CONSTITUTION.
YOU KNOW THAT WOULD ACTUALLY BE
A QUESTION FOR TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE THOSE PROBABLY ON
APPROPRIATE RIGHT NOW SHE'S NOT
A LAWYER WERE NOT ASK HER TO
OPINE AS SUCH.
AND I KNOW THE COMMITTEE VECES
WITH A VARIETY OF INDIVIDUALS
WITHIN THE COMMITTEE.
WITHIN THE WITHIN THE BUILDING
AND I THINK WE'RE PRETTY
COMFORTABLE THIS IS
CONSTITUTIONAL.
OKAY WELL I I DON'T ABOUT YOU
MISTER CHAIR BETTER THAN -- WITH
TO DEFEND THE CONSTITUTION OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
UNITED STATES AND I GENERALLY
TRY TO ABIDE BY THAT AND MAKE
SURE THE MY BILLS -- PASS
CONSTITUTIONAL MUSTER.
BUT I MOVE ON I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
LOOK INTO THAT.
SO MY UNDERSTANDING IS SOME
DISTRICTS -- HAVE TEACHERS
DEPARTMENTS TEACH FOR AMERICA
AND OTHERS DOWN IS THAT RIGHT.
I AM AND IT'S NOT YOU I'M
FIGHTING A COLD SO MY HEARING TO
LIVE IT OFF CAN YOU REPEAT YOUR
QUESTION SURE -- SO THERE'S SOME
DISTRICTS IN CALIFORNIA THE
PARTNER WITH TEACH FOR AMERICA
AND OTHERS THAT DON'T IS THAT
RIGHT CORRECT.
OKAY.
SO THE ONES TO DO IT THE ONES
THAT DO -- PARTNERS TEACH FOR
AMERICA NO ONE'S FORCING THEM TO
DO IT IS THAT RIGHT.
THEY VOLUNTARILY CHOOSE
DEPARTMENT TEACH FOR AMERICA.
OKAY -- I SEE THAT A A RANDOM
SURVEY FROM TWENTY FIFTEEN SAID
THAT A MAJORITY OF SCHOOL
PRINCIPALS WOULD HIRE TEACH FOR
AMERICA TEACHERS.
HAVE YOU HEARD THAT.
NO JUST RECENTLY PLEASE I JUST
YOU KNOW TO HELP YOU APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT THE WITNESS IS NOT
HOSTILE.
YOU KNOW JUST.
ASK YOU THE QUESTIONS WITH
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL -- MAYBE
GET TO THE POINT THAT -- THAT
YOU WANT ME TO CONSIDER.
WELL NO I'M ASKING QUESTIONS AND
PUTTING INFORMATION IS VERY
IMPORTANT AND MISTER CHAIR THIS
IS ONE THE MOST HOSTILE PIECES
OF LEGISLATION I'VE SEEN.
SINCE MY TIME IN THE LEGISLATURE
SO I HAVE EVERY RIGHT TO ASK
QUESTIONS OF THE WITNESS THAT
GET TO THE CORE MERITS OF THE
LEGISLATION AND THAT'S WHAT I'M
DOING.
NOW DO YOU HAVE REASON TO
BELIEVE THAT THAT'S WRONG THAT
OVER A MAJORITY OF TEACHERS AND
CAL OF PRINCIPLES IN CALIFORNIA
CITY WOULD HIRE TEACH FOR
AMERICA TEACHERS.
THESE PRINCIPLES IN AMERICA'S IN
THE THIRTY PRINTS.
FEATURES CALIFORNIA PRINCIPLES
ARE SAYING THIS.
YOU KNOW WHAT THAT'S ACTUALLY A
GOOD QUESTION IN MY I DON'T KNOW
THAT'S CALIFORNIA SPECIFIC OR OR
ACROSS THE COUNTRY BUT I WOULD
HAVE TO LOOK AT THE CITY AND
LOOK AT THEIR DATA AND ALSO YOU
KNOW MAKE SURE THAT I AGREE WITH
THEIR THEIR METHODOLOGY AND SEND
THAT.
PART I CAN SPEAK IF I HAVE THE
DATE AND FINING ME SURE I HAVE
THAT MUCH TRAINING BUT CERTAINLY
WE CAN AGREE THAT AT LEAST SOME
PRINCIPLES -- HIGHER TEACH FOR
AMERICA TEACHERS LONG TERM CARE
HIRING THE NUMBER AS EARLY AS
OKAY SO WHY IS IT THAT YOU THINK
THAT WE IS.
THE STATE GOVERNMENT NO BETTER
WHAT'S BEST FOR THE SCHOOLS THAN
THOSE SCHOOL LEADERS.
YES THEY GOVERNMENT COSTLY
PASSED LEGISLATION THAT TELLS
PEOPLE WHAT WE THINK THEY SHOULD
BE DOING AS A BODY AS A WHOLE.
OUT THERE AND SO PART OF WHAT WE
DO IS DISCUSS IT AS THE BODY AND
TRY TO COME TO A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION TO GIVE DIRECTION TO
OUR LEADERS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
ON A REGULAR BASIS NOT JUST IN
THE SPACE.
SURE MAYBE OTHER PIECES OF
LEGISLATION DO SIMILAR THINGS
I'M ASKING FOR THIS PARTICULAR
PIECE OF LEGISLATION WHY DO YOU
THINK WE AS THE STATE GOVERNOR
BETTER EQUIPPED.
THAN SCHOOL LEADERS TO DETERMINE
WHAT'S BEST FOR THE STUDENTS AT
THEIR SCHOOLS.
I'VE I'VE I WOULD SAY THAT.
INSTANCE WHERE YOU'RE IN THE
THICK OF THINGS YOU MIGHT HAVE
TELEVISION AND WE NEED TO STEP
BACK AND LOOK AT IT AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE TODAY.
OKAY SO YOU THINK THAT THE
SCHOOL LEADERS WHO DECIDE TO
HIRE TEACH FOR AMERICA TEACHERS.
ARE NOT MAKING DECISIONS THAT
ARE BEST FOR THEIR SCHOOLS I
THINK THE TEETH THE SCHOOL
LEADERS WHO ARE.
HIRING WHETHER TEACH FOR AMERICA
OR OTHER INTERN TEACHERS WOULD
ALL AGREE THAT WOULD THAT THEY
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE THE TEACHER
THERE FOR AT LEAST FIVE YEARS.
OKAY.
WHICH IS PART OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE TRYING TO MAKE
SURE WE HAVE A PIPELINE AND WE
HAVE TO KEEP THESE INDIVIDUALS
IN THE CLASSROOM.
PASSED PROFICIENCY SO THAT ONCE
THEY GET TO THAT LEVEL THEY'RE
GIVING THAT SKILL SET BACK TO
THE STUDENTS.
OKAY SO IT BUT IN IN EACH AND
EVERY INSTANCE WHERE SCHOOL
LEADER IN CALIFORNIA HAS DECIDED
TO PARTNER WITH TEACH FOR
AMERICA AND HIGHER TEACH FOR
AMERICA TEACHERS YOU'RE
CONFIDENT THAT I WAS NOT THE
RIGHT THING TO DO [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
OKAY.
DO YOU AYE AYE AS I UNDERSTAND
YOUR POSITION YOU BELIEVE THAT.
THE TEACH FOR AMERICA TEACHERS
BASED UPON THE TRAINING THEY
RECEIVED ARE NOT.
CAPABLE OF BEING AFFECTED
TEACHERS IS THAT RIGHT.
SOME OF THE MORE YOU HAVE A
GREAT TEACHER HAIRFINITY HE'S
BEEN TEAM TEACHER OF THE YEAR
HER SCHOOL THIS YEAR
CONGRATULATIONS ASHLEY.
SO SOME OF THEM ARE BUT WE HAVE
85% OF THEM WHO ARE LEAVING.
MANY OF THEM ARE NOT FINISHING
EVEN THEIR TWO YEAR CONTRACT
BECAUSE THEY DECIDED THAT THEY
WANT.
TO LEAVE A YEAR EARLIER BECAUSE
IT WASN'T FOR THEM.
OUT THERE AND SO IT'S NOT A 100%
BUT BUT THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THEM ARE STRUGGLING OR LEAVING
OR NOT STAYING IN THE PROFESSION.
A LONGER THAN A COUPLE YEARS AND
SO WE WANT TO TALK ABOUT KEEPING
TEACHERS IN THE CLASSROOM AT THE
AND THAT'S THAT'S MY GOAL HERE.
OKAY ARE YOU AWARE THAT TEACH
FOR AMERICA IS THE MOST DIVERSE
TEACHER TRAINING PROGRAM AND
PIPELINE IN THE STATE.
I'M NOT HAVING THE MY MY ISSUES
I TRYING TO ADDRESS SO THERE WE
HAVE A DIVERSE WORKFORCE BUT
WHETHER WE HAVE TEACHERS WITH
EXPERIENCE IN THE CLASSROOM --
FOR AN EXTENDED PERIOD OF TIME.
OKAY MY QUESTION WAS ARE YOU
AWARE THAT TEACH FOR AMERICA IS
THE MOST DIVERSE PIPELINES. ONE
OF LORENA.
I'VE SEEN DATA THAT BERRIES --
DATA THAT TELLS ME THAT 51% OF
TEACH FOR AMERICA OUR ARE
CAUCASIAN.
AND WAS CAR NUMBER LAST NIGHT.
OUR AUTOMATIC REIMAGINE.
THE CROSS EXAMINATION INTEREST
FACTS THAT.
THE SUMMER KILEY HAS STATE THOSE
FACTS AND THEN ASK THE OPINION.
AS OPPOSED TO DO YOU KNOW THIS
YOU KNOW THIS YOU KNOW THAT
SPEAKING OF THE BILL MISTER
KILEY PLEASE SPEAK TO ASK.
SPEAK TO THE PRESS YOU CLEARLY
ALREADY KNOW.
AND THEN IF YOU WANT SO HIM HER
GARCIA TO COMMENT ON THEM SHE
CAN COMMON.
MISTER KALRA.
WHEN I?
WE CAN ACTUALLY HOLD ON HOLD ON
HOLD ON HERE OKAY. ONE PERSON
SPEAKS AT A TIME MR KILEY YOU
ARE GOING TO BE ALLOWED. TO
CONTINUE THE QUESTIONING THE
PLEASE MAKE IT.
SPECIFIC TO THE BILL NOT STUDIES
THAT THE THAT THAT THE AUTHOR OF
THE BILL CAN'T POSSIBLY BE AWARE
OF OR CARRY AROUND IN HER HEAD.
PLEASE KEEP THEM AGAIN RELEVANT
TO THE BILL SO WE CAN GET
THROUGH AND DECIDE WHETHER OR
NOT WE WANT TO SUPPORT THIS
EFFORT.
SURE.
SO I HAVE INFORMATION IN FRONT
OF ME THAT SAYS THAT -- AND I
HAVE NO REASON TO THINK THAT
THIS IS WRONG THE 60% TFA
TEACHERS ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR
COMPARED 238%.
OF THE GENERAL TEACHING
POPULATION THAT'S ABOUT -- ONE
AND A HALF PERCENT MORE -- ONE
IN THREE TEACHERS IN CALIFORNIA
IF THEY TEACHERS IN CALIFORNIA.
ARE THE FIRST IN THEIR FAMILY TO
GO TO COLLEGE -- IN LA OVER HALF
OF TV TEACHERS ARE PROGRAM
RECIPIENTS SO MY QUESTION.
IS WHAT MESSAGE DO YOU THINK IT
SENDS IF WE SINGLE OUT.
THE SINGLE MOST DIVERSE PIPELINE.
FOR TEACHERS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND SAY THAT THIS ONE
ORGANIZATION AS YOUR BILL
ACTUALLY DID BY NAME IN ITS
FIRST ITERATION.
WE WANT TO PREVENT YOU FROM AN
OPERATING ARE.
HOMELESS AND I'M COMFORTABLE
WITH YOU ASKING QUESTIONS BUT
WHEN I'M NOT KIND OF CONTROL BUT
IT -- COMES ALONG YOU DOING IS
MAKING.
ASSERTIONS THAT THAT THAT MAY OR
MAY NOT BE TRUE I MEAN YOU GOT
WE DON'T HAVE THE DATA THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE AUTHOR
DOESN'T HAVE THE DATA SHE CAN
SPEAK TO THE THE QUESTION.
AND CITING STUDIES THE ENTIRE
TIME WE SHE CAN SPEAK TO THE
QUESTION N GENERAL PLEASE
PROCEED.
OUR INDIA THE CITY WE HAVE
REFERENCE ARE IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS -- THAT'S AVAILABLE TO
THE PUBLIC AND HAS BEEN
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC -- AS OF
AS ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE OF COLOR.
THAT WAS IN IN THAT VERSION
ORIGINAL COLLEGE ATTENDEES WHO
WALKED IN AS AS A TEACHER I SAID
AS A TEACHER FOR THIRTEEN YEARS
AND HAD THE BEST.
VALUES AND WANTED TO DO THE BEST
FOR THE STUDENTS TO LOOK JUST
LIKE ME AND SO IMPACTED.
THAT'S NOT ENOUGH.
HAVING THAT GOOD WILL IS NOT
ENOUGH TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE
GETTING THE EDUCATION THEY NEED
TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN THAT THE
MESSAGE I'M SENDING THOSE PEOPLE
THAT WE NEED.
MORE AND AND THEN I ALSO HOPE
THAT ONCE WE INVESTING YOU YOU
SAY THAT PASSED THAT TWO YEAR
COMMITMENT IS WE NEED TO THEIR
LONG TERM WE NEED TO BE THAT
EXPERIENCE TEACHER THAT BECAUSE
OR ROLE MODEL.
AND THE MENTOR FOR THE FEATURES
THAT ARE COMING BEHIND YOU.
THANK YOU I I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY SOME YOU SAID BEFORE YOU
YOU SEEM TO SUGGEST YOU ARE
AGAINST -- ANY SORT OF IN TURN
CREDENTIAL IS THAT RIGHT.
I AM NOT AND I HAD THE I AM
TALKING AS THE BILL HERE SPEAKS
AND SO ITS THIRD PARTY --
EMPLOYMENT TYPE PROGRAMS THAT WE
ARE NOW.
COME TO THINK THAT THIS BILL I
SEE SO WHY SHOULD WE CREATED
DISTINCTION THOUGH -- BETWEEN
INTERNAL CREDENTIALS FOR THIRD
PARTY -- ORGANIZATIONS AND OTHER
TYPES OF INITIAL CREDENTIALS NOT
BE OUT THERE.
DATE THE THEMSELVES CREATED
DISTINCTION WHEN THEY CHARTS THE
SCHOOL'S AVERAGE OF FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR FOR
THESE PLACEMENTS -- TO BEGIN
WITH I THINK THERE'S A FEW OTHER
ITEMS THAT MAKE THEM DISTINCT
OUT THERE AND AGAIN I THINK THE
BILL SPEAKS THE TIME COMMITMENT.
OF THE PARTICIPANTS IN THE
PROGRAM AND ALSO TO THE FEES
CHARGED TO A SCHOOL DISTRICT TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM THAT
IS THAT IS THE SIGNIFICANT
CONCERN I REALLY THAT SHE'S
PRESENTED TODAY I'M NOT THE NAME
OF THE PROGRAM.
BUT THE SORT OF OKAY SO THAT
THAT IS PART OF THE SEASON.
THE FISCAL ACADEMIC IMPLICATIONS
OF THE PROGRAM HER CONCERNS OKAY
AND I'M AGAIN ADDRESS MY
QUESTIONS TO THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL I IT THAT IS ONE OF THE
PRONGS IS DEALING WITH -- THESE
PLACEMENT FEES BUT ANOTHER
PROBLEM DEAL SIMPLY WITH
PARTNERING.
WITH A THIRD PARTY ORGANIZATION
AND WITH PLACING FOLKS A TITLE
ONE SCHOOL SO.
WHY SHOULD WE DISTINGUISH -- YOU
KNOW THOSE SORT OF ARRANGEMENTS --
FROM OTHER TYPES OF INTERN
CREDENTIALS IF YOUR CONCERNS
TEACHER PREPARATION.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE LOSING THE
TEACHERS THE QUICKEST AND THE
FASTEST AT THE FASTEST RATE ALSO.
I WANT.
TO GO BACK TO SOMETHING THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I'LL WEBER
BROUGHT UP YEAH AND IT SPEAKS TO
YOUR CONCERN ASSEMBLY MEMBER AYE
GARCIA THAT YOU THINK THAT THAT
WE NEED TO HAVE KIND OF MORE
EXPERIENCED TEACHERS ANDIN
SCHOOLS IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES WHO MIGHT -- SORRY A
WAY FOR YOU.
TO I UNDERSTAND AND I JUST GOT
OVER A COLD MYSELF.
SO I AM I AM I REPRESENTING YOUR
YOUR VIEW CORRECTLY THAT WE NEED
TO HAVE MORE EXPERIENCE TEACHERS
IN THESE -- YOU KNOW LOW INCOME
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS WITH MORE
FORMAL STUDENT POPULATIONS
[inaudible]
YES.
SO ASSEMBLY MEMBER I WEBER
BROUGHT OUT BY THE POINT THAT WE
HAVE THESE -- PREFERENCES THAT
ARE KIND OF A PRODUCT OF STATE
LAW WHERE -- YOU KNOW MORE
SENIOR TEACHERS ACTUALLY GET
FIRST CHOICE OVER THE SCHOOLS
THEY GO.
TO ACTUALLY TO BE THAT THAT
WOULD BE NEGOTIATED AT THE LOCAL
DISTRICT LEVEL.
THAT THAT'S WHERE THAT TYPE OF
AGREEMENT WITH THE KURDS SO
AGAIN I'M GIVING YOU KNOW I'LL
LET ME FINISH LET ME FINISH IS A
LISTEN WE'RE GONNA TALK FACTS
HERE K..
NOT GONNA MAKE UP STUFF JUST
THROW IT OUT THERE HOPE IT
STICKS GAY THAT WOULD BE
NEGOTIATED IN THE LOCAL DISTRICT
MO YOU CONTRACT IT WOULD NOT BE
SOMETHING THAT TO AN ANIMAL OF
THE STATE -- NOT ACCURATE
ACTUALLY THE STATE GOVERNMENT
ACTUALLY ACT REQUIRES THAT IS
BEING NEGOTIATED YOUR LINE OF
QUESTIONING SO IT IS CUT OFF
LET'S GO GET IT IS CORRECT THAT
THAT IS TO GO SHE HATED -- AT
THE DISTRICT LEVEL BUT THE
REQUIREMENT TO HAVE A PROVISION
RELATING TO CRESSMAN IS PRODUCT
OF THE STATE GOVERNMENT CODE.
SO -- THERE'VE BEEN A TIMES IN
THIS LEGISLATURE TO ACTUALLY
CHANGE THAT PROVISION OF THE
STATE GOVERNMENT HAD. TO CHANGE
THE SORT OF A SENIORITY BUMPING
SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE THE MOST
EXPERIENCED TEACHERS GIVEN
PREFERENCE WHERE TO GO AND AND
YOU KNOW MORE OFTEN THAN NOT
GOING AWAY FROM THE LOW INCOME
SCHOOL SO WOULD YOU.
COMMIT TO AMENDING THE BILL --
TO TRY TO DO AWAY WITH THE SORT
OF SENIORITY BUMPING PRACTICES
TO GET YOUR CONCERN HAVING MORE
EXPERIENCED TEACHERS LOW INCOME
SCHOOLS [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
OKAY.
DO YOU THINK THAT WOULD NOT BE
AN EFFECTIVE WAY TO DEAL WITH
THIS CONCERN.
I DON'T THINK THAT THAT'S THE
PURPOSE OF MY BILL AT THIS VERY
MOMENT IN BRINGING LIGHT.
I TO A PRACTICE THAT MIGHT
INCLUDE THAT RELATE TO THAT --
DISCUSSION BUT I'M NOT GOING TO
COMMIT TO COMPLETELY CHANGE HIM
A BILL TO PLEASE -- YOU TODAY AT
SENDING YOU AND I COULD DISCUSS
AT A LATER TIME ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
I HAVE ABOUT ONE OTHER AREA SO
THERE'S BEEN SOME DISCUSSION
ABOUT DIFFERENT STUDIES AND I
KNOW BOTH SIDES PRESENT
CONFLICTING ARE TO SOME EXTENT
CONFLICTING -- DATA AS TO
TEACHER PERFORMANCE DO WE HAVE
ANY DATA AS FAR AS THE
PERFORMANCE OF TSA BAY TEACHERS
VERSES THE PERFORMANCE OF LONG
TERM SUBSTITUTES.
SO THE WINNER DRAWING HAMMOND
STUDY FROM TWO THOUSAND FIVE WE
LOOK THAT AND NOT EASILY
SUBSTITUTES BUT UNCERTIFIED
TEACHERS WHO COULD BE IN THAT --
GROUP -- AND TFA PERFORM
SLIGHTLY BETTER THAN THE AND
CERTIFIED TEACHERS BUT NOT
BETTER THAN THE CERTIFIED
EXPERIENCED TEACHERS.
BUT I THINK THE KEY THERE IS
THAT.
CHOOSING BATTLE WORSE IS THE
ENEMY OF GOOD.
OKAY BUT YEAH IT SOUNDS LIKE
YOU'VE SORT OF ACCEPT WHAT IS MY
IMPLICIT PROMISE -- THAT -- IF
YOU YOU SIMPLY SAY WE CAN'T HAVE
TFA ANYMORE THAT THERE WILL BE
MORE LONG TERM SUBS PLACED IN
SCHOOLS.
THERE'S A STATE CAN HAVE MORE
TFA.
IS IS THAT YOUR OF YOUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT WILL ENTER INTO A
CONTRACT FOR FIVE YEARS WITH
THIRD PARTIES WHICH INCLUDES
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE.
TFA OUT THERE ARE THAT YOU THAT
YOU WILL MAKE SURE YOU TRY TO IF
THEY'RE GOOD ENOUGH FOR A STATUS
TO THEM AND THEY SHOULD BE GOOD
ENOUGH FOR ANOTHER SET OF
STUDENTS THAT WE DON'T HAVE. TO
CLASS THE STUDENTS AND SO I
THINK THAT THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WE HAVE TAKEN THAT'S WHAT THE
BILL SAYS CORRECTED TO BE CLEAR --
THE AMENDMENTS DON'T BAN TFA.
WITH A C. TO DO IS GET MORE
EXPERIENCE TEACHERS IN THE
CLASSROOM THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF
THE BILL.
OKAY MISTER I CAN JUST ASK ALSO
THE WITNESS AS WELL BECAUSE YOU
WOULD COMMENT ON THIS AYE IN
RESPONSE TO MY QUESTION DO YOU
THAT EXCEPT THAT -- IS THE
RESULT OF THIS BILL WOULD BE THE
PLACEMENT OF MORE LONG TERM SUBS
AT LEAST IN THE FORESEEABLE
FUTURE.
I THINK IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO KNOW
WHETHER LABOR MARKET A LOOK LIKE
OVER THE NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS
AND IT.
YOU KNOW -- MAYBE DISTRICTS WILL
PAY TEACHERS MORE MAYBE WORKING
CONDITIONS WILL IMPROVE THERE'S
I THINK TOO MANY VARIABLES TO
MAKE THAT A SUNSET ALL THINGS
BEING EQUAL DO YOU THINK THE
BILL WOULD RESULT IN THE
PLACEMENT OF MORE LONG TERM SUB
SOMETHINGS ARE NEVER EQUAL.
SO YOU'RE NOT ANSWER QUESTIONS
ALL RIGHT.
SO.
IS THERE ANY EVIDENCE THAT YOU
COULD SEE HIM IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA -- AT THAT WOULD GET YOU
KNOW BASED UPON THE PERFORMANCE
OF OF TFA TEACHES VERSUS NON TFA
TEACHERS -- THAT WOULD CONVINCE
YOU THIS BILL IS NOT A GOOD IDEA.
AT THE MOMENT THERE HASN'T BEEN
BUT YOU AND I CAN CONTINUE THE
DISCUSSION ON IN THE FUTURE I
MUST HAVE KNOWN WHAT.
THE PARAMETERS OF THE DEBATE ARE
SO IF WE WERE TO HAVE EVIDENCE
SHOWING THAT.
THE TEACHERS WERE FIRED AT ARMS.
MEMBERS OF THE DEBATE ARE ON THE
BILL.
YOU KNOW YOU DON'T NEED TO GET
IS SOME ESOTERIC CONVERSATION
ABOUT WHAT YOU MIGHT WANT TO DO
IN THE FUTURE CAN YOU SPEAK TO
THE TENANTS OF THE BILL.
VOTE NO VOTE YES.
BUT THIS LINE OF QUESTIONING IS
CONTINUING ON FOREVER AND
GETTING NO WHERE.
WELL I I THINK IT'S PARTLY TO
BLAME FOR THAT MISTER CHAIR SO I
WILL WRAP UP MY QUESTIONING AT
THIS POINT.
I AND I WILL SAY JUST IN CLOSING
THAT I ACTUALLY WANT TO THANK
YOU.
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
[inaudible]
WE HAVE. SEVEN THOUSAND TFA
ALARMS IN CALIFORNIA WHO KNOW
BETTER THAN ANYONE THAT OUR
PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM IS
FAILING OUR KIDS AND THE DATA
BEAR THAT OUT.
THAT OUR KIDS IN LOW INCOME
SCHOOLS -- GET A WORSE EDUCATION
HERE THAN ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE
COUNTRY TF ELEMENT ALUMS KNOW
THAT BETTER THAN ANYONE AND THIS
BILL.
MAKES VERY CLEAR THE MAIN REASON
WHY IS THAT WE HAVE A COMMITTEE
HERE.
AT THE LEGISLATURE THAT IS NOT
FOCUSED ON KIDS AND IT OPERATES
AS A DEFAULT MODE OF PASTA
POLICY MAKING IS ANTI STUDENT
ANTI TEACHER AND ACT ANTI I
FORTY AND THERE IS A MOVEMENT TO
CHANGE THAT.
TEACH FOR AMERICA IS A BIG PART
OF THAT MOVEMENT AND I THINK
THIS BILL MIGHT GET PAST THIS
COMMITTEE DON'T A DANIELLE WILL
NOT PASS.
AND I THINK IT WILL GO OUT.
IF YOU DON'T.
EVERY.
MR KILEY YOU DON'T NEED THE L.
TO MAKE YOUR POINT [inaudible]
PLEASE CONTINUE.
AND I THINK THAT WE WILL THAT
THAT YOU'RE GONNA HELP US TO
GALVANIZE THIS MOVEMENT TO
ENSURE THAT YES ONE DAY EVERY
CHILD IN CALIFORNIA WILL HAVE
ACCESS TO AN EXCELLENT EDUCATION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- BEFORE THE OTHER
CLOSES I JUST WANT TO SAY AS A
TEACHER IN A TITLE ONE SCHOOL I
WANT SOMEONE TEACHING NEXT DOOR
TO ME THAT IS DEDICATED TO THE
PROFESSION.
NOT SIMPLY TRYING TO BUILD A
RESUME IT'S THAT SIMPLE AND MY
CONCERN WITH ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
TFA I LISTEN I I THINK IT'S VERY
NOBLE HELP SUPPORT TEACHERS GET
IN THE CLASSROOM.
AS LONG AS THEY HAVE A
COMMITMENT TO KIDS AND A
COMMITMENT TO THE PROFESSION
THAT'S WHAT MY CONCERN COMES
WITH WITH YOUR EFFORTS THUS FAR
BUT EXTENDING OUT THE TIME
COMMITMENT FROM THE ORGANIZATION.
AND ALSO THOSE PEOPLE PLACED IN
A CLASSROOM I THINK IT'S A
POSITIVE THING. FOR KIDS IT'S A
POSITIVE THING FOR THE
PROFESSION IN FACT IT SAYS
TEACHING IS A PROFESSION.
IMAGINE IF WE SAID WELL YOU'LL
BE A PARAMEDIC FOR TWO YEARS YOU
CAN START TODAY.
AND THEN IN TWO YEARS YOU CAN
MOVE ON TO GOING TO GRAD SCHOOLS
ARE GOING TO LAW SCHOOL BECAUSE
THAT'S TYPICALLY WHAT PEOPLE ARE
DOING.
THEY'RE USING THIS AS A RESUME
BUILDER BECAUSE THEY WANT TO GO
ON TO SOME HE LIED GRAD SCHOOL
OR LAW SCHOOL -- AND I WONDER IF
WE'RE NOT JUST.
FEELING A POT HOLE WITH TFN.
AS OPPOSED TO RE PAVING THE
STREET RIGHT WHAT IS OUR PROMISE
BEEN MENTION OF HEREBY EVERYBODY
EVERYBODY THAT ARE PROBLEMS
GETTING EXPERIENCED TEACHERS IN
THESE TITLE ONE SCHOOLS IN FACT
IN ALL SCHOOLS RIGHT.
AND WE NEED TO WORK AS A
COMMITTEE AS A BODY AS A
LEGISLATURE. TO ADDRESS THAT WE
NEED TO DO THAT LISTEN I HAVE
LIVED THIS MORE THAN ANYONE ON
THIS DíAS.
OKAY I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO
HAVE AN EXPERIENCED TEACHERS AT
A SCHOOL SITE.
IT IS DANGEROUS IT IS NOT SAFE
OKAY THEN WE MOVE ON TO THE
ACADEMICS EXPERIENCES SO WE
REALLY NEED TO WORK ON THAT IN
THAT ROOM AND WHAT ABOUT THE MID
NINETIES WHEN WE STARTED THE
CLASS SIZE REDUCTION.
NEWBIES WERE COMING ESPECIALLY.
AT THE MIDDLE SCHOOL LEVEL LIKE
THAT RIGHT.
RIGHT NOW THAT SLOW DOWN OVER
THE YEARS BECAUSE THE PIPELINE
INCREASED AND AND THINGS CHANGED --
BUT I'M WORRIED THAT WE'RE
HEADIN BACK IN. TO THAT ERA SO
THIS COMMITTEE THIS BODY THIS
LEGISLATURE AGAIN NEEDS TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE BECAUSE IT
SPEAKS.
THE CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE SO WITH
THAT I'M GOING TO HAVE YOU CLOSE
YOU DO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CLOSE --
ONE I THINK THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE ROBUST DISCUSSION I THINK WE
HAVE BEEN GALVANIZED SOUTH THAT
BODY FOR OUR STUDENTS AND
TODAY'S DISCUSSION ON BOTH SIDES --
MOVES THAT THIS MOVE THIS
FORWARD CLOSER. TO TO REALLY
IDENTIFIED THE PROBLEM -- AND
ARE WE AND ARE WE REALLY COMING
UP WITH SOLUTIONS ARE JUST
ELAINE AND PROLONGING AND DOING
MORE FOR THE SERVICES SIT INS
FOR ANOTHER GENERATION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAY VOTE.
THANK YOU -- THE MOTION IS -- WE
NEED A MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS YOU'RE PRETTY
TOUGH WHAT IS THEIR AUTHOR THERE
MISS GARCIA.
A JOB UNDER QUESTIONING THEIR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE SMITH SMITH I WEBER.
WEBER AYE.
YOU GOES FIVE OH TO DESIGN.
IS THE MYSTERY OF US WHERE ARE
YOU.
WAKE UP.
YEAH I SAW YOU SITTING OUT THERE.
I KNOW TOMORROW SHE'S GOING TO
COME OUT THREE ON THE FLOOR AND
ASKED TO BE ON THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
MAYBE NOT.
OUR WITH THAT MYSTERY WAS IS
GOING TO PRESENT -- AT SHE HAS
TWO BILLS WHEN WE START WITH AB
ONE ONE SIX IF WE CAN IF WE MAY.
SIXTEEN AB SO AB SIXTEEN ARE YOU
OKAY STARTING WITH AB SIXTEEN OR
ALL OF YOUR GOT IF YOU GOT
EVERYBODY UP THERE LET'S JUST DO
A DO YOU ARE THEY WHAT YOU WANNA
DO YOU TELL ME.
LET'S GO THOUGH.
SO I THINK LET'S. TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY TWO YES AB ONE EIGHTY TWO
IS.
GOING TO BE FIRST AB ONE EIGHTY
TWO AND THAT'S FILE ITEM TWO OR
THREE I'M NOT SURE WHICH THREE
FIVE NINE THREE YEAH
[inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT -- THEY MAY PROCEED
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FOR CONSIDERING THIS
MEASURE.
I'D LIKE TO START BY ACCEPTING
ALL OF THE COMMITTEES PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS THAT ESTABLISH A
WORKING GROUP TO EVALUATE THE
NEED FOR A SINGLE SUBJECT
TEACHING CREDENTIAL.
AND I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
MY TEAM ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO TAKE THE
CHAIR FOR HIS COMMITMENT TO ME
THAT I'LL BE ALLOWED TO BRING A
SINGLE SUBJECT TEACHING
CREDENTIAL BILL BEFORE THE FULL
COMMITTEE FOR CONSIDERATION NEXT
YEAR -- PASS THE LEGISLATION TO
DEVELOP A COMPUTER SCIENCE
SINGLE SUBJECT TEACHING
CREDENTIAL IS A RECOMMENDATION
FROM THE COMPUTER SCIENCE
STRATEGIC IMPLEMENTATION PLAN
WHICH THE LEGISLATURE DIRECTED
THE CD. TO CONVENE AS A RESULT
OF AB -- TWENTY THREE TWENTY
NINE BY FORMER ASSEMBLY WOMAN --
SCHISM MONIA WHICH IS HERE TODAY
WITH ME -- IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT WHILE CALIFORNIA IS A
GLOBAL TECHNOLOGY LEADER THE
INDUSTRY STILL CANNOT MEET ITS
LABOR DEMANDSWITH OVER SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND OPEN COMPUTING
JOBS WITH AN AVERAGE SALARY
ABOVE A HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
DESPITE 93% OF PARENTS WANTING
THEIR CHILD TO STUDY COMPUTER
SCIENCE ONLY 35% OF SCHOOLS
OFFER A COURSE IN COMPUTER
SCIENCE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND ONLY 25% OF SCHOOLS -- OFFER
IT IN DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
LIKE MINE -- EXPANDING COMPUTER
SCIENCE EDUCATION IS ALSO AN
ISSUE OF EQUITY.
OF THE 1-000-020-0404 CALIFORNIA
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS WHO TOOK
THE AP COMPUTER SCIENCE EXAM IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN ONLY 27% WERE
FEMALE ONLY 14% FOR LATINO AND
JUST ONE POINT 4% WERE AFRICAN
AMERICAN.
THAT IS YOU KNOW SOMETHING THAT
WE REALLY NEED TO CHANGE IN OAK
PEOPLE THAT LOOK LIKE ME THAT
ARE FROM COMMUNITIES LIKE ME ARE
NOT GETTING ACCESS TO
OPPORTUNITY YOU KNOW I TOOK.
MY FIRST COMPUTER SCIENCE CLASS
THIRTY FIVE YEARS AGO WHEN I WAS
IN FIFTH GRADE AND I DON'T WANT
TO WAIT ANOTHER THIRTY FIVE
YEARS FOR COMPUTER SCIENCE TO BE.
ACCESSIBLE ON TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES ON'T SO CURRENTLY TO
TEACH COMPUTER SCIENCE A TEACHER
MUST EITHER BE CREDENTIALED IN
MATH.
BUSINESS OR INDUSTRIAL
TECHNOLOGY EDUCATION OR RECEIVE
A SUPPLEMENTARY AUTHORIZATION --
A DEDICATED CREDENTIAL IN
COMPUTER SCIENCE WOULD ATTRACT
TEACHERS WHO MAY BE TURNED OFF
FROM THE PERCENT PROFESSION BY
THIS ROUND ABOUT PATHWAY TO
AUTHORIZATION AND YOU KNOW MANY
PEOPLE HAVE ASKED ME.
WHO WOULD?
OF NOT ENTER OF THE COMPUTER
SCIENCE FIELD -- N. OR LEAVE THE
COMPUTER SCIENCE FIELD TO BECOME
A COMPUTER SCIENCE TEACHER AND
YOU KNOW I KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE.
THAT WOULD LIKE TO DO THAT YOU
KNOW I COME FROM A STEM
BACKGROUND -- MOST OF MY NETWORK
AND FRIENDS ARE IN STEM
PROFESSIONS -- AND YOU KNOW A
LOT OF THEM HAVE ALREADY BUILT
THEIR RESUME AND NOW WANT TO
GIVE BACK TO UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES BY TEACHING --
COMPUTER SCIENCE SO -- YOU KNOW
I JUST I THINK. FOR WITH A STATE
LIKE CALIFORNIA WITH A LOT OF
TECH PROFESSIONALS -- THAT THERE
ARE A LOT THAT DO WANT TO ENTER
THE TEACHING PROFESSION.
SO I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK OUR
ALEXIS HER AGAIN FROM C¡ DOT
ORG AND FORMER ASSEMBLYWOMAN
SUSAN BOCHNIA WHO AUTHORED THE
BILL THAT CREATED THE STRATEGIC
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN.
WILL BE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. FOR THESE REASONS
REASONS I URGE YOU TO VOTE I ON
AB ONE EIGHTY TWO AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THIS
COMMITTEE THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS ALEXIS
MINAKATA HERE AGAIN.
I'M A CO DOT ORG C DOT ORG IS
A NONPROFIT DEDICATED TO
EXPANDING ACCESS OF COMPUTER
SCIENCE IN SCHOOLS AND
INCREASING PARTICIPATION BY
WOMEN AND UNDERREPRESENTED
MINORITIES.
WE BELIEVE EVERY CHILD IN
CALIFORNIA SHOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN COMPUTER
SCIENCE WE THINK THE CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND COMMITMENT TO
COMPUTER SCIENCE EDUCATION.
WE HAVE SEEN A RECORD NUMBER OF
COMPUTER SCIENCE BILLS
INTRODUCED AT THIS YEAR AND THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION IS ALSO
MAKING SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS TO
EXPAND ACCESS.
THE ADOPTION OF THE K. TWELVE
COMPUTER SCIENCE STANDARDS AND
THE SOON TO BE ADOPTED CS.
STRATEGIC IMPLEMENTATION PLAN.
OUR COMPUTER SCIENCE CHAMPIONS
KNOW THAT HAVING A FOUNDATIONAL
KNOWLEDGE OF COMPUTER SCIENCE
OPENS DOORS.
AB ONE EIGHTY TWO WILL CREATE A
CLEAR PATHWAY FOR FUTURE
COMPUTER SCIENCE TEACHERS.
THE EXISTING SUPPLEMENTARY
AUTHORIZATION FOR COMPUTER
SCIENCE ALLOWS TEACHERS TO TEACH
CS BUT DOES NOT PROVIDE THE
ADEQUATE INFRASTRUCTURE TO
SUPPORT TEACHERS WHO MAY WANT TO
TEACH CS AS THEIR PRIMARY
SUBJECT.
INSTEAD OF A FUTURE COMPUTER
SCIENCE EDUCATOR MUST OBTAIN A
SINGLE SUBJECT CREDENTIAL IN
ANOTHER SUBJECT AND THEN SPENT
EXTRA TIME AND MONEY.
OUTSIDE OF THEIR CREDENTIALING
PROGRAM TO TAKE ADDITIONAL
COURSEWORK IN COMPUTER SCIENCE.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO OFFER
TEACHERS MULTIPLE PATHWAYS TO
TEACH CS IN ORDER TO MEET THEIR
NEEDS.
THIS BILL CREATES A SINGLE
SUBJECT CREDENTIAL FOR COMPUTER
SCIENCE THAT WOULD TARGET
TEACHERS WHO WANT TO TEACH THE
S. AS THEIR PRIMARY SUBJECT AREA.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE NO
CREDENTIALING PROGRAMS IN
COMPUTER SCIENCE THAT EXIST AT
CALIFORNIA'S HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS.
THE CREATION OF A SINGLE SUBJECT
CREDENTIAL IT WOULD INCENTIVIZE
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES TO
CREATE.
CS CREDENTIALING PRORAMS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M SUSAN
BONY AND HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY
REPRESENTING A NONPROFIT READY
NATION OF BUSINESS LEADERS.
WHO CARE A GREAT DEAL ABOUT A
COMPUTER SCIENCE EDUCATION IN
OUR K. TWELVE SYSTEM?
I'M JUST A FEW POINTS I WANTED
TO TOUCH ON ONE IS THAT --
TEACHERS GO INTO THE PROFESSION
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A PASSION THEY
ARE NOT IN IT FOR THE MONEY.
AND SO IF WE ARE ABLE TO
ESTABLISH A CREDENTIAL I REALLY
BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE THOSE
FUTURE TEACHERS THAT HAVE A
PASSION FOR COMPUTER SCIENCE
MAYBE NOT FOR THOSE OTHER
SUBJECTS.
AND THAT THEY WOULD REALLY
APPRECIATE IT DEDICATED COURSE
OF TEACHER PREPARATION IN
COMPUTER SCIENCE -- I YOU KNOW
YOU CAN I THINK SOME PEOPLE
THINK YOU CAN JUST TEACH ANY
SUBJECT THAT MAYBE YOU'VE GOT A
LOT OF EDUCATION BUT ACTUALLY
THE SKILL OF TEACHING.
IS UNIQUE AND DIFFERENT AND SO
CERTAINLY NOT ONLY CAN WE
CAPTURE THOSE PEOPLE WITH THAT
PASSION BUT THEN WE HOPE TO
ENCOURAGE OUR UNIVERSITIES TO
ACTUALLY DEVELOP DEDICATED.
COMPUTER SCIENCE EDUCATION
PROGRAMS -- THIS MIGHT BE
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT THAN THE
COMPUTER SCIENCE MAJOR AND MIGHT
SOLVE THAT PROBLEM WHERE
COMPUTER SCIENTIST MAYBE ARE
TRACKED INTO A DIFFERENT
PROFESSIONAL TOGETHER BUT
COMPUTER SCIENCE EDUCATION
MAJORS WANT TO GO AND HELP
OTHERS UNDERSTAND -- THE
INTRICACIES OF COMPUTER SCIENCE
AND THEN UP FINALLY -- WE ARE
ALSO HOPING THERE WOULD BE AN
EXAM THAT WOULD THEN HAPPENED
WITH THE NEW CREDENTIAL
CURRENTLY THERE IS NO SEE SAID
EXAM EVERY OTHER -- ONE OF OUR
SINGLE SUBJECT CREDENTIALS
REQUIRES THIS THE EXAM THEY TAKE
IS FOR INDUSTRIAL TECHNOLOGY
WHICH DOES NOT HAVE ONE QUESTION
ABOUT COMPUTER SCIENCE ON IT BUT
IT DOES HAVE A QUESTION ASKING
YOU HOW TO CHANGE A TIRE.
SO I THINK THAT THERE IS A
BENEFIT -- TO THE TEACHING
PROFESSION EXPANDING THE
PROFESSION AND MAKING SURE THAT
THESE HIGH QUALITY -- TEACHING
THAT HAPPENS AND I REALLY
COMMEND THOSE TEACHERS OF THE
FIRST ADOPTERS WHO ARE GOING OUT
AND GETTING THAT SUPPLEMENTARY
AUTHORIZATION.
MY CONCERN IS AROUND EQUITY WHAT
ABOUT THE DISTRICTS WHERE THERE
ISN'T ONE OF THOSE REALLY GO
GETTER TEACHERS THAT'S WILLING
TO PUT IN THAT EXTRA TIME. FOR
THE EXTRA TRAINING I THINK THIS
IS A STATE WIDE INTEREST TO MAKE
SURE THAT ALL ACROSS THE THE
STATE IN YEARS TO COME THERE
WOULD ACTUALLY BE A CREDENTIAL
COMPUTER SCIENCE TEACHER
AVAILABLE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU UP WITH OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
DONNA ARE TWO CABBAGE CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA IN SUPPORT.
SHANNON PRIMER EDUCATIONAL
PARALEGAL MY HUSBAND'S WATCHING
AND SAN DIEGO WERE BOTH IN
SUPPORT.
PROJECT LEAD THE WAY IN SPORTS.
INJURIES.
COURTNEY JENSEN ATTACK NOT IN
SUPPORT.
THEY BROKE ON BEHALF OF
MICROSOFT CORPORATION IN SUPPORT --
ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ISABEL
GARCIA REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
FIRST WE WANT TO THANK THE
DISTINGUISHED AUTHOR FOR
INTRODUCING THE BILL AND THE
COMMITTEE THE HARD WORK ON THE
ANALYSIS WHICH REALLY.
ELOQUENTLY LAYS OUT THE HARD
WORK OF THE STRATEGIC PLAN.
ON THE TWENTY THREE MANNER
MEMBER PANEL YOU LAID OUT ALL
THE ISSUES AND THE PROGRESS WAS
MADE IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN WITH THE
STATE BOARD OF DOCTOR COMPUTER
SCIENCE STANDARDS AND I WANT TO
SALUTE.
A COMMAND OF THE FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER A SUSAN BORNEO
WHO WE WORKED WITH IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN TO CREATE THE PANEL.
AND THE DAY AND WE WERE SO HAPPY
THAT WE HAD EIGHT TEACHERS ON
THAT PANEL AND SOME OF THEM
TAUGHT A P. COMPUTER SCIENCE IN
HIGH SCHOOL OR IN A MIDDLE
SCHOOL OR IN ELEMENTARY SO.
IT WAS A VERY VIBRANT PIANO AND
YOUR YOUR ANALYSIS POINTS OUT
THAT THE DRAFT PLAN HAS A MULTI
PRONGED APPROACH ANYWAY I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT WITH THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WE ARE NOT
ONLY GOING TO REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION BUT WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO A SUPPORT THE BILL.
WE THINK THAT THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT WORKING WERE UNITED IN.
THAT WE ALL WANT TO RECRUIT AND
RETAIN.
TEACHERS THANK YOU COMPUTER
SCIENCE THINK.
THAT WAS PRETTY SMOOTH.
I HAVE TO GO AFTER HER.
THIS IS LAW HER PRESIDENT
DISSOCIATION CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS WE TOO ARE
REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION AND IT
WILL BE ASKING FOR SUPPORT.
THE ONE OF THE THINGS I JUST
WANT TO ADD IS THAT IT WOULD BE
REALLY HELPFUL TO HAVE A
CREDENTIAL ANALYST IN THIS WORK
GROUP.
WE DID SEEM TO ALWAYS AVOID OR
NOT INCLUDE THEM AND THERE'S A
THE REAL EXPERTS IN PREVENTION
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- ANY OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION SEEN OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION WILL BRING IT BACK I
JUST WANNA -- THANK YOU WAS
REVERSE FOR YOUR PATIO VERY
PASSIONATE ABOUT THIS ISSUE THAT
HAS BEEN WELL DISPLAYED TO ME.
AND IT'S ALSO PERSONAL TO YOU SO
I APPRECIATE THAT AND I KNOW YOU
WANTED.
TO GO THROUGH WITH THE
CREDENTIALS WITHOUT ANY WORK
GROUP THIS YEAR BUT WE KINDA.
HE SAID THAT WE'VE GOT TO GIVE
THIS SOME PROCESS BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT WE'VE DONE IN THE PAST AND
SO WE'RE GONNA DO THAT THIS YEAR.
AND I'M VERY CONFIDENT THAT
WE'LL GET THAT WORKING GROUP
TOGETHER AND GET IT DONE BY THE
START OF NEXT YEAR BECAUSE IF
NOT YOUR COME BACK WITH A BILL.
RIGHT I KNOW THAT -- YOU SHARED
THAT WITH ME AND I JUST WANNA
THANK AS A FORMER SELLING A
RUNNING FOR HER THIS IS THE
FRUITION OF SOME OF YOUR WORK
FOR SURE.
AND YOUR PASSION SO THANK YOU I
JUST THINK ON THE MORE IMMEDIATE --
FOR THE MORE.
IS SHORT TERM.
TAKE A LOOK AT THERE'S A BILL
THAT I HAVE AND AND I MISS A
QUIRK SILVA HAS IT SPEAKS TO A
MORE EVERY IMMEDIATE RESPONSE TO
THIS NEED.
WHICH IS TO CREATE MORE
SUPPLEMENTALS AND AND WHY THAT --
BECAUSE NUMBER ONE IT'S MORE
MEDIA BUT ALSO NUMBER TWO IT'S
SOME SCHOOL SITES YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO HAVE THE NUMBER
STUDENTS NECESSARY TO SUPPORT.
THAT -- YOU KNOW COMPUTER
SCIENCE ONLY CREDENTIALED
TEACHERS SO THAT'S A DYNAMIC I
JUST WANT YOU TO BE WELL AWARE
OF THAT'S PROBABLY WHERE WHERE
AXIS COMING FROM I CAN'T SAY I
YOU KNOW I CAN'T SPEAK FOR THEM
BUT I THERE'S SOME
ADMINISTRATIVE.
REALITIES HERE TO WHEN YOU GET
PEOPLE JUST PARTICULAR --
CREDENTIALS SO -- SO WITH THAT --
ANY OTHER FOR MANY MANY.
THE BILL'S EMOTIVE SECOND --
THEM.
DO YOU DO YOU DO EXCEPT BE THE
THE EMINENCE.
THEM -- THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
I DO WHICH YOU WISH CLOSE --
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR IPHONE.
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL AYE
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY KALRA.
KALRA I'D MCCARTY SMITH.
SMITH I WEBER.
THE BILL HAS THREE VOTES WHAT IS
ON CALL OKAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IT NEEDS -- FOR WITH THAT WE'RE
GONNA GET TO IT OF ONE MORE.
I DO AB SIXTEEN AB SIXTEEN WHICH
IS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FILE ITEM NUMBER. TWO ONE FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO YOU MAY PERCEIVE
ALREADY OKAY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I WANT TO
START BY ACCEPTING THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS AND THANKING THE
COMMITTEE.
OF FOR WORKING WITH ME ON THIS
BILL -- AB SIXTEEN ESTABLISHES A
COMPREHENSIVE POLICY APPROACH
THAT WILL GIVE THE STATE THE
ABILITY TO BETTER HELP
COMMUNITIES.
VIED SERVICES TO HOMELESS
FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN BY
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION HOMELESS COORDINATORS
AND BY FUNDING THREE GEOGRAPHIC
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION. TO
DEVELOP TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
CENTERS.
IN MY DISTRICT SPECIFICALLY AT
MY OLD ELEMENTARY SCHOOL 24% OF
THE STUDENTS WERE CONSIDERED
HOMELESS -- LAST SCHOOL YEAR THE
HIGHEST RATED ANY OF THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT'S ELEVEN HUNDRED
SCHOOLS IN LOS ANGELES -- THIS
IS UNACCEPTABLE YOUR CALIFORNIA
HAS EXPERIENCED A RISE IN
STUDENTS EXPERIENCE.
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS BUT
THERE HAS BEEN NO INCREASE -- IN
RESOURCES PARTICULARLY IN CD
EASE FUNDING TO COMBAT
HOMELESSNESS.
AB SIXTEEN WILL ENSURE THAT THE
CD AND DISTRICTS HAVE RESOURCES
NEEDED TO ASSIST OUR HOMELESS
CHILDREN.
AND COORDINATE BETWEEN OUR
EXISTING STATE AND LOCAL
HOMELESS EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
I'M EXCITED TO HAVE WITH ME
TODAY COOLEY UNCLE HAVE US
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
AT CD SALT.
TURN IT OVER TO HIM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
MEMBERS AND OF COURSE COMMITTEE
STAFF -- THANK WELL AS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND.
AND SPONSOR OF AB -- SIXTEEN IN
SUPPORT NO IN THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN SCHOOL YEAR
THERE WERE TWO HUNDRED FOUR
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
SCHOOL STUDENTS.
WHO AT ONE POINT DURING THE
SCHOOL YEAR MET THE FEDERAL
DEFINITION OF HOMELESSNESS
REPRESENTING ABOUT THREE AND A
HALF PERCENT?
OF THE TOTAL STUDENT POPULATION.
THIS IS A 21% INCREASE OVER THE
200-042-00015 SCHOOL YEAR WHEN
THEIR WORKS ONE HUNDRED SIXTY
EIGHT THOUSAND STUDENTS
IDENTIFIED.
AB SIXTEEN WOULD PROVIDE
RESOURCES TO BUILD CAPACITY AT
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO BETTER HELP
DISTRICTS IDENTIFY STUDENTS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
ENSURE THAT THESE STUDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES ARE RECEIVING THE
APPROPRIATE SERVICES.
THE BILL WOULD PROVIDE RESOURCES
TO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF OUR
HOMELESS -- HOMELESS
COORDINATORS AND WE'LL FIND
THREE COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
TO DEVELOP THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE CENTERS ACROSS THE
STATE.
ARE HOMELESS COORDINATORS HELP
IMPLEMENT THE MCKINNEY VENTO
HOMELESS ASSISTANCE ACT WHICH
REQUIRES ALL DISTRICTS TO ENSURE
THAT A HOMELESS CHILD.
OR YOUTH HAS ACCESS TO PUBLIC
EDUCATION INCLUDING PUBLIC
PRESCHOOL EDUCATION.
THE FEDERAL MCKINNEY VENTO
PROGRAM REQUIRES THAT THE
STATE'S AWARD FUNDS TO ELEAZAR
ON A COMPETITIVE BASIS OUR DATA
INDICATES THAT TWO TOUSAND
SIXTEEN ONLY -- SIXTY ONE OF THE
ONE THOUSAND SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
THE STATE RECEIVED SUPPORT FROM
THIS PROGRAM OR ROUGHLY 6% OF
ELEAZAR IN THE STATE.
BY INCREASING RESOURCES TO THE
DEPARTMENT IT WILL DRASTICALLY
IMPROVE ITS ABILITY TO ASSIST
DISTRICTS SPECIFICALLY THE
DEPARTMENT PLANS TO FIND THREE
ADDITIONAL STATE COORDINATORS TO
MONITOR AND ASSIST ALL.
THIRTEEN HUNDRED DISTRICT
HOMELESS STUDENT LATE LIAISONS.
ESTABLISHED THREE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE CENTERS ACROSS THE
STATE TO SUPPORT DISTRICTS
FOSTER RELATIONSHIPS WITH
COMMUNITY PARTNERS AND OTHER
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
PROVIDE TARGETED TA TO DISTRICTS
THAT ARE STRUGGLING AND
INCREASED TRAINING AND SUPPORT
FOR DISTRICTS THAT HAVE
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF HOMELESS
STUDENTS.
AB SIXTEEN WILL ENSURE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS THE RESOURCES
NEEDED TO ASSIST DISTRICTS AND
IDENTIFY HOMELESS STUDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES AND ENSURE THAT
THESE FAMILIES ARE RECEIVING ALL
THE APPROPRIATE SERVICES.
AND WITH THAT WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SB PEDIATRICS AND SUPPORT BUT TO
MAKE SURE THAT MIKE IS ON LYDIA
BORN REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS IN SUPPORT.
THREE GARAGE WHAT THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT.
RESIDENTS HALLS WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
RON RAPIDLY AFTER THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION TEACHERS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION SEEN
OPPOSITION ANY COMMENTS READY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEE NO COMMENTS TO EMOTION.
BILLS AND MOVED ALL SECOND --
THE MOTION IS -- DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS YOU
MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHEN MEMBERS I
DO WANT TO CLARIFY THAT -- THIS
BILL WILL ESTABLISH THREE
ADDITIONAL HOMELESS COORDINATORS
FOR A TOTAL OF FOUR AT C. D. E. --
I THINK THERE MAY HAVE BEEN AN
ERROR IN THE AMENDMENT LANGUAGE
BUT IF WE CAN CHECK THAT BUT THE
INTENT IS FOR FOR FOR FOR TO
HOLD THREE ADDITIONAL OR TOTAL.
FOUR DOES INTENDED THERE WHEN WE
DO THIS IF THERE IS SOME IF
THERE IS SOME.
YES THERE ARE MORE THAN MEMBERS
WE OFTEN WELL OKAY HEARING IT
NOW OKAY GREAT THANK YOU -- I
TELL THE TRUTH.
OKAY THANK YOU -- FOR HEARING
THIS BILL AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE THANK YOU.
A PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL AYE
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KALRA MCCARTY SMITH SMITH I
WEBER.
THE BILL HAS TO VOTE IT IS ON
CALL WE'RE NOT GONNA MOVED A
FILE ITEM EVERY FIFTEEN BY MISS
BURKE.
IF TEAM.
AND IT IS.
AB 855-585-2852.
YOU MAY RECEIVE ALREADY I THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS AND WE
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR AND YOUR STAFF.
FOR THE WORK YOU'VE DONE ON THIS
BILL ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT FIFTY
TWO IS SPONSORED BY THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION AUTHORIZES THE
SUPERINTENDENT AND INSTRUCTIONAL
QUALITY COMMISSION. TO REVIEW
CONTENT STANDARDS AND GIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION ON UPDATES TO
THOSE STANDARDS SHOULD UPDATES
BE NECESSARY.
CONTENTS CONTENT STANDARDS
DIRECT THE CONSTRUCTION OF
CURRICULUM FRAMEWORKS AND
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIAL THAT
TEACHES THE TEACHERS USE IN THE
CLASSROOM ON ANY GIVEN SUBJECT
MATTER HOWEVER IN THE PAST
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL HAS STATED
THAT THE S. B. E. DOES NOT HAVE
THE AUTHORITY. TO CHANGE
ACADEMIC CONTENT STANDARDS
FOLLOWING THEIR ADOPTION AND TO
DO SO REQUIRES AN ACT OF
LEGISLATION -- BY ESTABLISHING A
PURSE PROCESS FOR THE PERIODIC
REVIEW AND UPDATING OF STATE
CONTENT SANDERS AB EIGHT FIFTY
TWO INTEREST CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
ARE BETTER PREPARED.
FOR LIFE BEYOND KHI THROUGH
TWELVE EDUCATION AND OUR PRINT
PRESENT WITH THE MOST RELEVANT
INFORMATION WHEN LEARNING A
SUBJECT WITH THAT AND I'LL MOVE
TO MIGHT WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AGAIN MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AND COMMITTEE STAFF TO
LINK WITH US WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION ON
BEHALF OF THIS THE
SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION AND SPONSOR OF AB
FIFTY TWO IN SUPPORT -- YOU KNOW
THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION IS
ADOPTED ACADEMIC CONTENT
STANDARD IN A VARIETY OF SUBJECT
AREAS INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED.
TO ENGLISH LANGUAGE ARTS
MATHEMATICS SCIENCE VISUAL
PERFORMING ARTS PHYSICAL
EDUCATION AND CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION.
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TEN THE
STATE ADOPTED A NEW ACADEMIC
CONTENT STANDARDS AND CERTAIN
SUBJECT AREAS THAT INCLUDE
COMMON CORE STATE STANDARDS IN
COMPUTER SCIENCE.
AND THE NEXT GENERATION SCIENCE
STANDARDS.
HOWEVER THERE ARE OTHER CONTENT
AREAS IN WHICH STANDARDS HAVE
NOT BEEN UPDATED IN OVER TWENTY
YEARS.
I THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY THAT
THE LAST TWENTY YEARS OUR WORLD
IS CHANGED.
NEW LAWS HAVE BEEN ENACTED THE
IMPACT IN THE CONTENT BEING
TAUGHT IN OUR SCHOOLS.
AND A WHOLE NEW GENERATION OF
TEACHERS AND STUDENTS HAVE
ENTERED INTO A CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION SYSTEM.
HOWEVER THERE IS CURRENTLY NO
PROCESS IN PLACE TO REGULARLY UP
THE EXISTING ACADEMIC CONTENT
STANDARDS EXCEPT THE LEGISLATION
THAT AUTHORIZES THE DEPARTMENT
TO DO SO ON A SUBJECT BY SUBJECT
BASIS.
GIVEN HOW QUICKLY OUR SOCIETY
AND TECHNOLOGY ARE CHANGING IT
IS IMPERATIVE THAT OUR STATE
STANDARDS KEEP UP [inaudible]
I PROCESS. FOR REGULARLY
UPDATING THE STANDARD SHOULD BE
DOES -- DESIGNATED OR DESIGNED
TO EMPHASIZE PUBLIC ACCESS AND
ENGAGEMENT A RELIANCE ON
SCHOLARSHIP AND CURRENT AND
CONFIRMED RESEARCH ALIGNMENT TO
CURRENT STATUTE.
AND THE MINIMAL DESTRUCTION TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS USING CURRICULA
AND ASSESSMENTS BASED ON THOSE
STANDARDS.
THE CALIFORNIA EDUCATION SYSTEM
IS BETTER SERVED BY STANDARDS
THAT REFLECT THE CURRENT LAWS.
MEET THE NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITY
INCLUDING BUSINESS AND HIGHER
EDUCATION AND ENABLE TEACHERS
AND STUDENTS TO PLACE THE
CONTENT INTO CONTEXT.
THE STANDARDS ARE THE WHAT IN
EDUCATION WHAT STUDENTS SHOULD
KNOW AND BE ABLE TO DO BY THE
END OF THE YEAR OR IN IN ANY
PARTICULAR CONTENT AREA.
CALIFORNIA PROVIDES GUIDANCE TO
TEACHERS ADMINISTRATORS AND
PARENTS TO THE CURRICULUM
FRAMEWORKS THEY GIVE EXAMPLES OF
HOW THOSE STANDARDS MAY BE
TAUGHT.
WHEN THE STANDARDS ARE NOT
CURRENT THE FRAMEWORK MUST
PROVIDE INFORMATION AND GUIDANCE
THAT WHILE REFLECTING CURRENT
STATUTES?
MAY NOT REFLECT OLD STANDARDS.
TO KEEP IT SHORT BECAUSE I KNOW
WE HAVE A LONG LIST OF BILLS TO
STILL GO THROUGH.
I WOULD SUMMARIZE YOU GOT IT IN
THE DISPARITY IN THE CURRENT LAW
IS AN OLDER STANDARDS HAS CAUSED
CONFUSION FOR TEACHERS.
AND ARE WORKING HARD EVERY DAY
TO ENSURE CHILDREN HAVE ACCESS
TO THE MOST CURRENT INFORMATION
AND SCHOLARSHIP -- I DO HAVE
WITH ME TODAY ARE DIRECTOR OF
OUR CURRICULUM FRAMEWORKS
INSTRUCTIONAL RESOURCES DIVISION
DR STEPHANIE GRACE IS TO HELP
AND ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
ISABEL GARCIA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WE DON'T HAVE A FARM POSITION
YET BUT WE'RE TO WE'RE GONNA
TAKE WANTED THIS WEEKEND AT
STATE COUNCIL SO WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO PASS THE BILL.
THANK YOU -- ANY COMMON FOR MANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- SEEING NO.
MANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS YOU MAY CLOSE
RESPECT THEIR CUTS NAY VOTE.
DO WE NEED A MOTION WE DO THOSE
MOVED IN ALL SECOND PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY KALRA.
KALRA I'D MCCARTY SMITH SMITH I
WEBER.
THE BILL HAS THREE VOTES IT IS
ON CALL.
WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
MISTER MAIENSCHEIN.
HE'S GOING TO BRING A TAKE OF AB
SIX OH FIVE THAT'S FILE NUMBER.
ELEVEN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I WILL BEGIN WANT TO
BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS AS PROPOSED IN THE
ANALYSIS -- AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
SB SIX OH FIVE INSURERS THAT A
STUDENT AND REQUIRES AN
ASSISTIVE TECHNOLOGY DEVICE.
HAS THE RIGHT TO USE THAT DEVICE
OUTSIDE OF SCHOOL HOURS OF
DETERMINE NECESSARY BY THEIR I
EP.
THESE DEVICES ARE IMPORTANT
TOOLS TO HELP STUDENTS WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS COMMUNICATE LEARN
INTERACT WITH THEIR ENVIRONMENT.
HERE WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SHARON PRIMER FROM
EMPOWER FAMILIES CALIFORNIA AND
CHRISTY SUPPORT THAT APPROACH IT
FROM EDUCATE ADVOCATE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
OF THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE I AM
CHRISTIE'S OF OVER THE BRIDGE IT.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF EDUCATE
ADVOCATE.
EDUCATE ADVOCATE SERVICE
FAMILIES THAT HAVE CHILDREN WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS.
SHANNON AND I ARE MOTHERS OF
CHILDREN WHO HAVE SPECIAL NEEDS
AND BOTH OF OUR SONS USE
COMMUNICATION DEVICES TO
COMMUNICATE.
WE BECAME AWARE OF AN ISSUE THAT
MANY OF OUR FAMILIES ARE FACING
AROUND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THAT THEIR CHILDREN WERE NOT
ALLOWED TO TAKE HOME FROM SCHOOL
THEIR COMMUNICATION DEVICE.
THIS AND IN SOME CASES WITH
AFTER SCHOOL IN GENERAL OR
SOMETIMES ON SCHOOL BREAKS AND
HOLIDAYS.
MY SON SPEECH THERAPIST AT
SCHOOLS THAT IT PASSED HER QUOTE
IS WHAT IF YOU DISCOVERED YOUR
CHILD IS ABLE TO COMMUNICATE IN
FRENCH.
WOULD YOU IMMEDIATELY INVEST IN
A FRENCH TUTOR CLASSES OR RESENT
US DOWN OF COURSE YOU WOULD.
IN THE SAME WAY ALL PARENTS AND
FAMILIES WANT AND SHOULD BE
ENCOURAGED TO BECOME PROFICIENT
IN OUR CHILDREN'S LANGUAGE.
WHICH IN THE CASE OF CHILDREN
WHO USE COMMUNICATION DEVICES
THIS IS THEIR LANGUAGE.
PARENTS AND FAMILIES ARE UNABLE
TO BECOME PROFICIENT IN THEIR
CHILDREN'S LANGUAGE IF THEIR
CHILD IS AN ABLE TO BRING THEIR
DEVICE HOME AFTER SCHOOL OR ON
BREAKS AND HOLIDAYS.
WE'VE SENT A FEW VIDEO CLIPS
DEMONSTRATING THE IMPORTANCE OF
USING COMMUNICATION DEVICE AT
HOME AND IN THE COMMUNITY AND WE
HOPE IT IMPRESSES UPON YOU THE
VALUE AND IMPORTANCE OF A
STUDENT HAVING CONTINUED ACCESS
TO THEIR COMMUNICATION DEVICE.
THANK YOU AND WE ASK FOR YOUR
I'VE LOW VOTE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
IMPORTANT BILL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIMPLY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE FOR HAVING US MY NAME
IS SHANNON PRIMER.
I AM A MEMBER OF THE EMPOWER
FAMILY CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE A GROUP OF ORGANIZATIONS
AND MEMBERS -- ADVOCATING
EDUCATING -- AND LOBBYING FOR
FAMILIES OF CALIFORNIA I'M ALSO
AN EDUCATIONAL PARALEGAL
REPRESENTING FAMILIES OF
STUDENTS WITH VARIOUS
DISABILITIES.
AS A PARALEGAL WE FIGHT TO GET
STUDENTS VARIOUS TYPES OF
ASSISTIVE TECHNOLOGY ONE SUCH
DEVICE IS A COMMUNICATION DEVICE.
MANY DISTRICTS DO NOT ALLOW
STUDENTS TO TAKE.
THE THEM HOME EVERY DAY THE
FAMILIES I WORK FOR ALL WORKING
TOWARDS INDEPENDENCE FOR THEIR
STUDENTS WHEN OUR STUDENTS ARE
DENIED THEIR VOICES THEY LOSE
THAT OPPORTUNITY TO WORK TOWARDS
INDEPENDENCE WE WANT TO EMPOWER
ALL STUDENTS TO BE TAXPAYERS.
ENABLING THEM TO ACCESS THEIR
ENVIRONMENT MAKES THEM HAVE A
GREATER CHANCE TO ACHIEVE
INDEPENDENCE WHEN A STUDENT
LEAVES A DISTRICT OR AGENTS OUT
OF A PROGRAM.
THIS DOES NOT PRECLUDE THEIR
NEED FOR A VOICE.
WHICH IS WHY IT'S IMPORTANT TO
GIVE FAMILIES A FEW MONTHS TO
FIND A GENERIC RESOURCE TO GET
COMMUNICATION DEVICES REPLACED
WE RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR HELP
TO PROVIDE THAT ACT THAT ACCESS.
TO OUR STUDENTS WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS REQUIRING TECHNOLOGY AND
COMMUNICATION DEVICES TO HELP
THEM ACHIEVE INDEPENDENCE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I AM
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
THIS IS SYLVIA REESE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF THE BLIND IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME'S JOHN NOLTE I'M WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
PARENT CHILD ADVOCACY AND ONE
STRONG SUPPORT.
WHERE IS THE GONZALEZ WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT?
JIMMY FROM AGAIN DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHERS IN OPPOSITE
ANY IN ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO OPPOSITION WILL ROUTE
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE --
DO EMOTION BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED -- ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS REALLY COMMITTEE
MEMBER SINGLE QUESTIONS -- THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS YOU MAY CLOSE
MISTER MENTION.
THE SECOND QUESTION ABOUT.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY KALRA.
I MCCARTY SMITH SMITH I WEBER.
THE BILL HAS THREE VOTES SO IT
IS ON CALL IT NEEDS A TOTAL OF
FOUR VOTES BUT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR YOUR PARTICIPATION OF
PRESENTATIONS GOOD JOB --
WITHOUT WILL GO TO THE MISC IS
MISS QUIRK SILVA HERE.
LET'S GO AROUND HER IF SHE'S NOT
THIS YEAR SHE'S TALKING AND WE
WERE WORKING SO.
MISS QUIRK SILVA HAS -- TWO
BILLS WHICH ONE DO YOU PREFER TO
DO FIRST ALL WE WILL START WITH
EIGHTY NINE FOUR SEVEN AB NINE
FOUR SEVEN WHICH IS FILE ITEM.
SEVENTEEN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND I KNOW
IT'S BEEN A LONG AFTERNOON SO I
USUALLY THE PROCESS PATIENTS
WITH PEOPLE THAT'S RIGHT.
AND PATIENCE IS A VIRTUE.
BUT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM HAPPY TO PRESENT
TODAY AB NINE FORTY SEVEN WHICH
ENSURES THAT EVERY STUDENT TO IS
MORE WIND OR HAS LOW VISION OR
WHO IS VISUALLY IMPAIRED
RECEIVES INSTRUCTION.
THAT IS SUITABLE TO THEIR
SPECIFIC NEEDS THE EXPANDED CORE
CURRICULUM OR ECC.
IS A STANDARD ON ONLY TO
ACCOMMODATE HARDSHIP.
BUT PROMOTE A STUDENTS FULL
POTENTIAL.
THIS INCLUDES SKILLS AND
FACULTIES LIKE BRAILLE
ORIENTATION AND MOBILITY
ASSISTIVE TECHNOLOGY AND OTHERS
TO FOSTER INDEPENDENT LIVING AND
SELF DETERMINATION.
AS A FORMER TEACHER I RECOGNIZE
THE NEED FOR THERE TO BE NO
UNCERTAIN.
TERMS WHEN STUDENTS REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL RESEARCH RESOURCES
AND CONSIDERATION TO SUCCEED.
THAT VISUAL IMPAIRMENTS FALL
INTO THIS CATEGORY IS OBVIOUS
WHAT IS NOT ALWAYS OBVIOUS OR
THE FULL SCOPE OF REDRESSING
EDUCATIONAL NEEDS ENTERTAINMENT.
I HAVE SOME WITNESSES HERE AND
WOULD LIKE TO ASK THEM TO DO
THEIR PRESENTATION [inaudible]
THE USER [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JEFF THOMAS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
LINE.
I WILL ADDRESS THE FIRST OF THE
TWO OF BILLS MAJOR COMPONENTS.
AND THAT IS AS AMENDED THE BILL
WILL ADD A DEFINITION OF THE
EXPANDED CORE CURRICULUM TO THE
EDUCATION CODE -- EXPANDED CORE
CURRICULUM HAS TWO COMMON
THREADS IN A MINUTE I WILL
DISCUSS SOME OF THE SPECIFIC
SERVICES.
BUT THE TWO COMMONALITIES OF
THESE SKILL SETS ARE THAT.
ONE THEY ARE SKILLS THAT ARE
IMPORTANT IF NOT ESSENTIAL TO
LIVE IS PRODUCTIVE INDEPENDENT
ADULTS AND TWO THEY ARE
PRIMARILY LEARNED BY SIGHTED
CHILDREN.
THROUGH VISUAL OBSERVATION OF
THEIR PEERS OR OTHER ADULTS AND
THEREFORE THE NEED TO LEARN THE
SKILLS OF US ARE BLIND CHILDREN
NEED TO LEARN THE SKILLS AND THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION.
SEVEN AND LET ME GO THROUGH JUST
A FEW OF THESE SKILLS FOR YOU.
ORIENTATION AND MOBILITY WHICH
YOU'LL HEAR MORE ABOUT A MINUTE.
COMPENSATORY ACADEMIC SKILLS
SUCH AS CONCEPT DEVELOPMENT
LEARNING TO USE BRAILLE AND
LARGE PRINT AND OTHERS THAT ARE
ESSENTIAL TO ACCESS THE CORE
CURRICULUM IN THE CLASSROOM.
SOCIAL INTERACTION SKILLS TO
AVOID THE ISOLATION BUT COMES
WITH.
NOT KNOWING HOW THE WORLD WORKS
SOCIALLY SUCH AS LEARNING TO
FACE YOUR AUDIENCE LEARNING --
TO NOT INVADE OTHERS PERSONAL
SPACE AND OF COURSE AS KIDS GET
OLDER THE INCREDIBLE WORLD OF
SOCIAL TEENAGER.
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION -- WE
HAD A REFERENCE TO THAT EARLIER
HOW DOES A KISS YOUR WORK WHAT
DO THEY DO WHAT IS A BANK TELLER
DO ALL THESE DIFFERENT THINGS.
TO GET AN IDEA OF WHERE YOU
MIGHT FIT IN THE WORLD OF ADULT
OCCUPATIONS.
A TECHNOLOGY INCLUDING SMART
PHONES COMPUTERS AND LOW VISION
AIDS INDEPENDENT LIVING SKILLS
SUCH AS MONEY MANAGEMENT HIGH G.
APPROPRIATE METHODS OF DRESSING
EXCEPT.
FOR RECREATION AND LEISURE AND
OTHERS.
HAVING THESE SKILLS IN THE
EDUCATION CODE ALBEIT NOT
REQUIRING THEM TO BE CONSIDERED
IN THE I EP WILL STILL GO A LONG
WAY.
TOWARD ENCOURAGING SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO MAKE SURE THAT ARE
BLIND AND VISUALLY IMPAIRED
CHILDREN GET THE SERVICES THEY
NEED WE THANK -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SO BEFORE OFFERING THE BILL AND
WE HOPE THE COMMITTEE WILL
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU MISTER TOM.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR SONYA VIXEN
I'M A CERT ORIENTATION MOBILITY
SPECIALIST AS WELL AS A TEACHER
OF THE BLIND AND VISUALLY
IMPAIRED.
I'VE BEEN TEACHING FOR THIRTY
FOUR YEARS I AM ALSO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ORIENTATION OR VILLAGE
SPECIALIST.
AND A PARENT OF A SUCCESSFUL
TWENTY SEVEN YEAR OLD BLIND --
SON WHO IS A WORLD TRAVELER WHO
RECEIVED IMPORTANT ORIENTATION
MOBILITY SERVICES IN SCHOOL.
HE WOULDN'T BE A WORLD TRAVELER
IF YOU DIDN'T.
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AB.
NINE FORTY SEVEN AS A
PROFESSIONAL WHO PROVIDES
INDEPENDENT EVALUATIONS AND
SERVICES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
I'VE WITNESSED CASES.
WHERE MY COLLEAGUES HAVE BEEN
TOLD THAT THEY CANNOT PERFORM
KEY COMPONENTS OF THEIR JOBS AS
ORIENTATION AND MOBILITY
SPECIALIST?
THEY HAVE BEEN TOLD THERE
DISTRICTS DO NOT PROVIDE
SERVICES IN THE HOME OR
COMMUNITY.
EVEN THOUGH THE STATE'S PLAINLY
AN IDEA TWO THOUSAND FOUR THAT
ORIENTATION AND MOBILITY
SERVICES ARE.
TO BE PROVIDED IN THE HOME
SCHOOLING COMMUNITY.
WHEN I HAVE QUESTION THEM AS TO
WHY THEY ARE NOT UPHOLDING THE
IDEA TWO THOUSAND FOUR LAW?
I WAS TOLD THAT IT IS THE
DISTRICT POLICY NOT TO PROVIDE
THOSE SERVICES.
I WAS APPALLED THAT A SCHOOL
DISTRICT WOULD WILLINGLY
DISREGARD IDEA.
TWO THOUSAND FOUR AND HINDER THE
ONEM SPECIALIST FROM DOING THEIR
JOB.
OTHER COLLEAGUES HAD TOLD ME
PERSONALLY THAT THERE DISTRICTS
OF SAID THEY CANNOT PROVIDE
SERVICES OFF CAMPUS.
WILL NOT PROVIDE TRANSPORTATION
TO DESTINATIONS FOR LEARNING ST
TRAVELER LIGHTED CROSSINGS.
IN BUSINESS AREAS OR ALLOW THEM
TO TEACH PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
SKILLS.
NOT ONLY ARE THEY OWN AND
PROVIDERS NOT ABLE TO PERFORM
THE BASIC FUNCTIONS OF THEIR JOB
DESCRIPTIONS.
BUT THE STUDENTS THEY SERVE
SUFFER GREATLY IN NOT LEARNING
THOSE IMPORTANT SKILLS.
AND WHEN THE STUDENTS ARE READY
FOR TRANSITION INTO COLLEGE OUR
CAREERS.
THEY'RE NOT ADEQUATELY PREPARED.
AB NINE FORTY SEVEN WILL SOLVE
THE PROBLEM OF DISTRICTS AND
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION
IMPOSING THESE TYPES OF
RESTRICTIONS.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN HAVING A
COMMITMENT TO OUR BE AYE KIDS
AND ARE TEACHING PROFESSION.
PLEASE SUPPORT AB NINE FORTY
SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WILL NEXT GO TO THE
PUBLIC -- MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN SUPPORT I'M GONNA HAND OFF
THE THE GAVEL TO MISS SMITH HERE
FROM ALL I STEP OUT OF IN.
THE COMMITTEE ROOM BUT MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IT WHICH WHICH TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL A STEP FORWARD
AND SPEAK.
SYLVIA REESE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
OF THE BLIND IN SUPPORT.
TING SU PROFESSOR THE TEACHER
PREPARATION PROGRAM VISUAL
IMPAIRMENTS AT SAN FRANCISCO
STATE UNIVERSITY IN SUPPORT.
SANDRA RECKLESS ORIENTATION
MOBILITY SPECIALISTS IN SUPPORT.
SHARON SACKS RETIRED
SUPERINTENDENT CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
FOR THE BLIND AND PART TIME
FACULTY SAN FRANCISCO STATE
UNIVERSITY IN SUPPORT.
SANDERS STAPLES REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ORIENTATION ABILITY SPECIALIST
AND AN ORIENTATION MOBILITY
SPECIALIST IN SUPPORT.
SHANNON DILLON NATIONAL
FEDERATION OF THE BLIND OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON RICHARD RATHER
NEVER THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
THE BLIND AND THEN THE PORT.
EVAN POST IN MY BROTHER IS
LEGALLY BLIND IN SUPPORT.
J. SUPERMAN PRESIDENT ELECT OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF ORIENTATION MOBILITY
SPECIALISTS CERTIFIED
ORIENTATION MOBILITY SPECIALIST
CERTIFICATED TEACHER IN
ORIENTATION MOBILITY SUPPORT. TO
THE LISTENER FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR PARENTS OF
CHILDREN WITH VISUAL IMPAIRMENTS
IN SUPPORT.
FRANCIS DOUBLE RETIRED TEACHER
AND ADMINISTRATOR WITH THE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL FOR THE BLIND CURRENTLY
WORKING AT THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
FOR THE BLIND IN LECTURE AT SAN
FRANCISCO STATE.
LEASING AS AMANDA ORIENTATION
MOBILITY SPECIALIST IN SUPPORT.
NANCY MICHENER CERTIFIED
ORIENTATION AND MOBILITY
SPECIALIST AND SUPPORT.
BRIT REAL ORIENTATION MOBILITY
SPECIALIST IN SUPPORT.
DO YOU KNOW ALL THAT
SUPERINTENDENT AT THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL FOR THE BLIND IN SUPPORT.
SERRA BLAIR WORKING IN THE ROLE
OF TEACHER OF STUDENTS WITH
VISUAL IMPAIRMENTS AT SAN RAMON
VALLEY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT.
DEVIN UPS AN ORIENTATION AND
MOBILITY SPECIALIST AT SAN RAMON
VALLEY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND STRONG STRONG SUPPORT.
NEED ELIANE ORIENTATION AND
MOBILITY SPECIALIST AT SAN RAMON
VALLEY UNIFIED AND THEN STRONG
SUPPORT.
DIANA JOHN TEACHER FOR STUDENTS
WITH VISUAL IMPAIRMENTS FROM
CEREMONY BELL UNIFIED IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
ON EARLY SUMMER OKEH FROM CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
TEACHER OF THE VISUALLY IMPAIRED
AN ORIENTATION MOBILITY
SPECIALIST IN STRONG SUPPORT.
EMILY GRIFFITH ORIENTATION AND
MOBILITY SPECIALIST WITH CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
AND TRANSPORT.
JIMMY FROM IN DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
POR RASKIN LONGTIME ON AND
INSTRUCTOR IN SUPPORT.
CHARLES YOU TEACHER OF THE
VISUALLY IMPAIRED INTERN IN
SUPPORT.
ISABEL GARCIA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WE DON'T HAVE A FORMAL POSITION
BUT OUR SPECIAL EDUCATION
COMMITTEES GOING TO REVIEW THIS
WITH THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS BUT
WE WANT TO THANK YOU FOR WORKING
WITH US.
AND WE URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
PASS THE BILL.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY HEARING -- NINE BACK TO THE
AUTHOR MISS QUIRK SILVA COULD WE
CLARIFY PLEASE IF YOU'RE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS.
I AM IN THANK YOU FOR WORKING
WITH US ALSO THANK YOU TO ALL OF
THE WITNESSES THAT CAME UP I
KNOW IT'S BEEN A LONG AFTERNOON
BUT WE DEFINITELY.
SUPPORT -- I DID NOT SHARE AT
THE BEGINNING THAT I TOO HAVE A
NIECE WHO IS BEEN A WHO IS BLIND
WHO'S BEEN BLIND SINCE -- TWO
THE AGE OF TWO AND MATTER OF
FACT SHE'S ACTUALLY GOING TO A
SURGERY RIGHT NOW BECAUSE OF
SEIZURES -- THAT SHE HAS BUT I
HAVE SEEN MY SISTER -- WORK
DILIGENTLY WITHIN THE SYSTEM TO
TRY TO ACCESS -- AS MANY TYPES
OF SUPPORT SERVICES AS POSSIBLE
AND ALTHOUGH THERE ARE MANY.
MANY TIMES IT'S THE ADVOCACY OF
THE PARENTS OR THEY CARE GIVERS
OR SUPPORT -- PERSON NOW THAT
REALLY HAVE US DO -- PUSHIN MAKE
EXTRA EFFORTS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE STUDENTS THAT WE HAVE -- GET
AS MUCH ACCESS TO SERVICES
POSSIBLE SO WITH THAT I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
ANY MEMBER QUESTIONS.
AND I'LL SECOND THE BILL THE
CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL.
KILEY.
KALRA.
KALRA FIVE MCCARTY SMITH.
SMITH I WEBER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND NOW MEMBER QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
IF WE COULD MOVE -- TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT YOUR A. B.
FOURTEEN TEN PLEASE.
YES THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE HERE.
NOW IT'S A VERY BUSY AFTERNOON --
I A WE WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS AND WE ALSO WANT TO
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR WORKING ON
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION WITH
US -- WE KNOW THAT WE'VE HAD
SOME -- BIG ASK THEM WHERE YOUR
YOUR PATIENCE HAS BEEN VERY
VALUED THANK YOU -- THIS BILL
WOULD CREATE THE COMPUTER
SCIENCE ACCESS INITIATIVE
DIRECTED AT IMPROVING QUALITY
AND QUANTITY OF COMPUTER SCIENCE
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
SCHOOLS.
AND JUST A LITTLE JUMP IN HERE
FROM OUT OF MY NOTES WHICH IS --
I HAVE BEEN A CLASSROOM TEACHER.
FOR CLOSE TO THIRTY YEARS AND
HAVE SEEN EVERYTHING FROM WHAT
WE USED TO CALL OF THE DUPLO
MACHINES AT WHAT WERE THOSE KIND
THAT YOU WOULD ROLL OUT DIDN'T
WRITE EVERYTHING BY HAND.
AND THEN OF COURSE WE WENT TO
COFFEES -- THAT NOW I CALL XEROX
OF MY KIDS MY OWN CHILDREN TELL
ME -- OUTDATED TO TECHNOLOGY BUT
AT OVER THE THREE DECADES OF
EDUCATION WE CERTAINLY HAVE SEEN
NOT ONLY HOW ARE YOUNG LEARNERS
ARE LEARNING DIFFERENTLY BUT
HELL TEACHERS HAVE -- HAD TO
EVOLVE OVER THOSE YEARS AND SO
AS WE START TO LOOK AT
TECHNOLOGY IS JUST.
PART OF WHAT WE DO ALL OF US
EVERY DAY LOOKING ARE AT OUR OWN
DEVICES UP.
TO I BELIEVE ABOUT TWO THOUSAND
TIMES A DAY IS WHAT I'VE HEARD
WITH OUR INDIVIDUAL DEVICES IF
YOU TRACKED THAT IT'S KIND OF
SCARY BUT WE ARE USING
TECHNOLOGY THROUGHOUT OUR DAY
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE.
THAT OUR COMPUTER SCIENCE --
KILL -- IS AS UP TO DATE IN AS
THOROUGH AS POSSIBLE SO THIS
WOULD PREPARE AND ENCOURAGE
STUDENTS AT AN EARLIER AGE TO
PURSUE -- NOT ONLY A COMPUTER
TECHNOLOGY BUT IT.
ADDITIONS THAT HAVEN'T BEEN
TYPICALLY TAUGHT IN OUR SCHOOLS --
MAKING SURE THAT WE GO BEYOND
DIGITAL LITERACY COMPUTER
SCIENCE EDUCATION WOULD PREPARE
THE NEXT GENERATION OF
CALIFORNIANS TO SUCCEED AND YET.
ALSO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE THE
COURSES AVAILABLE FOR THIS AB
FOURTEEN TEN WOULD GOVERN GROW
AWARDING GRANTS TO SUPPORT
TEACHERS IN ENTERTAINING A
COMPUTER SCIENCE AUTHORIZATION
IN THIS IS REALLY A KEY PART.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT MANY
TEACHERS HAVE EVOLVED IN
LEARNING TO USE TECHNOLOGY OR
HAVE GROWING UP WITH THAT BUT WE
HAVE NOT OFFERED A COMPUTER
SCIENCE AUTHORIZATION AND I KNOW
IN THE HIRING OF TEACHERS.
AND MORE AND MORE THESE ARE THE
TYPE OF SKILLS WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR TEACHERS HAVE BUT
IF THEY GO THE EXTRA STEP MIKE
WOULD HAVE TO SAY THAT WOULD BE
A VERY VALUABLE ASSET TO A
SCHOOL -- WE DO HAVE TWO
WITNESSES HERE AND LIKE TO ASK
THEM TO JOIN US.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON --
ALEXIS WHEN I GOT HERE AGAIN
AGAIN WITH CO DOT ORG AB JOBS
REQUIRING A BACKGROUND IN
COMPUTER SCIENCE ARE THE FASTEST
GROWING AMONG THE HIGHEST PAYING
YET ONLY 32% OF CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC HIGH SCHOOLS TEACH CS.
WITH RURAL LOW INCOME BLACK AND
LATINOS.
BEING THE LEAST LIKELY TO HAVE
COURSES AVAILABLE TO THEM THE
GREATEST BARRIERS SCHOOLS HAVE
TO OFFERING CS IS THE LACK OF
TEACHERS TRAINED TO TEACH IT.
AB FOURTEEN TEN WILL PREPARE
TEACHERS TO TEACH THE ASK WHAT
PRIORITIZING FUNDING TO AREAS
THAT DO NOT CURRENTLY OFFER
COMPUTER SCIENCE COURSES.
NOT EVERY STUDENT NEEDS TO BE A
COMPUTER PROGRAMMER HOWEVER ALL
STUDENTS WHO TO UNDERSTAND
TECHNOLOGY.
COMPUTER SCIENCE OPENS DOORS
THAT ALLOW STUDENTS TO HARNESS
THEIR CREATIVITY TO CREATE NEW
TECHNOLOGY. TO HOPEFULLY USE
THAT TECHNOLOGY FOR GOOD AND
IMPACTS SOCIAL CHANGE WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MEMBERS I'D COURTING JENSEN WITH
TECH MAN -- A LATE HOUR ALL TO
BE VERY QUICK AND SAY WE KNOW
STUDENT EXPOSURE TO COMPUTER
SCIENCE AT A YOUNG AGE IS
CRITICAL TO ADDRESS THE
DIVERSITY GAP.
IN COMPUTER SCIENCE FIELDS AND
PROVIDE THE WORK FORCE NEEDED
FOR CALIFORNIA AND THE NATION TO
REMAIN COMPETITIVE IN THE GLOBAL
ECONOMY.
OUR TEACHERS NEED MORE ACCESS TO
TRAINING SO MORE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS CAN OFFER COMPUTER
SCIENCE EDUCATION.
AB FOURTEEN TEN WILL ASSIST IN
THIS TRAINING WHILE PRIORITIZING
FUNDING FOR SCHOOLS THAT DO NOT
CURRENTLY OFFER COMPUTER SCIENCE
COURSES AND UNDERREPRESENTED
STUDENTS -- WE THINK THE AUTHOR
FOR THIS BILL IT'S A GREAT STEP
IN MOVING TOWARDS -- MAKING SURE
THEIR TEACHERS ARE WELL TRAINED --
IN COMPUTER SCIENCE -- AND WE'RE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST RIVALS.
THANK YOU MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN SUPPORT PLEASE.
RIVER NOW DIRECTOR OF EDUCATION
FOR THE CATHOLIC CHURCH WE ARE
IN SUPPORT.
SUSAN BERNIE I WAS READY NATION
I'M BUSINESS MEMBERSHIP AND ALSO
FOR MISSION READINESS RETIRED
MILITARY LEADERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
ISABEL GARCIA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
OUR CREDENTIALS COMMITTEES
LOOKING AT IT AT OUR STATE
CONSERVATION CATION MEETING AND
WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
CONCEPT AND URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO PASS THE BILL.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION.
GREAT SEEING NINE ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION.
RIGHT FANTASTIC HEARING NONE I
WILL TURN IT OVER TO COMMITTEE
MEMBER QUESTIONS.
AND I WILL SECOND THE BILL --
MISS QUIRK SILVA HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE -- JUST WE
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE TIENDA.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
THAT SAID WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND THE CLERK WILL CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL
KILEY KALRA.
KALRA I'D MCCARTY SMITH HI SMITH
I WEBER.
OKAY SO IT HAS TO VOTES ON CALL
THANK YOU.
AND NEXT WE'LL CALL PLEASE A
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER.
WHICHEVER YOUR PREFERENCES ARE
FOR FILE ITEMS NAY BY WITH FIVE
EIGHT OKAY WE'LL BE HEARING THEN
AB NUMBER TWO FIVE EIGHT THANK
YOU WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
FIRST SIR WILL ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS -- I'M HERE
TO PRESENT AB TWO FIVE EIGHT A
BILL THAT WE USE FUNDS FROM.
PROPOSITION SIXTY SIXTY FOUR
YEAR MARK FOR TREATMENT AND
PREVENTION THE FUN OF
SUSTAINABLE HEALTH AND MENTAL
HEALTH PROGRAMS THE BILL
ADDRESSES THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL SCHOOL SUPPORT
SERVICES.
THE GRANTS CREATED BY THIS BILL
WILL HELP FILL THE VOID AND A
NUMBER OF SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
STAFF.
ALLEVIATE THE WORKLOAD OF
ALREADY OVERWORKED TEACHERS AND
CONNECT SCHOOLS EXISTING
COMMUNITY REOURCES THE BILL IS
STRUCTURED SUCH THAT GRANTS WILL
LEVERAGE ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
RESOURCES SPECIFICALLY A 50%
FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENT FROM
MEDICARE OUT ADULT ELIGIBLE
SERVICES.
THE NEED FOR THIS BILL IS CLEAR
AS EVIDENCE IN A TEACHER STRIKES
WE HAVE BEEN THAT HAVE BEEN
ACROSS THE STATE.
EDUCATORS IN BOTH LOS ANGELES
AND OAKLAND MADE CLEAR THE NEED
FOR ADDITIONAL SUPPORT CURRENT
RATIOS OF SUPPORT STAFF ARE
TERRIBLE WITH ONE COUNSELOR FOR
EVERY SIX HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE
STUDENTS ONE NURSE. FOR EVERY
TWO THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
STUDENTS AND ONE SOCIAL WORKER
FOR EVERY NINE THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED STUDENTS OUR STUDENTS
ARE FACING STRESS.
AND TRAUMA AT UNPRECEDENTED
LEVELS WITHOUT SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES STAFF AND PROGRAMS ON
CAMPUS TO ATTENDEES NEEDS WE
CANNOT POSSIBLY EXPECT OUR
STUDENTS TO SUCCEED.
THIS BILL PROVIDES GRANTS THAT
ALLOW SCHOOLS TO MAKE THEIR OWN
DECISIONS ALWAYS.
BEST FIT THE NEEDS OF THEIR
STUDENTS FOR SOME THIS MAY MEAN
TRAUMA INFORMED CARE FOR OTHERS
TRAINING FIRST TEACHERS.
AND IN IDENTIFYING STUDENTS IN
NEED OF TREATMENT FOR OTHER
STILL THE CREATION OF A SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH CENTER MIGHT BE
MOST APPROPRIATE.
WHEN STUDENTS ARE PROVIDED WITH
THE SUPPORTIVE SERVICES STAFF
THAT THEY NEED WE SEE INCREASED
CLASSROOM ENGAGEMENT BETTER
ATTENDANCE AND IMPROVE STUDENT
SUCCESS?
THIS PROGRAM IS MODELED AFTER A
SOME REALLY SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM
IN COLORADO WHICH ALSO SAW
EFFECTIVE HEALTH PROGRAMS RESULT
IN BETTER.
PUPIL DISCIPLINE DATA AS WELL
WITH SUSPENSIONS AND EXPULSIONS
DECREASING AFTER IMPLEMENTATION
WE OWE IT TO OUR STUDENTS TO PUT
THEM IN THE BEST POSITION TO SAY
TO SUCCEED. FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
BOAT WITH ME TODAY TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IS SHERRY
COBURN PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA.
SCHOOL NURSES ASSOCIATION SOCAN
AND HELEN DOUBT AND FROM
TEACHERS FOR HEALTHY KIDS
[inaudible]
IN.
I'M HELEN ROCKED OUT IN TEACHERS
FOR HEALTHY KIDS YESTERDAY WE
HAD THE HEAD OF THE COLORADO
DEPARTMENT.
OF EDUCATION'S OFFICE OF HEALTH
AND WELLNESS HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THIS BILL IS -- THE AUTHOR
SAID IS MODELED AFTER THE
COLORADO PROGRAM.
LET ME TELL YOU WHAT'S HAPPENED
SINCE THEY PUT IT IN.
THEY'VE HIRED OVER AND THIS IS A
SMALL STATE WHERE THEY HAVE A
MILLION STUDENTS NOT LIKE OUR
STATE.
THEY'VE HIRED OVER -- TWO
HUNDRED NURSES IN THE STATE
SOCIAL WORKERS AND PSYCHOLOGISTS.
THERE LEGISLATOR THOUGHT IT WAS
SO SUCCESSFUL THAT THEY'VE
ACTUALLY KUDROW PULLED THE FUNDS
FOR IT FOR OVER THE LAST FOUR
YEARS BECAUSE OF WHAT'S COME OUT
OF IT -- WHAT THEY FOUND FOR
EXAMPLE IS BY HAVING A SCHOOL
NURSE OR A LICENSED PROFESSIONAL --
THE USER THERE CANNABIS
INITIATIVE FUNDS FOR THIS SO
USING THEIR CANNABIS INITIATIVE
FUNDS THEY HAD A SCHOOL
PROFESSIONAL THE COULD ASSESS
KIDS IN REFER THEM QUICKLY FOR
TREATMENT.
AND THEN WORK OUT PROGRAMS TO
DEAL WITH DRUG DIRECTLY WITH
OTHER STUDENTS PROBLEMS WERE
KIDS MIGHT GET INTO DRUGS BUT
THEY WEREN'T THERE YET.
AND THEY DELIVERED EVIDENCE
BASED PROGRAMS FOR THOSE KIDS
AND THEY HAD NOT SEEN THEIR RATE
OF DRUG USE.
INCREASE EVEN WITH THE PASSAGE
OF THEIR MARIJUANA INITIATIVE.
SO THE OTHER THING ABOUT THIS
BILL IS IT WILL PROVIDE FUNDS
THROUGH THE CANNABIS SHOULD
INITIATIVE WHICH WILL PROVIDE
THE FIFTY FIFTY MATCH. TO BRING
DOWN MEDI CAL FUNDS FOR THE
SCHOOL PROFESSIONALS WE NEED
THESE PROFESSIONALS IN THE
SCHOOLS THEIR CRITICAL TO LINK
TO SERVICES INTO TREATMENT.
AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE SUPPORTING
THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MY NAME IS
DOCTOR SHERRI COVER AND I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL NURSES ORGANIZATION.
WE ARE IN PROCESS SUPPORT OF
THIS AB -- TWO FIFTY SIX EIGHT
EXCUSE ME TO FIFTY EIGHT THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOINS SO
JONES SAWYER -- ASTHMA DIABETES
CANCER MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
DEPRESSION SUICIDE IDEATION
ANXIETY ORAL HEALTH LIFE
THREATENING ALLERGIES RATE CHILD
ABUSE.
IN CAPRICES MOLESTATION TEEN
PREGNANCY SUBSTANCE ABUSE SCHOOL
NURSES COUNSELLORS PSYCHOLOGISTS
AND SOCIAL WORKERS FACE THAT
EACH AND EVERY DAY AS CHILDREN
DO NOT LEAVE THEIR HEALTHCARE
ISSUES AT THE SCHOOL'S FRONT
DOOR.
WE KNOW THAT CHILDREN COME EVERY
DAY -- FACE WITH ADVERSE
CONDITIONS AND WE'RE HERE TO
SUPPORT OUR CHILDREN -- THIS
WOULD IMPLEMENT A MULTI TIERED
SERVICES AS WELL AS RECRUIT AND
RETAIN SCHOOL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS PROVIDE NECESSARY
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH SERVICES.
PRESENTLY SO CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS
DO NOT MEET THE RATIO SHE TALKED
ABOUT WHEN THERE'S FOR EVERY.
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS AS
A MAN TAKE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT NURSE I HAVE. ONE TO
EVERY FIVE THOUSAND STUDENTS --
WHEN I WAS PRACTICING SCHOOL
NURSING -- THIS PROGRAM WILL BE
MULTI PRONGED APPROACH PROVIDE
NECESSARY SCHOOL SERVICES BY
CREDENTIALED SUPPORT PERSONNEL
CANCERS SCHOOL NURSES SOCIAL
WORKERS IN SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGIST.
STUDENT SUCCESS IS SIMPLY MORE
THAN ACADEMIC INSTRUCTION OF
PERFORMANCE WE KNOW THAT THERE
HAVE BEEN INCREASING NUMBERS OF
STUDENTS COME TO SCHOOL WITH A
MYRIAD OF PROBLEMS.
RESEARCHERS DOCUMENTED OVER
AGAIN THAT ADEQUATE NUMBERS OF
SCHOOL HELPER PERSONNEL CAN WORK
COLLABORATIVELY WITH TEACHERS TO
WRITE SAFE SUPPORTIVE AND
LEARNING ENVIRONMENTS.
WE NEED TO SUPPORT THE WHOLE
CHILD THE PHYSICAL BEHAVIORAL
AND SOCIAL WELL BEING -- AT IN
TWO THOUSAND THREE A STUDY.
AND REPORT A FEW BILL PERSONAL
RATIOS AND SERVICES CAN -- IT
WAS STATED BY THEN FORMER STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION JACK O'CONNELL THAT
PEOPLE SERVICES SPECIALIST
PROVIDE CRUCIAL SUPPORT TO OUR
STUDENTS -- WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON AB.
TWO FIFTY EIGHT THANK YOU OTHERS
IN SUPPORT.
GIRL ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION A PROUD CO
SPONSOR THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING WE ENTER THE READ
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL COUNSELORS
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
WHERE SECONDS ALSO ME UP OF
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS AND STRUCK SUPPORT?
THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION.
SING OPPOSITION ANY.
ANY COMMITTEE COMMON.
SEE NO CLICK ON THE BILL'S BEEN
MOVED BY MY MISTER KALRA AND
SECOND MY MISS SMITH -- THE
MOTION IS -- IS TO PASS TO
HEALTH THEIR MEMBERS WILL BE
TAKEN IN THE HEALTH COMMITTEE.
THE OTHERS AGREED THAT YOU MAY
CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DO PASSED TO HELP WITH
AMENDMENTS TO BE TAKEN IN HEALTH.
O'DONNELL HI O'DONNELL AYE KILEY
KALRA.
KALRA I'D MCCARTY SMITH SMITH I
WEBER.
THE BILL HAS THREE VOTED IS ON
CALL THANK YOU GIVEN THAT WILL
GO TO MISTER NAZARIAN WHICH IS
FILE ITEMS ON YOUR NICE TO I
APOLOGIZE YOU.
TO WHEN WE DON'T KNOW
[inaudible]
BUSY DAY.
FILE ITEM [inaudible]
TWENTY FOUR AB. TWELVE EIGHTEEN
TWELVE NINETEEN MAY [inaudible]
EVENTUALLY.
OUR FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO START
BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
AMENDMENT -- AB TWELVE NINETEEN
WILL REQUIRE THAT ALL PUBLIC
SCHOOLS MONITOR TEACHER MISS
ASSIGNMENTS ANNUALLY AND THE TWO
THOUSAND FOR HIS STORE CIVIL
RIGHTS.
VICTORY WILLIAM FIRST A
CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT FOUND THAT CERTAIN
FACTORS AMONG THEM QUALIFY
TEACHERS ARE FUNDAMENTAL TO
ENSURE A STUDENT SUCCESS.
AS A RESULT OF THE WILLIAM
SETTLEMENT THE COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING BECAME.
RESPONSIBLE FOR ENSURING THAT
TEACHERS HAVE THE APPROPRIATE
CREDENTIALS FOR THE COURSES THEY
ARE TEACHING.
HOWEVER ONLY THE LOWEST
PERFORMING SCHOOLS UNDER THE
ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE INDEX KPI
WERE REQUIRED TO BE MONITORED
FOR TEACHER MISSED ASSIGNMENTS
ANNUALLY ALL OTHER SCHOOLS ARE
WITH THE QUARTERS.
OF SCHOOLS MONITORED EVERY YEAR
ADDITIONALLY RECENT DATA
COLLECTED BY THE SEA.
AT CTC SHOWS THAT IN AT LEAST
ONE SCHOOL DISTRICT SCHOOLS
MISMANAGED MORE THAN HALF.
MRS SIGN MORE THAN HALF OF
TEACHERS IN CORE COURSES IN
COLLEGE PREPARATORY COURSES AND
IN HALF OF THOSE MISSED
ASSIGNMENTS HALF OF THE TEACHERS
HELD IN ADULT EDUCATION
CREDENTIAL.
WOULD REQUIRES NO EDUCATION
BEYOND A HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA.
AB TWELVE OF NINETEEN OPPOSED TO
RIGHT OF EVERY STUDENT TO A
QUALIFIED TEACHER BY AUTHORIZING
THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING TO UTILIZE
EXISTING FUNDS TO MONITOR ALL
FUTURE ASSIGNMENTS AND ALL
SCHOOLS THROUGH AN AUTOMATED
DATA SYSTEM.
THIS BILL ALSO REQUIRED THAT
TEACHER MRS SIMON INFORMATION IS
POSTED ON THE COMMISSION'S
WEBSITE.
MEMBERS AB TWELVE NINETEEN WILL
PROVIDE ADVOCATES AND LAWMAKERS
THE ABILITY TO HOLD SCHOOLS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR FAILING TO
PROVIDE STUDENTS WITH A QUALITY
EDUCATION STUDENTS ARE
GUARANTEED UNDER OUR STATE
CONSTITUTION.
WITH ME TODAY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE IS JOSH
SPEAKS WITH THE COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALS MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IAGO.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
VERSE I AM JUST FOR SPEAKS
LEGISLATIVE MANAGER MANAGER FOR
THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING WHERE THE SPONSORS
OF THIS BILL.
AB TWELVE NINETEEN WILL HELP
AUTOMATE THE STATE'S ANNUAL
ASSIGNMENT MONITORING PROCESS
ALLOWING US TO EXAMINE ALL
SCHOOLS ANNUALLY -- THIS ANNUAL
MONITORING IS NECESSARY TO
COMPLY WITH FEDERAL REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AND TO PROVIDE
GREATER TRANSPARENCY IN THE
TEACHER ASSIGNMENTS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE PUBLIC
ACROSS THE STATE.
I'M -- HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
THANK YOU ANY OTHERS.
ITEMS ARE WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATES
IN SUPPORT.
ISABEL GARCIA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WE'RE WORKING NOT A FORMAL
SUPPORT WE WE WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS AND THE
COMMITTEE -- WHERE WE SUPPORT
AND YOU WON'T MONITORING OF OF
AS TEACHERS SEGMENTS THANK YOU?
THANK YOU -- ANY OPPOSITION.
GOOD EVENING -- COLIN MILLER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER
SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION -- WE DON'T
HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION ON THE
BILL -- BECAUSE WE'RE SPAWNING
TO THE AMENDMENTS THEMSELVES --
WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS MR IS
CONCERNED WITH THE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENT ON PAGE SIXTEEN OF THE
ANALYSIS IT APPEARS INTENDED TO
A ROAD AND ELIMINATE THE OR
POTENTIALLY ELIMINATE THE
FLEXIBILITY FOR CHARTER SCHOOL
TEACHERS -- IN RELATION TO THEIR
CREDENTIAL AND NON COR NON
COLLEGE PREP COURSES -- THE
CURRENT ID FLEXIBILITY IS A
CRITICAL ELEMENT OF CHARTER
SCHOOL OUTCOME DRIVEN
ACCOUNTABILITY IT'S USED
COMMONLY IN -- IN -- CHARTER
SCHOOLS IN ARTS PROGRAMS
TECHNOLOGY FOCUS SCHOOLS AND
OTHER STEAM AND CITY SCHOOLS
THAT ENGAGE WORKING
PROFESSIONALS EXPERTS AND
ACADEMICS. TO SUPPLEMENT THE
CORE PROGRAM OF THE SCHOOL WITH
REAL LIFE AND CURRENT EXPERIENCE.
ELIMINATING OR CHANGING THIS
OPPORTUNITY WITHOUT REGARD TO
THE SUCCESS OF THE PROGRAM OR
THE STUDENT OUTCOMES ARE
ACHIEVED BY THESE TEACHERS --
WOULD JEOPARDIZE MANY SUCCESSFUL
SCHOOLS AND THE ENGAGEMENT OF
RICK MANY SUCCESSFUL TEACHERS SO
WE REQUEST -- COULD --
CLARIFICATION ON THAT AMENDMENT --
TO INSURE THAT EXISTING
FLEXIBILITY NON CORE COURSES IS
RETAINED THANK YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU JUST FOR THE
RECORD I BELIEVE IT IS THE
COMMITTEE POSITION THAT YOU
ACTUALLY DO NOT HAVE THAT
FLEXIBILITY CHARTER SCHOOLS DO
NOT HAVE THAT FLEXIBILITY IN
FACT THAT FLEXIBILITY WAS MEANT.
FOR FOR GUEST SPEAKERS AND
THINGS ALIKE BUT NOT FOR
TEACHERS IN THE CLASSROOM EVERY
DAY -- WITH THAT I SEE NO OTHER
OPPOSITION OVER YOU BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY COMMENT SAYING NO
COMMENT -- THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS YOU
MAY CLOSE.
PERSPECTIVE AS RELIABLE.
THANK YOU -- PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL -- THEN MOVED AND SECONDED
SORRY.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL AYE
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY KALRA.
KALRA I'D MCCARTY SMITH SMITH I
WEBER. TWO BILLS ON CALL HAS
THREE VOTES.
THANK YOU GIVE ME SOME MORE
MEMBERS HERE MISTER SO JONES
AROUND ABOUT.
NOBODY WANTS TO BE HERE -- YEAH
I WILL GO TO MISTER --
MISLEADING -- MISTER NAZARIAN
WITH THE WAITING OUT THERE FOR
EVER [inaudible] ONE AND WE'RE
GONNA.
THIS IS VEGAN MALE.
PLANT BASED.
PLAN BASED SO I REALLY THINK YOU
KNOW WHEN I FIRST SAW THIS BILL
I REALLY HAD A BEEF.
WELL -- I'M GLAD YOU DID WAS IT
MADE OUT OF SOY.
YOU'VE YOU'VE MOVED A LOT.
AND WE CHANGE THE BILL AND MUCH
MORE CODDLE.
WE LIKE THOSE TO BALANCE IT'S
ALL ABOUT BALANCE.
SO WITH THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR HUMOR MISTER CHAIR AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
THANK YOU TO ALL THE MEMBERS FOR
YOUR PATIENCE.
I THINK THIS IS JUST THE START
OF THE MARATHON COMING UP NEXT
WEEK AS WELL -- I JUST WANT TO
TAKE A MOMENT AND FOR SO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE
WONDERFUL WORK THAT THEY'VE DONE
ON THIS BILL AND THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AS WELL -- I DO --
I DO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND THANK YOU FOR THE
WORK ON THIS -- A BEFORE SEVENTY
NINE SETS A FRAMEWORK FOR PUBLIC
KEY THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS -- TO
RECEIVE ADDITIONAL STATE FUNDING
TO SUPPORT SERVING PLANT BASED
FOOD AND BEVERAGE CHOICES THE
BILL WOULD SET UP A PROGRAM
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION FOR SCHOOLS TO APPLY
FOR REIMBURSEMENT.
IF THEY SERVE AN INCREASED
NUMBER OF PLANT BASED OPTIONS
FROM A BASELINE YEAR -- THIS ACT
WILL ACCOMPLISH THE FOLLOWING
THREE THINGS ONE ASSISTS SCHOOLS
TO EXPAND THEIR AVAILABLE FOOD
AND BEVERAGE THAT EXPAND THEIR
AVAILABLE FOOD AND BEVERAGE
CHOICES TO IMPROVE ACCESS TO
HEALTHY PLANT BASED OPTIONS FOR
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES.
AND THREE ACCOMMODATE STUDENTS
WITH RELIGIOUS AND CULTURAL
NEEDS. TO BE CLEAR A BEFORE
SEVEN NINE DOES NOT TELL SCHOOLS
TO STOP SERVING MEAT OR DAIRY
AND WITH THAT -- WITH ME I HAVE
MY WONDERFUL COLLEAGUE AND JOINT
AUTHORED ASSEMBLY MEMBER ASH
KALRA.
WHO WILL BE FOLLOWED BY A KERRY
HAMMER SLUG FROM FRIENDS OF THE
EARTH AND MIGUEL?
THE LADY OUT FROM A DIRECTOR OF
FOOD AND NATURAL SERVICES AT THE
NEVADA UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
THANK YOU FOR INDULGING SNAKE IS
HE GOING TO SPEAKERS YOU JUST
HAVING A MEET.
TO HELLO.
RAMOS IS HERE.
BRIEFLY FOR ME SORRY TO MY
ANIMAL FRIENDS WERE JUST HAVING
A LITTLE HUMOR.
YES WE DON'T MEAN IT YEAH.
I I I DO WANT -- TO BOOK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING ME TO
COPE PRESENT AND I REALLY WANT
TO THANK ASSEMBLY NAZARIAN FIRST
LEADERSHIP ON EIGHTY FOUR SEVEN
NINE THIS IS AN IMPORTANT STEP
IN HELPING TO TAKE.
STEPS TO PRESERVE AND PROTECT
THE ENVIRONMENT COMBAT CLIMATE
CHANGE PROVIDE FOR THE HEALTH
AND WELL BEING OF ALL PEOPLE AND
SHOWING COMPASSION TO SUPPORTING
THE HUMANE TREATMENT OF ANIMALS
AND AS MANY EVEN ARE GOING ABOUT
A RESEARCH HAS DEMONSTRATED --
THE HEALTH ENVIRONMENTAL YOU MAY
BENEFITS A PLANT BASED DIET.
INSTITUTIONS AS THE MASTER
NATIONAL INSTITUTES OF HEALTH
PUBLIC HEALTH ORGANIZATIONS IN
COLLEGES UNIVERSITIES REGULARLY
EXTOL THE VIRTUES AND BENEFITS
OF A PLANT BASED DIET AND THE
BENEFITS PRESENTS MEDICALLY
SOCIETALLY ENVIRONMENTALLY.
PLANT BASED DYES HAVE BEEN
PROVEN TO HELP LOWER CHOLESTEROL
INCREASE CONSUMPTION OF FIBER
AND NATURALLY OCCURRING VITAMINS
MINERALS.
HELLO THE REST OF CANCER HEART
DISEASE DIABETES AND OTHER
CHRONIC HEALTH CONDITIONS AND
UNFORTUNATELY AS WE KNOW THE
JUVENILE DIABETES.
IS AN EPIDEMIC IN OUR NATION AND
WHETHER IT REFERS TO A
SPECIFICALLY ARE NOT IN THE BILL
WE DO KNOW THAT AB FORTY SEVEN
FOUR SEVEN NINE WILL CERTAINLY
HELP US IMPROVE OUR EFFORTS TO
PROTECT.
AND PRESERVE THE ENVIRONMENT BY
REDUCING OUR IMPACT ON
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS IMPROVE
WATER CONSERVATION AND REDUCE
HABITAT.
DEGRADATION AND DEFORESTATION --
AND FINALLY ALLOWED THAT
INCREASED PLANT BASED FOOD
PRODUCTION CAN HELP TO IMPROVE
THE WORLD'S ABILITY TO MEET
FUTURE FOOD SUPPLY DEMANDS.
AND SO AGAIN ONCE AGAIN THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR EYES I
CERTAINLY HOPE THAT THIS IS --
SOMETHING THAT THE ENTIRE
ASSEMBLY CAN GET BEHIND I HOPE
YOU'LL JOIN ME SUPPORT THE
MEASURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- YOUR FIRST WITNESS
THANK YOU -- I'M PARTY.
O'DONNELL AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M CURRY HUMMERS
FLOCK AND ON BEHALF OF FRIENDS
OF THE EARTH AND ARE MORE THAN
HUNDRED NINETY THOUSAND
SUPPORTERS.
IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPRESS OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR A BI FOR
SEVENTY NINE AND THE CREATION OF
THE PLANT BASED SCHOOL FOOD
PROGRAM.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NAZARIAN FOR ENJOYING AUTHOR
KALRA FOR INTRODUCING THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION THAT WILL
HELP IMPROVE KIDS HEALTH AND
REDUCE CALIFORNIA'S CARBON WATER
FOOTPRINT.
WE ARE PLEASED TO JOIN MORE THAN
SIXTY EDUCATIONAL PUBLIC HEALTH
ENVIRONMENTAL LABOR AND ANIMAL
PROTECTION ORGANIZATIONS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
WILL PROVIDE INCENTIVES IN STAFF
TRAINING TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
HEALTHY CLIMATE FRIENDLY PLANT
BASED FOOD OPTIONS ON THE PLATES
OF NEARLY FOUR MILLION LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
AT LEAST TEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND LEADING EDUCATIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS IN THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL BOARDS
HAVE WRITTEN IN SUPPORT OF THIS
IMPORTANT BILL.
DESPITE THE BEST EFFORTS OF
SCHOOL FOOD DIRECTORS CALIFORNIA
KIDS ARE OFTEN SERVED HEAVILY
SUBSIDIZED HIGHLY PROCESSED
INDUSTRIALLY PRODUCED ANIMAL
PRODUCT ANIMAL FOODS THAT ARE
UNHEALTHY FOR PEOPLE AND THE
PLANET.
AND WHILE WE ARE NOT ADVOCATING
CUTTING MEAT OR DAIRY ALTOGETHER
WE BELIEVE THAT ALL KIDS DESERVE
ACCESS TO HEALTH YOUR ALTERNATE
ALTERNATIVES ESPECIALLY SINCE.
EXCESSIVE CONSUMPTION OF THESE
WATER AND CARBON INTENSIVE FOODS
LEADS TO HIGHER RATES OF COSTLY
AND DEBILITATING HEALTH PROBLEMS
LIKE OBESITY.
HEART DISEASE AND TYPE TWO
DIABETES.
EVEN THE THE USTA'S 200-420-0015
DIETARY GUIDELINES FOR AMERICANS
EXPLICITLY RECOMMEND THAT.
TEENAGE BOYS AND MEN REDUCE
THEIR OVERALL INTAKE OF MEAT AND
NOTE THAT MOST CHILDREN ARE NOT
EATING NEARLY ENOUGH VEGETABLES
AND OTHER PLANT BASED FOODS
INCLUDING PROTEIN RICH -- NUTS
AND LEGUMES.
SO IN CONCLUSION BY CAN'T BY
ENCOURAGING CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS
TO MAKE MORE OF THE FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION LUNCHES ARE SERVED
EVERYDAY PLANT BASED THIS BILL
WILL MEASURABLY REDUCE THE
STATE'S FOOD FOOD RELATED
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
OR PROTECTING AMERICA'S VALUABLE
NATURAL RESOURCES ESPECIALLY OUR
WATER -- AND IT WILL ALSO
IMPROVE OUR RESIDENTS HEALTH FOR
GENERATIONS TO COME WHILE
SUPPORTING THE STATE'S MANY
PLANT BASED FOOD PRODUCERS.
SO WE URGE YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS THANK YOU.
AND AS THE MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS MIGUEL THE AREA.
I'M INTERESTED US.
AND I SPENT THE LAST THIRTY FIVE
YEARS OPERATING SCHOOL FOOD
SERVICE OPERATIONS BOTH IN
CALIFORNIA AND TEXAS.
INCLUDING THE LAST SIXTEEN YEARS
AS A SCHOOL FOOD SERVICE
DIRECTOR IN THE NEVADA UNIFIED
SCHOOL THIS DISTRICT.
TODAY EVERY DIETITIAN PRINCIPAL
TEACHER AND PARENT KNOW THAT FOR
A CHILD TO EXCEL IN TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY LEARNING AND THRIVE
IN THE CLASSROOM CHILDREN MUST
FIRST BE PROPERLY NOURISHED.
I'VE SEEN DIRECTLY THE ILL
EFFECTS OF HIGHLY PROCESSED
FOODS AND KIDS AND I SUPPORT A.
B. FOUR SEVEN NINE BECAUSE IT
WILL INCREASE THE ACCESS TO
HEALTHY PRESS PLANT BASED FOODS.
FOR ALL CHILDREN. TWENTY THREE A
MEALS ARE RICH IN HEART HEALTHY
FIBER LOW IN SATURATED FAT AND
CHOLESTEROL EATING A DIET DIET
RICH IN PLANT BASED FOODS.
LOWERS CHILDREN'S LONG TERM RISK
FOR HEALTH PROBLEMS LIKE.
WE'VE HEARD HEART DISEASE TYPE
TWO DIABETES AND OBESITY.
IS TRULY A MATTER OF EQUITY.
IN FOOD JUSTICE.
EVERY CHILD DESERVES ACCESS TO
HEALTHY PLANT BASED FOODS THAT
ARE MINIMALLY PROCESSED.
MANY OF US IN SCHOOL FOOD
SERVICE ARE DOING THE VERY BEST
WE CAN PRY CHILDREN WITH
HEALTHIER FOODS HOWEVER IT'S IT
IS DIFFICULT FOR SCHOOLS TO
OFFER PLAN MAYES MEALS.
BECAUSE OF THE ADDED EXPENSES
PLAN BASED BILLS INCREASE COSTS
IN FIVE MAJOR AREAS FIRST.
FOOD COSTS ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE
BUYING PRE MAY PRODUCT OF THAT
ARE HEAVILY SUBSIDIZED TO FOOD
PREPARATION IN MY LABOR THAT IT
TAKES THREE FOOD SERVICE
TRAINING.
STAFF TRAINING -- AND FOR
REFRIGERATION STORAGE FOR PLANT
BASED FOODS AND OF COURSE FIVE
MARKETING AND EDUCATION FOR
STUDENTS -- EACH OF THESE BROUGH
MUST WORK IN TANDEM TO HAVE A
SUCCESSFUL PLANT BASED MEAL
PROGRAM.
I ALSO THE ONLY TO TELL ANY OF
YOU HOW DIFFICULT IS IT IS TO
GET CHILDREN TO EAT MORE VEGGIES.
MY AND MY SCHOOL DISTRICT ALONE --
MORE MORE STUDENTS ARE EATING
VEGETABLES IMPLANT BE SIGNED.
UP ITEMS OF FOOD ITEMS LIKE
SPINACH SALADS KILL SELL ITS
HOMELESS -- BROADLY BEANS VEGGIE
BURGERS ALL BECAUSE OF A
CULINARY NUTRITION EDUCATION
CLASSES AT ENGAGE OVER THIRTY
FIVE HUNDRED KIDS PER SEMESTER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU KNOW WHAT IS
THE ONE LAST THOUGHT I'VE BEEN
DOING THIS IS YOU KNOW A LONG
TIME -- TEACHERS TODAY ARE
TELLING ME MCGILL IF YOU'RE NOT
DOING WHAT YOU'RE DOING WE CAN
DO WE DO IN THE CLASSROOM THANK
YOU.
I THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT COME DOWN A
MICROPHONE SO YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL ONLY PLEASE.
JACKIE DAY FORMER HIGH SCHOOL
HEALTH TEACHER AND LOS ANGELES
COUNTY TEACHER OF THE YEAR I AM
VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT SEEING NO
OTHERS IN SUPPORT HI I'M IN
SUPPORT LISA CARLIN FROM
THOUSAND OAKS CALIFORNIA I
REPRESENT PIECE FOR ANIMALS I AM
IN STRONG SUPPORT [inaudible]
VERY EFFECTIVE.
CARLOS THE CHILD WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
CAPTION MISTER CHAIR JENNIFER
FANG ON BEHALF OF THE CENTER FOR
FOOD SAFETY AND SUPPORT.
NICHOLAS SACKETT SOCIAL QUESTION
LEGISLATION PROD CO SPONSOR IN
SUPPORT.
MADDIE KRASNO ON BEHALF OF FARM
SANCTUARY IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
THERESA BROKERAGE ON BEHALF OF
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
MICHAEL IN SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA WE SUPPORT THIS BILL
AN URGENT AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
HE'S YOU DO IT ALL ON BEHALF OF
IN DEFENSE OF ANIMALS WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
BROWN WRAPPER ME HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT AND SOMEONE
WHO HAS A NEAT RED MEAT FORTY
TWO YEARS.
ELIZABETH BONTA BACK THE
CALIFORNIA FOOD AND FARMING
NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
VERONICA RAF KIND OF BEHALF OF
ANIMAL HOPING LEGISLATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
MARCHING ANIMAL OPEN LEGISLATION
AND A FATHER OF A SEVEN YEAR OLD
CHILD IS ANY MEAT.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
VIDEO BORN REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU -- ANY OPPOSITION.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE -- WE
JUST AN OLD FIELD ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS WESTERN
NINETY MIN TODAY. ONE I THINK
THAT THE CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE
AS WELL AS THE AUTHOR. FOR
WORKING WITH US ON AMENDMENTS TO
THIS BILL -- AND AND AT THIS
POINT WOULD LIKE TO REMOVE
OPPOSITION THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU -- SEEING NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION OR OPPOSITION -- WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE --
ALL JUST KNOW MISTER NAZARIAN
I'M GOING TO WATCH WHAT YOU EAT.
IN THE LOUNGE.
AND IT'LL BE INTERESTING I DO
HOPE YOU DO LIVE UP TO YOUR YOUR
YOUR BILLS -- BUT EITHER WAY
WITH THAT -- ANY COMMENT IS MISS
SMITH SHE'S A BIG.
YEAH AND THE MOTHER TO
VEGETARIANS WHO HAS STRUGGLED AS
A MOM TO FEED MY KIDS OVER THE
YEARS PARTICULARLY AT SCHOOL I I
WISH WE'D GONE THERE WHEN THEY
WERE YOUNGER BUT I'M GLAD WE'RE
DOING IT NOW.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR SAYING NO FURTHER
COMMENT THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS -- YOU
MAY CLOSE -- I THINK I THINK
THIS CHRISTY SMITH ACTUALLY DID
THE BEST JOB IN AND CLOSING FOR
ME BUT I'LL JUST SAY THIS AS YOU
CAN TELL.
FROM LOOKING AT ME I HAVE NOT
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST ANY TYPE
OF FOOD OVER MY LIFETIME -- I I
ENJOY ALL TYPES OF FOODS AND AND
I REVEL IN THAT AND AND AND IT'S
NOT I HAVE NOT STOPPED EATING
MEAT MYSELF BUT THIS IS ABOUT.
PROPORTION AND IT'S ABOUT CHOICE
AND IT'S ABOUT ESPECIALLY IN TWO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT WE FIND --
SOME OF THE MOST STRUGGLING
FAMILIES AND STUDENTS TO HAVE
THE BENEFIT OF KNOWING.
OF AN ALTERNATIVE PATH OF
STAYING HEALTHY AND GETTING
NUTRITION AND GETTING INTO THE
RIGHT HABITS AT AN EARLY AGE --
ANYONE TO MAKE THE CONVERSATION
TO SERIOUS BY SAYING THAT BUT
BUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
INDULGENCE THANK YOU FOR THE
SUPPORT.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE.
THE THE BILL'S GOING MOVE I MISS
SMITH SECONDED BY MISTER MCCARTY --
AGAIN THE MOTIONS YOU PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
O'DONNELL O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING.
KALRA COLOR I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE SMITH SMITH I WEBER.
THE BILL HAS FOR ROAD SO IT IS
OUT.
THANK YOU.
NIKKI.
I WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO MESS Là M<c.cyan> SHE'S HEARING</c>
THIS LOAN HAS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
OR I DON'T KNOW.
DO WE KNOW SHE HAS.
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FOURTEEN IT'S AB.
EIGHT FOUR TWO THANK YOU MEMBERS
AND CHAIR I WANTED TO START BY
ACCEPTING OF THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND THINKING YOU AND
YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING ON AB.
EIGHT FOUR TWO ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT FOUR TWO DOES TWO
IMPORTANT THINGS ONE INSURERS TO
ALL ELIGIBLE LOW INCOME PUBLIC
SCHOOL STUDENTS INCLUDING OUR
YOUNGEST LEARNERS ARE GUARANTEED
ACCESS TO NUTRITIOUS.
FREE OR LOW COST MEAL DURING
EACH PROGRAM DAY WHILE ATTENDING
PRESCHOOL OR CHILD CARE AT A
PUBLIC SCHOOL OR CALIFORNIA
STATE PRESCHOOL.
PROGRAM TO EXPAND STATE
SUPPLEMENTAL MEAL FUNDING TO
HELP PRESCHOOL AND CHILDCARE
PROVIDERS.
BUT PUTTING HEALTHY MEALS ON THE
TABLE FOR LOW INCOME CHILDREN
STUDENTS TO SHOW UP AT TO SCHOOL
HUNGRY FOR LACK OF FOOD AT HOME
STRUGGLE TO PAY ATTENTION IN
CLASS AND QUICKLY FALL BEHIND
THEIR PEERS.
HUNGER CAN DISADVANTAGED CHILD
EARLY EVEN BEFORE THEY HAVE
ENTERED GRADE SCHOOL THEREFORE
IT MAKES SENSE TO PREVENT HUNGER
WHILE CHILDREN ARE YOUNG AND
RAPIDLY DEVELOPING I HAVE WITH
ME TODAY MELISSA CAN IN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA.
FOOD POLICY ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
CALIFORNIA FOOD POLICY ADVOCATES --
WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MOANS LEADERSHIP
ON THIS ISSUE -- SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE CALIFORNIA HAS
GUARANTEED ACCESS TO A FREE OR
LOW COST MEAL FOR ALL
KINDERGARTEN THROUGH TWELFTH
GRADE PUBLIC SCHOOL STUDENTS
TODAY.
IT IS OUR LOW INCOME
PRESCHOOLERS AND CHILDREN IN
CHILD CARE AT A PUBLIC SCHOOL
THAT ARE NOT GUARANTEED ACCESS
AND ALTHOUGH THE MAJORITY OF
PUBLICSCHOOLS ARE MAKING DEALS
AVAILABLE UNFORTUNATELY THERE
ARE SOME THAT ARE NOT -- WHAT AB
EIGHT FORTY TWO WOULD DO WOULD
PROVIDE THAT GUARANTEED ACCESS
TO ALL OF OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL
STUDENTS AND IT WOULD ALSO
PROVIDE?
THOSE FINANCIAL RESOURCES --
ACCESS TO THEM FOR ALL OF OUR
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS IN
PRESCHOOL PROVIDERS -- WHO SERVE
LOW INCOME CHILDREN THROUGH THE
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM AND IN
OTHER FORMS OF CHILD CARE HERE
WITHIN CALIFORNIA?
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
CUT OFF RIGHT THERE.
GOOD OF THE ONE OF OUR KENNEDY
PEDIATRICS AND SUPPORT.
CALIFORNIA FOOD BANK ASSOCIATION
INSTRUCTS APART.
RIVER NOW DIRECTOR EDUCATIONAL
CATHOLIC CHURCH IN SUPPORT.
JAMIE MORGAN WITH THE AMERICAN
HEART ASSOCIATION IT'S PART.
ELIZABETH BOND CALIFORNIA FIT IN
VERY NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
TRISTEN BROWN FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEN OPPOSITIONAL BRING BACK
PRETTY COMMITTEE COMMENT SINGLE
COMMITTEE COMMENT -- IS THERE A
MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND I'LL SECOND
THE BILL -- THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS YOU MAY CLOSE.
I RESPECT THE ASPIRIN I HAVE A
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY I'D KALRA.
KALRA I MCCARTY.
SMITH SMITH I WEBER. FOR THEM IT
HAS. THREE VOTES FOR THE THOUGH
THERE'S FOUR THERE'S FOUR APPLES
AS WELL AS FOR VOTE SO IT IS UP.
WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA MOVE.
TO MISS SMITH IS GOING TO
PRESENT TO BILLS.
ARE THESE LAST TWO TWENTY YEAH
THIS IS THESE ARE LAST TWO BILLS
SO IF THERE'S ANY MEMBERS IN THE
CAPITAL THEY MIGHT WANT TO HEAD
BACK -- AGAIN -- SHE'S GOING TO
PRESENT -- BELIEVE AB NINETEEN
NINE EIGHTEEN FIRST EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN FIRST NINETEEN WILL BE
FIRST I MISS SMITH AS A FILE
ITEM NUMBER.
SIXTEEN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AS WE GO INTO EXTRA
INNINGS HERE -- WE KNOW BECAUSE
WE HEARD SUCH RIVETING TESTIMONY
EARLIER THIS SESSION -- FROM OUR
OUR FRIENDS IN PARADISE ABOUT
WHAT THEY'RE COMMUNITY WENT
THROUGH AND SPECIFICALLY THEIR
SCHOOL COMMUNITY -- WITH THE
RECENT TRAGEDIES -- AND
WILDFIRES THERE I SERVICES
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER THROUGH A
SERIES OF DEVASTATING
EMERGENCIES IN MY DISTRICT
INCLUDING -- MASSIVE SCHOOL
EVACUATIONS AND MY COMMUNITY HAS
EXPERIENCED ENVIRONMENTAL
DISASTERS -- AT THE SHOOTING --
AT A LOCAL NIGHTCLUB AN
INCREDIBLY DESTRUCTIVE FIRE ALL
IN THE SPAN OF JUST A FEW YEARS
AND I THINK WHAT WE'VE ALL
LEARNED FROM THIS EXPERIENCE IS
THAT WE NEED KEY PERSONNEL TO BE
AVAILABLE IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING
A NATURAL DISASTER.
OR OTHER SIGNIFICANT EVENT.
STUDENTS THAT HAVE LIVED THROUGH
EMERGENCIES NEED OUR HELP TO
WORK THROUGH THEIR TRAUMA FIRST
SO THEY CAN HEAL AND THEN RETURN
TO BEING STUDENTS IN THEIR
ACADEMIC PROGRAMS.
ALTHOUGH THE IMPACT TO STUDENTS
IS GREAT SCHOOL PERSONNEL ARE
ALSO IMPACTED BY THESE TRAGEDIES.
IN ORDER TO BEST SERVE THEIR
STUDENTS SCHOOL LEADERS ALSO
BENEFIT FROM BEHAVIORAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORTS TARGETED
TO THEIR UNIQUE NEEDS AND ROLES
IN THE SCHOOL COMMUNITY.
UNFORTUNATELY WILD FIRES AND
OTHER NATURAL DISASTERS OUR NEW
NORMAL IN OUR STATE.
IT IS MY GOAL THAT WITH THE
PASSAGE OF AB NINE EIGHTEEN AND
THE RECOMMENDATIONS DEVELOPED BY
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION SCHOOLS WILL HAVE
GREATER ACCESS TO EXISTING
PERSONAL RESOURCES TO RECOVER
FROM THESE DRAMATIC EVENTS.
THANK YOU.
IS YOUR YOUR WITNESS.
STAFF OH OKAY WE'RE MORE READY
TO GO OKAY.
EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE ARE
THERE OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
JERRY FROM IN DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT -- ANY
OPPOSITION.
SEEN OPPOSITIONAL BRING BACK ANY
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBER SINGLE COMES FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS I WILL MOVE IT.
AND MR KILEY WAS SECOND -- YOU
MAY CLOSE I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
SMITH.
HI SMITH I WEBER.
THANK YOU SO THE BILL HAS THREE
SO IT IS ON CALL.
AND WE'RE NOW ON OUR LAST BILLS
OF THEIR MEMBERS IN THE BUILDING
THEY SHOULD HEAD THIS WAY
BECAUSE WILL BE CLOSING THINGS
OUT VERY SHORTLY -- MISS SMITH
HAS.
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY FIVE AB -- TWELVE THIRTY
THREE YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ADD TO BEGIN I'M HAPPY
TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS ON THIS
MEASURE AND I PARTICULARLY LIKE
TO THINK OF THE COMMITTEE AND
THE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS MEMBERS
AND STAFF AS WELL FOR THEIR
THOUGHTFUL.
CONSIDERATION IN ADDING TO THIS
BILL.
THE AP EXAM NOT ONLY PROVIDE
STUDENTS WITH WAYS TO BOLSTER
THEIR COLLEGE RESUMES IT ALSO
ALLOWS THEM TO BY PASS
REMEDIATION AND GRADUATE EARLIER
FROM COLLEGE WITH SMALLER
AMOUNTS OF DEBT.
CURRENTLY EXAM FEES ARE NINETY
FOUR DOLLARS PER TEST WHICH CAN
ADD UP QUICKLY TO A PROHIBITIVE
COST EVEN IN JUST ONE YEAR OF A
STUDENT'S EDUCATION.
THIS IS TRULY AN EQUITY ISSUE IF
WE ARE SERIOUS AND OUR
COMMITMENT TO ELIMINATING THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP ACCESS TO
RIGOROUS COURSEWORK MUST BE
BARRIER FREE FOR EVERY STUDENT.
AB TWELVE THIRTY THREE WOULD
ESTABLISH THE CALIFORNIA
ADVANCED PLACEMENT EQUITY
PROGRAM TO ENSURE THAT LOW
INCOME HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS HAVE
ACCESS TO AP EXAMS BY PROVIDING
GRANTS TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
REDUCE THE EXAM FEE TO FIVE
DOLLARS FOR ELIGIBLE STUDENTS.
THE GRANT PROGRAM WOULD BE
ADMINISTERED BY THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
AP EXAM FUNDING EVENS THE
PLAYING FIELD FOR ALL STUDENTS
AND PROMOTES GREATER ACCESS TO
HIGHER EDUCATION FOR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENT POPULATION.
WITH ME TODAY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL ARE RACHEL
LEWIS RACHEL'S AN A. P.
LITERATURE TEACHER AT WESTERN
SIERRA COLLEGIATE ACADEMY.
A PUBLIC SCHOOL IN ROCKLIN
CALIFORNIA.
AND JORGE UGLY OUR
SUPERINTENDENT OF SACRAMENTO
CITY UNIFIED SCHOOLS THE
THIRTEENTH LARGEST SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN CALIFORNIA.
SUPERINTENDENT OUT WE ARE HAS
MORE THAN TWENTY YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE IN K. TWELVE AND
HIGHER EDUCATION WITH A STRONG
FOCUS IN BACKGROUND ON ISSUES OF
EQUITY AND STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT.
PRIOR TO SERVING AS
SUPERINTENDENT MISTER AGUILAR
WAS ASSOCIATE SUPERINTENDENT FOR
EQUITY IN ACCESS AT FRESNO
UNIFIED HE ALSO PREVIOUSLY
SERVED AS ASSOCIATE VICE CHANCE
CHANCELLOR OF THE EDUCATIONAL
AND COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS AT UC
MERCED.
TURN IT OVER TO MY WITNESSES YES.
GET.
OUT OKAY THANK YOU -- THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR HAVING ME TODAY.
HI MY NAME IS RACHEL LEWIS I'M
IN ADVANCED PLACEMENT ENGLISH
LITERATURE TEACHER AT WESTERN
SEER COLLEGIATE ACADEMY IN
ROCKLIN CALIFORNIA -- AS A
TEACHER AT A SCHOOL THAT MAKES
AP CLASSES ACCESSIBLE TO ALL
STUDENTS EVERY YEAR I SEE LOW
INCOME STUDENTS WHO FEEL LIKE
THEY DON'T BELONG BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T AFFORD TEST FEES.
I FIGHT THE BATTLE EVERY YEAR TO
LET STUDENTS KNOW THAT THEY ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR FINANCIAL SUPPORT
AND MAKE SURE THAT NO STUDENT IS
LEFT BEHIND IN THEIR PURSUIT OF
COLLEGE CREDIT.
I SUPPORT AB TWELVE THIRTY THREE
BECAUSE I KNOW HOW IMPORTANT AP
TESTS ARE FOR MY STUDENTS
ESPECIALLY LOW INCOME STUDENTS
WHO LOOK AT EIGHT P. TEST
PASSAGE AS A WAY TO SAVE MONEY
ON AND GAIN BETTER ACCESS TO
HIGHER EDUCATION.
BY REDUCING THE AP EXAM PETER
JUST FIVE DOLLARS FOR STUDENTS
TO QUALIFY STUDENTS THAT
OTHERWISE MIGHT BE LEFT BEHIND
ARE EMPOWERED TO PURSUE RIGOROUS
CLASSES TAKE CLASSES FOR COLLEGE
CREDIT AND EXPAND THEIR COLLEGE
PORTFOLIOS AHEAD OF APPLYING TO
HIGHER EDUCATION.
WHEN CALIFORNIA STUDENTS HAVE
ACCESS TO AP TESTS THEY DO WELL?
JUST LAST YEAR CALIFORNIA RANKED
FIFTH IN THE ENTIRE NATION FOR
HIGH ACHIEVING ADVANCED
PLACEMENT TEST SCORES AMONG
GRADUATING STUDENTS.
ACT IS WE MUST ENSURE THAT LOW
INCOME STUDENTS WILL CONTINUE TO
BE ABLE TO ACCESS A. P. EXAMS AT
A LOW PRICE SINCE STATE FUNDING
SOON EXPIRES AND FEDERAL FUNDING
HAS LEFT STUDENTS BEHIND.
THAT'S WHY TEACHERS LIKE ME
SUPPORT AB TWELVE THIRTY THREE
WE MUST CONTINUE TO ENCOURAGE
LOW INCOME STUDENTS TO
PARTICIPATE AT THE HIGHEST
ACADEMIC LEVELS POSSIBLE.
I URGE THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT AB TWELVE
THIRTY THREE TO PROMOTE EQUITY
AND OUR SCHOOLS AND MAKE A PEE
TEST MORE ACCESSIBLE FOR LOW
INCOME STUDENTS.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON WE ARE.
GOOD AFTERNOON LEE LANI I'M
GOING OUT ON BEHALF OF
SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT OBVIOUSLY I AM NOT HEY
I CAN LEARN.
I APOLOGIZE HE HAD HE WAS HERE
EARLIER AND HE HAD TO LEAVE HERE --
TODAY BUT I WILL BE PRESENTING
HIS STATEMENT SO ON BEHALF OF
COURSE YEAH KILLER AS
SUPERINTENDENT SACRAMENTO CITY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT WE
SUPPORT AB TWELVE THIRTY THREE
BECAUSE EVERY STUDENT SHOULD BE
ABLE TO TAKE THE ADVANCED
PLACEMENT TESTS REGARDLESS OF
THEIR INCOME OR SOCIO ECONOMIC
BACKGROUND.
AT SAKS CITY UNIFIED WE'RE
COMMITTED TO PROMOTING EQUITY IN
STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT.
THIS YEAR WE HAVE AUTOMATICALLY
REGISTERED EVERY STUDENT
ENROLLED IN AP COURSES TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE AP EXAM FOR
THAT COURSE THEN WE COVER THE
COSTS FOR EVERY STUDENT TO TAKE
THE AP EXAM.
WE ALONG WITH DOZENS OF OTHER
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN CALIFORNIA
ARE USING THE LAST BIT OF
COLLEGE READINESS BLOCK GRANT
FUNDS TO SET TO EXPIRE AT THIS
HERE.
AND WE SEE THE IMPACT THIS
INVESTMENT IS MAKING THIS YEAR
IN 1-718-300-0200 AND SIXTY
EXAMS RETAIN AP EXAMS WERE TAKEN
AND SEX CITY.
AND THE SCHOOL YEAR -- WE'RE ON
TRACK FOR FOUR THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINE A. P.
EXAMS THIS YEAR AND WE BELIEVE
IT'S BECAUSE OF THE INVESTMENT
WERE TO ME FOR MAKING THIS YEAR
FOR STUDENTS.
WE COVER THE COST FOR EVERY
STUDENT TO TAKE AP EXAMS BECAUSE
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THE A. P.
EXPERIENCE BENEFITS TEENS IN
SEVERAL IMPORTANT WAYS.
FIRST E. P. STUDENTS ARE MORE
LIKELY TO GRADUATE FROM COLLEGE
IN FOUR YEARS.
STUDENTS WHO TAKE LONGER TO
GRADUATE AT PUBLIC COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES CAN SPEND UP TO
NINETY NINETEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR EACH ADDITIONAL YEAR.
SECOND A. P. STUDENTS HELP CALL
AP EXAMS HELP STUDENTS QUALIFY
FOR SCHOLARSHIPS 31% OF COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES LOOK AT EIGHT
EIGHT P. EXPERIENCE WHEN
DETERMINING SCHOLARSHIPS.
AND FINALLY AP EXAM
PARTICIPATION IS A POSITIVE
INDICATOR TO COLLEGES DESPITE
THE EXAM SCORE WHEN STUDENTS
PARTICIPATE IN AP EXAMS COLLEGES
SEE THAT THEY ARE WILLING TO
CHALLENGE THEMSELVES.
SO WE CAN'T LEAVE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS BEHIND I
URGE THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT AB TWELVE
THIRTY THREE TO MAKE SURE LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIA STUDENTS CAN
CONTINUE TO ACCESS THESE
IMPORTANT TESTS THANK YOU.
WE GOT AROUND HALF OF LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT.
KYLA BEHALF OF THE ADDED CENTER
FRESNO UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN A CORONA NORCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JUST AROUND CALIFORNIA VOTERS IN
TEACHERS IN SUPPORT -- YEAH.
JUST WANT TO SAY I THINK IT'S A
GREAT IDEA REALLY GOOD BILL AND
I WANT TO THANK OUR WITH THIS
FROM WESTERN EUROPE WHICH
ACADEMY WHICH IS A GREAT SCHOOL.
TESTIFIED [inaudible]
KALRA SECOND -- EMOTION.
THE MOTION IS -- DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS YOU
MAY CLOSE AGAIN I APPRECIATE OUR
MEMBERS BY IN ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE ON THIS MATTER AND ON
BEHALF OF STUDENTS SEEKING
EQUITY IN OUR STATE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST ARRIVE A
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY KILEY AYE
KALRA.
KALRA I MCCARTY SMITH HI SMITH I
WEBER.
THE BILL HAS FOUR VOTES TO IT IS
OUT.
THE GRADUATION -- WITH THAT
WE'RE GOING -- TO GO BACK TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR [inaudible] TO
CLARIFY.
ARE YOUR ANNA YES WE'RE CLEAR
FOR THE MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR QUICKLY BEFORE WE DO --
BILLS ON CALL AN OUNCE.CONSENT CALENDAR FILE ITEM NINE
AB FIVE TWENTY FIVE TO PASS
THROUGH APPROPRIATIONS.
FILE ITEM TEN AB FIVE FORTY
THREE TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
HIGHER EDUCATION FILE ITEM
TWENTY EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY EIGHT
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE AB TEN
EIGHTY ONE TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS FILE ITEM TWENTY
TWO AB TEN EIGHTY FIVE TO PASS
TO HEALTH WITH AMENDMENTS TO BE
TAKEN AND HEALTH.
THANK YOU I WILL NOW GO -- TO
BILLS ON CALL.
SO WE NEED TO WORK WE NEED TO
WE'VE GOT ONE MEMBERS SO WHY
DON'T WE GO AHEAD -- MISTER
MCCARTY HERE AS WELL
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
THIS CALL.
SO WELL PLEASE REINSTATED THE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FOR THE
MEASURES ON CALL THIS IS FOR ON
CALL ONLY.
FILE ITEM ONE A. B. SIX THE
CHAIR VOTING HI KALRA.
KALRA I'D MCCARTY [inaudible]
MCCARTY I LOS VIVOS IT IS OUT
THERE IS FILE ITEM ONE FILE ITEM.
ONE BY ITEM TO AB SIXTEEN THE
CHAIR VOTING I'D KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA.
COLOR EYES MCCARTY.
MCCARTY HI WEBER.
WEBER I SIX FILE ITEM TWO IS OUT
WITH SIX VOTES.
FILE ITEM THREE AB ONE EIGHTY
TWO THE CHAIR VOTING I'D KILEY.
KILEY I'VE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I WEBER.
WEBER I FILE ITEM THREE EIGHTY
ONE EIGHTY TWO IS OUT WAS SIX
VOTES.
FILE ITEM FIVE AB TWO FIFTY
EIGHT THE CHAIR VOTING I KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE WEBER.
WEBER I I'M SORRY I WAS.
OKAY KILEY AYE WHICH AT WHICH A
FILE ON FILE ITEM FIVE AB TWO
FIFTY EIGHT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
EXPERTS.
THE BILLS OUT.
FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB SIX OH FIVE
THE CHAIR VOTING I KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE WEBER.
WEBER I THE BILL HAS FIVE VOTES
FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN EIGHTY
SIX OH FIVE IS OUT.
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN AB EIGHT FIFTY
TWO THE CHAIR VOTING I KILEY.
KILEY AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE WEBER.
WEBER I I'M ABLE TO SIX THE BILL
HAS SIX VOTE THE AB -- FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN AB EIGHT FIVE TWO IS HOW
SIX WORDS.
FILE ITEM SIXTEEN AB.
NINETEEN THE CHAIR VOTING I
KALRA.
KALRA I'VE MCCARTY.
CARTY AYE WEBER.
WEBER I FILE I'M SIXTEEN AB
NINETEEN IS OUT WAS SIX VOTES.
FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN A. B. --
NINE FORTY SEVEN O'DONNELL AYE
O'DONNELL AYE.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE MCCARTY.
I WEBER.
WEBER I THE BILL'S OUT -- AB --
FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN EIGHTY NINE
FORTY SEVEN THAT WAS SIX VOTES.
FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN AB.
NINE SIXTY SEVEN OTHER CHAIR
VOTING OUT.
AT THE CHAIR VOTING I KALRA.
KALRA I MCCARTY [inaudible]
THE I..
THE BILL -- IF ITEM EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY NINE SIX SEVEN SEVEN FIVE
VOTES.
FILE ITEM TWENTY FOUR AB EIGHT
TWELVE NINETEEN THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE AND WEBER.
WEBER I FILE ITEM TWENTY FOUR AB
TWELVE NINETEEN IS OUT WITH FOUR
VOTES. FIVE OAKS FIVE OAKS.
FILE ITEM TWENTY EIGHT AB
[inaudible]
FOURTEEN TEN O'DONNELL.
HI BUT ON ALIVE KILEY.
KILEY AYE.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE WEBER [inaudible]
EVER AYE.
FILE ITEM TWENTY EIGHT AB
FOURTEEN TENNIS I WAS SIX MONTHS.
THREE YES WE DID WE MISS
THIRTEEN IS [inaudible]
ONE OKAY [inaudible]
SORRY.
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AB SEVEN
SEVEN THREE THE CHAIR VOTING I'D.
KALRA.
KALRA I MCCARTY [inaudible]
I THE BILLS OUT OF FIVE VOTES.
THIS CONCLUDES THE BUSINESS OF
THIS COMMITTEE HEARING THIS
COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED